two panels with different perspectives
on book publishing and the 2004 vote
were held this week in new york during
the republican national convention
earlier we brought you the conservative
perspective which you can see again
tonight at midnight eastern now the
other side takes a critical look at
president bush
during this two-hour event you'll hear
from paul krugman sydney blumenthal joe
wilson joe connison and mark greene
[Applause]
[Music]
uh good evening and uh thank you welcome
to nyu's skirble theater
and welcome to the downtown uh version
of the bush administration's activities
that are being discussed uptown now
during the republican convention
[Applause]
i'm mark green the uh president of the
new democracy project and the co-author
with eric alterman
of one of the five books that has
inspired this panel the book on bush how
george w is misleading america and we
have also published uh this month a book
for those who want a positive vision of
what could come next
a book called what we stand for
a program for progressive patriotism by
newmarket press
um let's face it all political
conventions democrat or republican
are exercises in uh plastic surgery
we however have a different medical
mission we are going to hold up a mirror
to reality
we are going to engage in substance uh
not spin
because
all our distinguished panel have at
least one
thing one trait in common
all have written best-selling books
about what bush has done for or two
america and the world
i want to um
thank first the institutional co-hosts
of this evening here at nyu for uh
bringing you all here together tonight
uh first people for the american way
which is
hosting what's called they call the
unemployment line a symbolic
issue protest wednesday
and for those of you who want to get
involved you're allowed to go to
www.theunemploymentline.org and let me
introduce the
beautiful head of people from the
american way before the
politically correct police put me under
arrest she doubles as my wife a danny
fran
[Music]
also thank you
to the nation magazine and katrina
vandenheuvel true majority
[Applause]
the true majority and ben cohn and gary
ferdman the progressive book club
elizabeth wagley who has just created
that um and among the 800 or so of you
that are here allow me to selectively
just acknowledge four people and save
your applause until the end if you so
choose
um but i want to acknowledge former
assemblyman frank barbaro
president former president of nyu john
bradamus
bob greenwald who produced and directed
and showed outfoxed
and uncovered
i knew i should have saved until the end
uh but last and not least and i'll say
this as politically neutrally as i can
since this is a nonpartisan event
um my and our good friend peggy carey
would all stand up and say hello
thank you
um
each panelist
will speak up to 15 minutes
and then answer questions submitted on
three by five cards that you have and
will be passed down while i introduce
them uh later but just in the interest
of uh first things first please now
welcome and wait until i've introduced
all and there'll be more details
subsequently
paul krugman who wrote the great
unraveling resisted temptation
i i know it's hard it's hard for me
um
craig unger house of bush house of saud
sydney blumenthal the clinton wars and
joe wilson the politics of truth
[Applause]
[Music]
um uh let me kick it off and uh
this is a high-powered group for such a
low technology but this egg timer is
infallible and when it goes off
the group coercion is amazing
um
uh
bill o'reilly could not shut up paul
krugman on cnbc but this can
[Applause]
all presidents
to some extent
have
misled distorted disassembled
disinformed fibbed even lied
um
when they asked eisenhower after he had
served as a uh
uh nato commander and that i'm sorry the
head of world war ii and normandy and of
course a two-term president what he most
regretted he said quote the lie i had to
tell about the you too close quote
which was not a weather plane obviously
it was a spy plane over russia
uh john kennedy
according to robert dalek's informed
biography of him was not entirely candid
about his addison's disease when he was
running in 1960 and thereafter
i don't have to um lecture this audience
about lyndon johnson and richard nixon
on vietnam and watergate
but if but george bush george w bush is
different he is really historically very
very different
if the
breadth and volume of dissembling to use
the metaphor of the moment were an
olympic event he would win the gold the
silver and the bronze
and there wouldn't be any letter
afterward complaining about it
based on our uh eric's and my
two-year investigation we did find a
president
who day in and day out and issues large
and small again and again and again
wouldn't tell the truth
now
we wrote about and this is pretty easy
enrons can light lay did not endorse
anne richards for governor in 1994
source ken lay and ann richards
uh
for example
when bush said that in his
self-described great compromise on stem
cells look we have
60 stem cell lines to investigate
when we had 10
stem cell lines available
when he says that the recession began
under clinton
when according to of course the economic
arbiters of such things that began under
bush those are obviously untrue
statements
but now since the book was researched
and published now that nearly all
independent authorities
the bipartisan 911 panel the senate
intelligence report you name it
have corroborated the thesis that we are
being governed by a serial
dissembler uh we now know of course that
um
the president did get explicit warnings
that al qaeda plan to hijack airplanes
in the united states not outside but in
the united states we now know of course
that there was no collaborative
relationship between saddam hussein and
al qaeda
we now know
that our troops encountered neither
weapons of mass destruction thank god
nor cheering crowds
unfortunately uh we now know of course
that tax cuts were not greater as a
percentage term in percentage terms for
the middle class than the top uh one one
percent um in other words you could go
on and on but i i would ask critics who
say well they're all alike bush is no
different could you really write a 150
000 word book much less 12 books
about
truman's dissembling
about
uh bush 41's dissembling about bill
clinton's dissembling and in terms of
volume not intensity but volume forgive
me about richard nixon's dissembling so
bush is actually extremely impressive in
his breath to the point that he reminds
me of something abraham lincoln once
said of a rival who had such a high
regard for the truth that he used it
sparingly
how does bush accomplish this feat in
full public view it's not that easy uh
first basically he and cheney are the
leaders in what magicians understand is
misdirection
so they say now watch my left hand watch
my left hand and the hand behind
is doing the tricks and so the left hand
is constant repetition to turn
a lie into reality by saying it often
enough and before you think that's
circular and ridiculous how else did
seventy percent of americans come to
think that saddam hussein was behind 9
11.
second is just absurdly
misleading but unprovably misleading
rhetoric and metaphor i tell you i've
studied issues like this for a long time
i have never been so sickened
as when condoleezza rice and then george
w bush said in late 2002 in the build-up
to the war
but we got to make sure that the smoking
gun doesn't become a mushroom cloud
uh we meet today one mile north of what
were the world trade towers we don't
need any lecture
about how
plausibly anxious a city or a country
could be because of terrorism but when
you start using images of nuclear
catastrophe against someone who didn't
have it
couldn't deploy it and wasn't an
imminent threat you are literally being
a president chicken little to
misdirect and mislead people
third
[Applause]
and then there is certainty replacing
accuracy it is true that friends of mine
the clinton administration
and i'm told uh uh intelligence services
abroad made their best guess that saddam
hussein had weapons of mass destruction
but dick cheney said
we're absolutely certain he has them and
we know where they are
now that he's out of his undisclosed
location i
saw him on television uptown he should
probably let us know uh where they are
then there's ideological arithmetic
something uh paul krugman could write
seven columns a week on if he had the
time of the day um and so when uh the
bush people are criticized for having
built up these large deficits their
answer is well it's only three percent
of gdp half that of reagan
well that's true if you're not counting
the 169 billion dollars they pilfered
from the social security trust funds
which they said they would not do
and frankly to compare yourself with
deficits to reagan is like not a
valentine
um and finally there's just pure
bunk
i saw gloria berger on cnbc interviewed
dick cheney and she said three weeks ago
gee you said that muhammad ada one of
the hijackers
met in prague
with iraqi officials he said i never
said that for sure she said no no you
said that
and i watched dick cheney go i never
said that
there's this thing called tape
and she then showed the tape of him
saying
absolutely confidently
otto met with iraqi agents in prague
this is an imitation of the british
aphorism perhaps wrong but never in
doubt
but some people keep believing it um
whenever i do an interview on this
subject and i'm sure my colleagues are
the same uh interviewers can't wait to
say in their first question are you
calling bush a liar
apparently by the way i know what the
audience i can hear what the audience
thinks but
i have the mic
apparently
in public life it's worse to be called a
liar than to be one
based on the
an antagonistic edge in the question
well
the only honest answer to that question
is either he's misleading us
or himself
and neither is a pretty answer
we can't know for uh physical certainty
that what he's saying he knows to be
untrue
more likely
sadly
is that while most people certainly most
presidents weigh facts
and then it leads to conclusions
president bush is the exact opposite
he arrives at conclusions
which lead to facts
so where do the foregone conclusions
come from
politicians apparently like staying
close to their base however if any of
you can think of one example
where george w bush has initially broken
with the religious right
big energy
and neoconservatives abroad please
email us at the new democracyproject.org
because we couldn't find one example
president bush and his supporters uptown
like to say that he's courageous and
strong i frankly don't think it's
terribly strong or courageous to be a
dancing puppet to the religious right
big oil and neoconservatives
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the problem is not just a credibility
gap i tell you the strongest bush
supporter and half the country is split
would have to acknowledge that he
sometimes gets things wrong
um
but the problem is not just a
credibility gap johnson had a
credibility gap the problem is
unbelievably worse it's a reality gap
because he won't see the world for what
it is because he sees the world the way
he his religion tells him to see it his
base tells him uh to see it it's as if
you're a batter who's blind
and you constantly swing assuming the
pitch is on the inside corner but it's
always on the outside corner you'll
never hit
by always misdescribing the way the
world is it leads consistently not
occasionally to failed policies and a
failed presidency
but actually it's worse than that to the
point that it's not just a failed
presidency
it's a radical presidency you know the
media is going to have to
start redefining common words radical
is no longer
a kid with long hair in the 60s
a radical
is a short haired conservative
who runs the government
saying the following it is based on
american values in history it is radical
to try to privatize social security
without saying with the trillion dollars
you have to pay for it would come from
that's an interesting economic trick
it's radical to invade and occupy a
muslim country which was no imminent
threat to us based on misleading
information repeatedly said
it is absolutely radical to treat the
geneva conventions as an annoyance
um
with the non-unpredictable result of
torture that's the word it's not abuse
it's torture and gen regrettably
probably generations
of
uh
angry arab youth uh as a result
it is absolutely radical to spend a
hundred billion dollars on a star wars
system which hasn't worked can't work
when clearly the nuclear threats to us
are with guys with box cutters and uh
guys with uh
handheld rocket launchers aiming at
airplanes which would take 10 billion
dollars to protect against
instead of 100 billion dollars for a
system that doesn't work it is
fundamentally radical to have a net
federal accounts shift
from a five trillion dollar projected
surplus in 2001
2000 rather to a five trillion dollar
projected deficit in 2003 a 10 trillion
dollar shift in three years is not easy
to do
um it is radical to nearly end
environmental law enforcement because
your polluting contributors tell you to
do it
it is radical to say the jury is still
out on global warming i'm glad that all
the presidents sit on juries and finally
it is absolutely radical to overturn 800
years of common law and constitutional
law and incarcerate people
without charges and without access to
lawyers
um
how does he get away with it well a lot
of the media not all the media but a lot
of the media
were so
uh deferential and mesmerized after 9 11
that they couldn't stop repeating the
original storyline that he's just a good
old boy
a lot of democrats
were mute
paralyzed
facing a president with a then 80
percent uh popularity it's my view that
the reason so many books
are suddenly political books
this clock is five minutes off
[Applause]
um
because of the vacuum left by the media
and democrats
authors writing the truth holding up a
mirror
did even better than they and we deserve
because it filled a great vacuum
finally republicans
[Applause]
there's a thing that a congressman a
republican congressman once called party
partyology we all understand ideology
cardiology is when you so benefit from
your party in power
the cufflinks the visits the access to
money
um
you're a chairman if you're in the
majority that you don't say what's going
on
and you're intellectually dishonest
but politically self-serving i have an
example of that if he says what he's
reported to be saying tonight rudy
giuliani the former mayor of the city is
speaking the republican convention
tonight
and he's going to say
that
george w bush is like winston churchill
don't blame the messenger least of all
me
because like churchill
saw the rise of nazism when no one else
would and spoke out against it as we say
in new york
give me a break
out of power churchill of course
nearly uniquely saw the rise of nazism
and then in power stood up to and
defeated one of the greatest threats the
world has ever known george w bush
in power
ignored the threat of al qaeda according
to richard clark and all the memos
and um
and now after the attacks is trying to
pretend that he's uh winston churchill i
am
by invading the wrong country churchill
did not invade bermuda
he responded to the nazis so
the conclusion of our book and we'll see
what the other panelists say is that
george w bush
and i say this not as a matter of
partisanship but uh empirical reality
really has been a
messianic uh radical divisive and
dissembling president and the people who
say that we're pessimists to say it
don't understand that when you write
books to educate people you're the
ultimate
naive optimist in the world like you who
attend tonight thank you very much
[Applause]
um
paul krugman again is the author of the
great unraveling a series of his essays
updated in paperback now his essays in
the new york times and elsewhere
he is of course a twice weekly columnist
for the new york times he joined them in
1999 on the op-ed page and he continues
as a professor of economics in
international affairs at princeton
university please welcome paul krugman
oh boy wow
thank you
does that come off my time
sorry
okay um
i usually try not to be too
emotional when i'm talking about this
stuff um
and i wasn't counting but i actually had
an emotional experience coming to this
event
i came in from central new jersey and uh
because something nasty is going on at
penn station on top of it i i got off at
newark and took the path train in uh
which turns out it's actually it's quite
something it takes you in to the world
trade center and it actually takes you
around you get a view of the of the pit
at ground zero um and then you walk
through the station which has got all of
the um a lot of memorial stuff and a lot
of uh uh history and so on it's it's
it's quite it it's quite something it's
quite moving
um and of course
uh what i and i suspect most people in
this room would feel going through it is
not just of course to to be moved and
and to remember but also uh quite a lot
of rage
uh rage at the at the at the
exploitation of this atrocity for
partisan ends uh if we ever come out the
end of this tunnel we will look back and
say that that uh
that some of what's happened over the
last uh three years has been among the
most shameful episodes in our history
this audience has probably not got a
whole lot of people i need to convince
that the bush administration is doing a
bad job
um
so i thought i would i would try to talk
a little bit about where we stand and
and possibly uh what can be done
um let me say first off that just this
whole business of the bush
the books about bush and books about the
administration have been a sort of
reverse of the parable
of the blind men and the elephant
in this case each author
has grabbed hold of a different piece of
the beast something that they knew about
so for me economics for joe wilson
national security for for molly ivan
sort of ground level reporting for
blumenthal how the the whole uh
apparatus uh works uh for craig unger
the the the relationship with the saudis
uh each of us has gotten hold of a piece
that we understood pretty well
um and gotten a picture of what the
beast is like from that piste and we've
all been right it's it turns out that
each piece gives you a picture of the
whole
that what you what whatever your field
is you get the sense that there's
something really wrong here that there's
something very deeply dishonest
irresponsible that there's a hidden
agenda
um
in my own case the the actual it's funny
that where i came in
the the point at which i realized uh
um prematurely because it's not
acceptable to have realized what was
going on until much later uh but the the
point when i realized that there was
something really wrong was actually
during the 2000 campaign and it was over
the issue of social security
privatization
uh which it actually took me a while if
it i've i've expunged from the book some
of my early attempts where i was
actually trying to desperately trying to
find out some way in which this thing
made sense what what candidate bush was
saying uh and finally realized that it
was a scam pure and simple that it
really was two minus one equals four
that he was saying something that's
complete nonsense um
it's amazing that if if the reports are
correct that on thursday night he's
going to
try the whole thing uh exactly as before
uh the that having having a run on it
having had his own commission unable to
come up with a plan because you know the
arithmetic just doesn't work uh he's
nonetheless going to try it once again
and say here's here's the magic solution
that will solve actually in the case of
social security solve a problem that
doesn't exist but anyway that we're
going to uh going to create this great
plan it's it's an amazing thing
it turned out that that's the story
all through that what i saw in social
security what i saw on fiscal policy
is also the story on science policy
environmental policy
and uh
of course uh
in the end national security and and and
the uh and the war
a couple of things to say
um
one
thing that i think is is important and
uh it's not a criticism of green and
aldermen but it's it's along the lines
um focusing on the gotcha
lies
is
worthwhile but you shouldn't focus on it
too much
because often the worst things are when
they don't literally lie
uh if you go through the economic
statements you can find if you want to
find a situation where bush said most of
our tax cuts go to uh people at the
middle or the bottom of the economic
spectrum you can find that but you have
to sift through mounds and mounds of
bush statements the great most of the
time what he and his people say are
things that convey that impression
without actually saying it so that uh in
last year and as you can find it again
in in the uh in the campaign materials
uh last year saying that uh 92 million
americans will get an average tax cut of
a thousand dollars
uh which conveys the impression uh and
actually you would find that some
pundits actually said well every
family's gonna get a thousand dollars so
that's really good uh and of course the
the you know the you know the answer
right it's it's uh the people don't know
what average means uh if bill gates
walks into a bar uh the average net
worth of the patrons is a couple of
billion dollars
um
but
the
the point about and that that is of
course exactly how it works but the
point about that is that when they say
something that
is deliberately misleading but not
literal that is misleading let me say
but not literally false
that actually shows that is deliberate
that if the the extreme
care try to find i don't think anybody
has found a statement in which bush said
that saddam was responsible for 9 11.
but you can find hundreds
of
elusive sentences where 9 11 saddam all
are kind of blurred together
which shows that he and his speech
writers knew that it wasn't true and
we're trying to about trying to plant
the idea in people's minds and that's
that's the thing that's worse it's not
it's not the the gotcha moment it's not
the smoking gun of the sentence where he
says something that's that's falsifiable
as the sentences that were clearly
carefully crafted to convince people of
something that the that the
administration knew was not true
um
bush um we
we also probably make a mistake if we
make too much emphasis on bush the the
individual i mean i know that there's a
there's a particular thing that that can
drive you wild which is the the uh
ascription of of all of these virtues to
a man who manifestly does not uh does
not possess them right the the the idea
that that that that this guy of all guys
is treated as a heroic figure um is is
really baffling but you know this really
isn't about bush
bush is the guy that the movement found
to take them over the top
uh
but it didn't start with him and it
won't end with him either if this is uh
what's going on in this country is that
a radical movement i think we really do
marcus is entirely right and radical is
the right word a radical movement that
has been building for several decades uh
finally found their moment and their man
uh in bush uh but you shouldn't think of
it as just being being him there's a
complete continuity uh between the
uh what's going on now uh and the the
campaign of slander and
innuendo against against bill clinton um
there's uh
there's complete continuity going back
really i think uh but this is this is my
next book you really need to go back to
to goldwater uh a lot of this has its
roots actually in in civil rights uh and
and the people who don't like them um so
it really um but you really have to
understand that this is not about one
guy it's not even about one dynasty
although they
that's a story in itself it's about the
uh the coalition between the
the male factors of great wealth uh and
and the religious right and how they got
uh how they found their man so don't
don't think of it as just being about
this one guy
um how can they get away with it
this is one of the biggest stories i
think and and uh
for you may want to know what does what
does the uh you know what does the times
think about what i write uh by and large
they're extremely protective but they do
get antsy when i talk about the media
because they're part of it because it's
sort of uh but it's it's not possible to
to to deny that the media are a very
central part of this actually
if you can get hold of it the the uh
american journalism review has a an
interview with uh with warren strobel
and jonathan landay the two night ritter
reporters who during the build-up to the
war uh were
providing by far the best account i mean
i i go i was going back and saying why
did i know that the that the case for
uh an active uh iraqi nuclear program
was being cooked up why did i know that
there was this was being sold that
analysts were being pressured all the
stuff that many people still won't admit
but that has been treated as a
revelation i think it was actually
because i was reading the night ritter
stories above all um and they say uh and
talking about it that that the the story
of media failure here is as important as
the story of intelligence failure uh it
is central to it
a couple of things to say on that one is
of course that that substantial chunks
of the media are part of this same
movement
with robert greenwald here we don't need
to uh to say much more about that yes uh
fox news and and uh and and the
washington times and all of that are
part of it um the rest is very much is
is very difficult uh the
most of the media
uh
[Music]
not sure if that's still true i've been
watching the sad decline of cnn but
anyway uh most of the media uh is is
still trying to be
uh even-handed is still mainstream but
uh they have
uh lost the sense of what it means what
what the job of being an even-handed
media uh really is uh it's not
what what they've it should be well okay
here's what what people are saying and
we have checked the facts and here's
what the truth is
uh instead it has become
here's what one side says here's what
the other side says we report you decide
um
as another one of my
people who've heard me before and we'll
know we'll recognize lies but but if if
bush said that the earth was flat
um the the headlines on a lot of the
mainstream media stories would be shape
of the earth views differ
um
and i i saw that
um i saw that in in 2000 over social
security i couldn't believe it was
happening that i could not get anyone at
my organization or any other to uh to
write a straight story saying what does
it take to privatize social security
it was always here's what bush says
here's what the other side said and you
know sounds good he's promising great
stuff um you can find it more recently
unemployment reports the uh if you can
find lots of issues many many issues
swift boats of course the most horrible
of them uh but in this case the uh
the last jobs report was really really
crummy uh it was crummy enough so if you
were watching cnbc uh which had this at
8 30 in the morning when they had the
traders in the chicago pit when the
number came out the traders started
chanting kerry carey carrie
but
to read all the newspaper stories the
next day it was well the bush people say
it's a good number it's a good report
and the other side said it's a bad
report you would never have known the
difference all right what do we do this
is it is really a it's it's much bigger
than bush uh it's a movement it's been
building um
the one thing i think you really have to
say is that people
can i say on the left the position
formerly known as the center
people like myself
[Applause]
people like myself have been asleep for
a long long time we just didn't we
didn't take it seriously we took we sat
through all the clinton scandals and
said oh you know probably funny stuff
going on there didn't really understand
that the extent to which this this
movement was being built
which says i have one minute i believe
um
um
in the long run
uh there has to be the creation of
institutions uh my my great beef with
bill clinton who i thought was did a
terrific job in the office but he did
not build the institutional basis for
rolling this thing back
uh that's in the long run
um how are we ever going to get time to
do that given that this onslaught is
there and it will come they're they're
getting rid of of one man
is not is not in itself it's it's
necessary but not sufficient as we say
in the in the academy um
the answer i think
that my great hope now is is
what we need is an enormous unearthing
of the scandals that we know have taken
place
we need a mega watergate that rocks them
back
for
enough time
so that we can build a counterweight to
this thing otherwise
this won't be the country we grew up in
thank you
[Music]
thank you paul
those of you who want to write questions
can do so at any time and a couple of
people if you could just walk down the
aisle looking for cards which will be
passed up and uh if you'd like to put
your name on the question that's invited
but not required
the next speaker is craig unger
who who's the author of the best-selling
uh house of bush house of saud he was
the deputy editor at the new york
observer and editor-in-chief of boston
magazine
uh craig has written about george
herbert walker bush and george w bush
for the new yorker esquire and vanity
fair
his work is featured in michael moore's
fahrenheit 9 11.
he appears frequently as an analyst on
terrorism and saudi american relations
and the oil industry
on a whole series of radio networks and
cable channels
please welcome craig unger
thank you
my family and i actually have a long
relationship with the bushes my my
father went to yale with george h.w bush
our families both moved from the east
coast to texas about 50 years ago
in 1959 i attended camp longhorn with
george w bush
that summer in the election he never
talks about
both george bush and i were elected
campfire lighter of the week
and finally uh
in around 1972 71 just after i graduated
college and i looked at my first
apartment off campus i found a place in
cambridge massachusetts and as i entered
it uh there was a floor-to-ceiling
poster of george h.w bush and i was
renting the apartment of this guy who
was about to graduate from harvard
business school
uh but that's all i have in common with
him
this book came me very much out of 9 11.
i i did have a history covering
george bush senior in iran country in
iraq gate in 1991
and
september 11th was not just horrifying
to me as an event i was also horrified
by the way the media covered it or
rather it didn't cover it
even the new york times uh
put out a book on the subject called out
of the blue
and 911 as i think we know now did not
come out of the blue uh it was the
product of a series of relationships and
events that have been building for many
many years
uh in covering
uh bush senior i was very much aware of
his relationship with the saudis uh they
they had uh been he'd been very very
close friends with prince bandar for
many years they had business
relationships together uh and and uh
prince bandar had played a key role in
the iran contra
uh he he had put his own money in uh the
saudis had no relationship with
nicaragua
yet prince bandar actually put his own
money in uh
in swiss banks to help get around
a congressional management that was
passed unanimously
known as the bolin amendment to stop the
iran contra back in those days so i
began looking into it right after 9 11
and i began googling like crazy and i
came across uh
the carlisle group
and as i began to look into it some
astonishing things started to to come up
i saw a number of saudis in it uh i
started looking at the relationship and
one of the things that became very very
clear to me
and it seemed to me this was the
elephant in the living room that i was
looking at that no one else uh in the
press seemed to be asking me questions
about this how could we wage a real war
on terror if the president of the united
states and his family had business such
close business relationship with saudis
some of whom were actually accused of
funding terrorism
and that was a question no one seemed to
be asking
i started looking all over the internet
for this and i started saving it to my
hard disk and then i remember the last
time i saved it was september 23rd 2001
and a few days later
the carlisle group website
went down
and when it came back up there were no
saudis on it
and so that's when i really decided to
get serious about this and start looking
into it
that relationship is an extraordinary
relationship and to put it in context i
i mean uh it might be
i'm not sure it's fair to compare it to
something like white water but that was
a a scandal and i'm using the word in
quotes in which the clintons actually
lost money they lost 65 000
by contrast
the bushes and their allies have 20 000
times as much money coming from the
saudis to them i found a total of 1.4
billion dollars in investments and
contracts going from the saudis from the
royal house of saud to companies
in which the bushes and their allies i'm
talking about dick cheney
have major positions the three major
companies i'm talking about are
halliburton harkin energy
uh and of course the carlisle group this
is a figure that uh if any of you
many of you may have seen 911 fahrenheit
911 and that figure is used there it's
finally being challenged and no one
bothered to challenge it until it came
out on the movie i guess now now it's a
high enough profile target
but the the criticism of it is that that
comes out and this is a way the right
and and the media sometimes spin it is
they say well uh george uh george bush
senior didn't join the carlisle uh asian
fund until 1998.
uh
that's true and i report that in my book
what they selectively omit in this
criticism is that george w bush joined
the carlisle group eight years earlier
in in october of uh
1990 and in 1993 after the end of the
bush quail administration
james baker richard darman frank
carlucci all joined the
carlisle group uh bush senior began um
giving speeches for them going to saudi
arabia raising investment money um
and so and so this relationship began
and a total of 1.4 billion dollars
the the real question that raises is
what did the saudis get in return and i
and i'm not alleging and it's sometimes
uh
criticized as this wild conspiracy
theory i'm not really alleging such a
major conspiracy theory what i'm saying
is they had close working relationships
they had close business relationships uh
prince bandar was a very very cl and
still is a very very close personal
friend of the bush family uh he drops by
in kennebunkport maine
he drops by in crawford texas
there are photos of him cooking up a
storm in the kitchen in kennebunkport
he's the only one who's allowed to smoke
cigars
or anything for that matter in the bush
household
barbara bush lets him he's known as
bandar bush if you look at the photos of
him uh
hanging out with george w bush this is
not a man standing in awe of the
president united states he's lounging
around with his good friend's son and
that is the kind of uh relationship they
have so i wanted to take that to
september 13 2001
and to see what what the saudis get in
return
and and how this administration waged
its so-called war on terrorism
and if you look at uh a lot of the
events leading up to it we see again and
again the bush administration ignoring
signs uh of the building terrorists
threat their first year and i think
uh to give them the benefit of the doubt
reasonable people could argue that look
a new president has a lot on his radar
screen even on august 6th when he's
given a memo that says bin laden to
attack
well who knows he's got a lot of other
things on his plate as he was in in
crawford texas that day and he was bass
fishing
but
but on september 13th
two days after 9 11 there's no excuse
for terrorism not to be the first thing
on his mind for the war on terrorism and
at that time
he knew of course that 15 out of 19 of
the hijackers were saudis he knew that
osama bin laden was behind it
he knew that the finance that al qaeda
was largely saudi in origin
that its financing
its infrastructure was backed by members
of the saudi royal family by the
islamist charities and prince bandar
came to the white house that day
and this is where the president should
have said
we have to we need transparency
in the islamist charities that are
funding it
uh we we need transparency uh in the
saudi royal family members who are doing
that
it but instead that day
uh
the planes began flying back
and at 4 30 in the afternoon the first
plane with three saudis on it left tampa
florida to uh
lexington kentucky
this again is a point of contention that
you'll see in in the 911 commission
report
uh and and i think it's worth looking i
i think there's a lot of valuable
information in the 911 commission report
but it's also the report of a commission
that is bipartisan
and whose mandate was to come up with a
consensus
and as a result i i think they uh
selectively omitted
information and facts that were divisive
and some of which were potentially
explosive so
though i don't find any facts that are
in it that are actually wrong what is
interesting is what what they don't have
in it and
on it is true that on that day
commercial aviation began again
but what they omit is that at 10 57 a.m
on that day
private aviation was once again all
banned it abandoned earlier the the
federal aviation administration set out
a new memo a new notice
to
to pilots uh
saying that
all private aviation was banned three
planes violated that ban in the united
states and were forced down
yet
the flight from tampa to lexington
started it needed white house approval
and it got white house approval
and that is just one of the many uh
many actions
done by the bush white house that shows
a certain lack of
of waging a real war on terrorism uh to
take another one they started a program
called visa express
and it they made saudi arabia this was
before 9 11 the only country in the
world where if you needed a visa you
didn't even really have to go down to
the consulate you could send a third
party to do it
three of the hijackers used that program
and they and what it was even more
remarkable is after 9 11 they didn't
bother to shut it down immediately they
let it go
again and again so i i think repeatedly
we've seen this attitude this lacks
attitude towards saudi arabia
um
and
it it just it as a result when you're uh
i happen to live five blocks from ground
zero and to see uh president bush lauded
as our great hero in the war on terror
it can be a bit hard to take
[Applause]
i i think it's also worth worth looking
at what what's going coming out of this
and in many ways i i think uh president
bush has left us with the worst of both
worlds
and by that i mean that uh it would be
one thing if if the the american people
were getting a lot out of this
relationship with saudi arabia and and i
think one of the great
tragic ironies that that seems to be
coming out of that
this is that
oddly enough this administration which
is dominated by oriole executives
is leaving us with more tenuous ties to
middle east oil than ever before
and that i i think we've all seen the
price of gas go up in in the last year
but if you think about it where we are
today and and if you and i think it
really is worth reading some of the
neo-conservative uh tracks that are that
are on the internet from the project of
new american century uh there there's a
new one out called world war four and
that that seems to be the
the guide post set out by uh james
woolsey and and and uh
um
norman pethoritz and so on
we are entering a uh a world in which
like it or not we've had to deal with
the devil with saudi arabia and we're a
nation with 165 million automobiles
and as the price of gas goes up
this economy is going to get in worse
and worse shape
and where are we now well saudi arabia
is
in a state of civil unrest uh
like never before
um
it's whether even if the house assad
survives for several years there's going
to be a succession crisis there
uh no moderate leader in the arab world
can uh possibly be friendly with the
united states now uh even before 9 11
this relationship was wearing thin
because of bush's positions and and
crown prince abdullah had written him a
28-page letter
saying our relationship is about over
in iraq now you have enormous
instability the war is increasingly
becoming a war on oil facilities
cheney had predicted that we'd be
getting 3 million barrels of oil a day
out of saudi arabia uh
it's less than a million and with the
attacks yesterday virtually coming to a
halt so
uh the the question is where are we
going now and are we entering a new era
of oil wars
thank you
thank you very much craig
uh sidney blumenthal um is the author of
the best-selling the clinton wars about
the term of bill clinton and the
right-wing assault on him and he knows
about it because he served as an
assistant to and senior adviser to
president clinton from august 1997 until
january 2001.
i thought
he was sort of the arthur schlesinger
junior of the administration i say that
that's his higher praise as i can come
up with he was someone who uh is an
intellectual a historian
but a politician and he'd known the
clinton for years before them but he was
there also because for years before then
he had been a prolific and prominent
author in the new republic
the washington post and then served i i
think as the
washington bureau chief of the
equivalent of the new yorker
before serving uh
president clinton
he now is the washington bureau chief of
salon the online magazine please welcome
sidney blumenthal
thank you mark i'm delighted to be here
with my old friend mark and uh
honored to be here with paul and uh
one of my oldest friends craig and with
joe who i served with uh in the clinton
white house
and i'm delighted that mark has convened
this first meeting of the new york
subway veterans for truth
[Applause]
well i've been watching those other
uh veterans not the ones who stood with
john kerry uh at the democratic
convention but those on that uh
commercial and
um
it's inspired me to uh
address this in a concentrated way
focused way here the most insidious of
the lies
uh about john kerry
is that it's his fault
it's that somehow he brought this on
himself
because he spoke about the fact that he
was a war hero
and by drawing attention to his war
heroism which by the way
is essential in his talking about his
defense policy foreign policy and how he
would conduct a war on terrorism and an
aggressive effective foreign policy
somebody who served for 18 years in the
senate on the senate foreign relations
committee and has a deep and profound
history of foreign relations that all
this was his fault
that he did this to himself
somehow i didn't think this was
an aberrant incident random
some kind of incoherent
happenstance or sudden
but
system something that
was the result of a systematic campaign
it was
long and coming
it was
a method that has been well perfected in
republican campaigning
and it has been essential to the rise in
power of george w bush
and
a method of which karl rove
is
a particular practitioner
but this is not simply about negative
campaigning
nor is it
about
the
common media
canard
if i can cite a duck here that
they all do it
this goes to more profound questions
goes to the question of the twisting of
u.s intelligence the intimidation of our
fundamental institutions of american
government
from the department of justice to the
cia
to the lies about
wmd that saddam was in league with al
qaeda
and
this week as bush said
that the problem
with the
failures of his
non-strategy in iraq
since the war is
catastrophic success
in other words
our military succeeded so brilliantly
that bush's strategy failed
so it is the military that is at fault
and not bush
and now we uh tonight while we're
seated here rudy giuliani is rehearsing
his speech
to
to depict george w bush is the modern
churchill
this is
a focused
disciplined message on the part of the
republicans in their convention which
you will hear every night that bush is a
decisive strong leader who is
indispensable in protecting your safety
and that
he is the churchill for our times you
will hear it every single night
all this is uh
starkly familiar to
me the night before uh i joined the
clinton white house as assistant to the
president
i turned on my computer screen and uh
i happened to surf by matt drudge's
website where i noticed a headline
saying that i had a
secret history of domestic abuse and was
hiding police records about it
well
you know this
the first time i looked at it it struck
me just
like those who laughed at it i thought
it was something like an old
boar spell joke you know when have you
stopped beating your wife lately i
called my wife
and asked her to look at this and her
first reaction was to
literally to look behind the computer
screen
and
she said
did one of your friends put this in here
as a joke
and what i
learned was
that
no matter how absurd and obviously false
a lie
can be nli is
people will believe it
even some of our closest friends
inquired
isn't there something there are there
some records
you know where there's smoke there's
fire are you sure
uh this has an insidious effect now i
knew about this before because um
i had um sat with
my friend hillary clinton when she was
uh subjected to news articles which said
that um
which were leaks from the ken starr's
office saying she was about to be
indicted in whitewater
total falsehoods
i had sat with uh president clinton
um
we were working on his second inaugural
address and he told me the story of his
conversation with
senator alan simpson where he said to uh
simpson alan you know this white water
stuff is nonsense that there's nothing
there that hillary and i didn't do
anything and simpson said sure we all
know that it just got out of hand
now why do they do it they do it because
it works
uh it works to um
uh destroy the effectiveness
of uh people they disagree with
to destroy uh any alternative positive
message and to destroy progress itself
they actually don't want the changes
and
it works to warp distort
and direct a political debate for their
benefit
it succeeds
and has succeeded in manipulating and
intimidating large parts of the press
corps
which has seen
its standards
and professionalism undermined
even the most professional and
stable parts of the mainstream press
have retreated into a false objectivity
where
the the lies become a matter of on the
one hand on the other hand
i wish i had a patent on the one hand
on the one hand is the lie on the other
hand is the truth
you decide
and they so on cnn for example for a
week they were presenting the story on
the one hand
here's the lie but not presented as the
lie it's just an opinion and then the
truth just another opinion
there's no adjudication of fact there's
a complete abdication of responsibility
when this takes place
[Applause]
[Applause]
now i saw this um in the clinton
experience and um i recall lots of
people saying to me you know the
clintons must have done something they
must have brought it on themselves
there had to be something there in
whitewater why would it happen now the
person who really explained why
whitewater happened and as craig unger
pointed out it was an investment in a
land deal in which the clintons lost
money they were subjected to a 75
million dollar independent council
investigation which determined in the
end that they were innocent
as other official investigations had
uh and um
it was rush limbaugh who was the
ultimate truth-teller
and limbaugh said
whitewater is about
healthcare
that's why it was done
because it worked to prevent
the clinton healthcare initiative
from being passed it was the creation of
a pseudo scandal
they wanted to obscure this and to
create political trouble
and it was
a very important element in succeeding
in killing health care and why today
more than 40 million americans are
uninsured
so we saw this with the creation of many
uh pseudo scandals who can
who can forget the travel office scandal
that
vince foster was killed by the clintons
their close friend
uh the fbi file scandal campaign finance
now here's an interesting fact about
campaign finance in which not a single
official of the clinton administration
was indicted or convicted of anything
there were
more than 1 000 fbi agents assigned by
louis free
the fbi director to investigate campaign
finance
more than four times more the number of
fbi agents ever assigned to investigate
the terrorism
in the first world trade center bombing
all politically driven
and
then of course we had the uh
the unconstitutional impeachment
this was uh followed then by the
smearing of al gore
now gore was an eagle scout who was
successfully tired as a liar and
exaggerator and of course the lies
were all about him
gore uh
gore was tired because he stood in the
in the spotlight it was his turn the
spotlight shifted to him he was the one
who was going to be next
that's how he brought it about himself
brought it on himself
and now it's john kerry's turn
first i saw
an intern scandal on matt drudge
that turned out to be
completely fabricated and now the swift
vote veterans for truth
where have we seen this before
somehow i remember that
ann richards when she was governor of
texas and running against george w bush
that there were terrible rumors that
somehow she was a lesbian
and she didn't want to talk about it and
she was badgered by press corps that
somehow was prodded to ask her in public
about this and then a republican state
senator who just so happened to be a
bush coordinator in east texas
in public
made an accusation against her which
then allowed the press to report this
and then there was an independent group
and so on and so forth
and then i remembered john mccain in the
2000 primaries with all sorts of
independent groups spreading rumors
about him uh and spreading uh stories
uh to in the south carolina primary that
he had adopted a black baby in fact he
and his wife had adopted a
young east asian girl
that
and that he had lied about his military
record
bush then emerges as somebody who says
that
he is against all this negative
campaigning he is above it all
and i have one more minute
so it all struck me as very familiar and
what is the ultimate issue here the
ultimate issue
um is
an issue
of democracy
it's an issue
it's really about it's about us let me
just finish in 60 seconds uh reading
from uh just a few sec few paragraphs
from a column i've written
um it's about um what's been going on at
bush rallies
uh before attending a rally to hear vice
president dick cheney citizens in new
mexico
were required to sign a political
loyalty oath approved by the republican
national committee
i
full name do
hereby
endorse george w bush and this is how it
actually read for re-election of the
united states
now bush is campaigning at events billed
as ask president bush
only supporters are allowed in talking
points are distributed to questioners
in travis city michigan
it's a dangerous spot a 55-year-old
social studies teacher who wore a
carry sticker had her ticket torn up at
the door
how can anyone in the united states deny
someone entry she asked
isn't this a democracy
well floundering in the polls
without a strategy for iraq unwilling to
say the name of bin laden
george w bush is secure in the knowledge
that the cheering multitudes before him
have been preselected
ask president bush has crystallized the
underlying
issue and you will see it all week
as the republicans stay on message about
our churchill
and that issue
was framed succinctly by the greatest
american poet of democracy who happened
to live for many years in this city walt
whitman
who wrote the president is there in the
white house
for you
it is not you
who are here for him
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you very much sydney um anyone has
any final questions could um people walk
up and down to
get cards and then pass them along
during the final remarks
the concluding speaker before the q a is
ambassador joseph wilson
ambassador wilson is the author of the
best-selling the politics of truth and
was a career united states diplomat
from 1976 to 1998.
he
he was called by president george
herbert walker bush a quote true
american hero close quote for his work
on international affairs for over 20
years and was the
last american official to see saddam
hussein before the first
gulf war
and of course most prominently in
february of 2003 he investigated reports
of iraq's attempts
to buy enriched uranium from niger
and when he was surprised that the
president repeated a claim he had
thought he had debunked in the 2003
state of the union address wrote a now
famous op-ed in the new york times
uh saying this was emblematic of the
bush exaggeration uh leading uh making
the argument for our case for inviting
inviting iraq invading iraq um about
which i'm sure you will now speak uh
please welcome ambassador joe wilson
thank you
this is eating into my time thank you
[Applause]
or as i like to say as i like to say bob
novak eats your heart
out now if we get too frisky
if we get too frisky i might just say
somebody ought to be frog marsh out of
the white house again so i don't want to
do that
after all that as my wife said you got a
little bit a little bit ahead of
yourself in that but i'm delighted to be
here mark thank you very much for
inviting me to my
colleagues paul krugman who has written
so eloquently for so long on this
particular subject twice a week in the
new york times thank you for your
service to american democracy to craig
[Applause]
to craig whose book is a real revelation
and and enhances our understanding of
the nature of this relationship thank
you and to my friend sid and his wife
jackie blumenthal who have been pillars
of strength to valerie and myself as the
latest smear campaign
has swirled around us it has been the
blumenthals who have come to us and have
held our hands and who said remember
one of the things that always happens
when it's spinning around you is you
have a tendency to forget that you're
just innocent
so remember you are innocent in all this
i thank you
since i only have 15 minutes about a
subject to talk about a subject where i
could wax eloquently for several hours
i'm going to assume that everybody has
read the book
and and talk really
about the chapter that is still being
written
in fact there are two chapters that are
still being written the first one which
i'll talk about today is the anatomy of
a smear campaign
the second one is redemption and i am
absolutely persuaded that we will have
redemption in this
thanks to pat fitzgerald and others
[Applause]
some of you who may read the wall street
journal and bill sapphire and other
right-wing
reporters
may have may have noticed that the
publication of the senate select
committee on intelligence report
there was a whole section on the niger
caper
and uh there were some conclusions that
the
senate came to which were simply
incorrect i want to address that and
there were some conclusions in the
additional views by the senators three
senators mr bond
mr hatch and mr roberts
relating to valerie and myself
i want to address just two parts of
these and the rest of them i'll address
in the q a session if i get a question
first
is the assertion
that the president
was correct
in making the statement in the state of
the union address
in january of 2003
that the british government has learned
that saddam hussein recently attempted
to acquire significant quantities of
uranium from africa
now as a consequence of that statement
being in the senate select committee on
intelligence report
i have been branded a liar
and i think
some of the ditto heads including
including my friend sean hannity a
traitor
for having lied and somehow impugned the
integrity of the president united states
for having suggested that he should not
have said those 16 words
and yet if you go back and you look at
the body of the report and regrettably a
rather docile american press decided
they couldn't take the time to read the
seven pages on this particular matter to
determine themselves what precisely the
senate had concluded and come up with in
terms of information but if you do that
pages
52-59 at least as i downloaded it of the
report
you might in fact see
that on october 2nd of 2002 nearly four
months before the president's date of
the union address
the deputy director of central
intelligence
testified to the senate the senate
select committee on intelligence the
same committee that did this report
now the deputy director of central
intelligence in testifying to the senate
committee was speaking as
the spokesman for the american
intelligence community
offering the corporate view of american
intelligence
not whether one analyst was somehow
reinforced by wilson's report
the corporate view of american
intelligence
almost four months before the state of
the union address and what he said was
one area where we believe the british
have stretched the information is on
uranium sales from africa to iraq
now those of you who don't live in our
little world our little national
security world might want a translation
of that sentence
it basically what he said representing
the american intelligence corporate view
we think the british are full of crap on
this one
four months before the state of the
union address
four days later the director of central
intelligence
again
offering the corporate view of american
intelligence called the deputy national
security adviser
and he said to him
we do not want the president to be a
witness of fact on this matter because
the reporting is weak translation the
case has not been made
and because we have told congress that
we believe the british have exaggerated
the case again the british are full of
crap on this one
the director of central intelligence
also sent two faxes to the white house
to the to the national security adviser
and her deputy on this matter
and yet four months later the president
united states used this assertion in his
speech
now
the day after my modest little piece
appeared in the new york times and i
remind people that for all the talk
about this it was 1500 words entitled
what i did not find in africa
this was not 7 000 pages of secret
documents
in fact the first attempt to smear he
said maybe he was revealing secrets
let me remind people nothing
what i did not find in africa
the day after that article appeared the
white house spokesman came out and he
said to the washington post the 16 words
did not merit inclusion did not rise to
the level of inclusion in the state of
the union address
a week later george tenet testified to
the senate in which he said
what i just said earlier he said to the
senate that yeah he did not want the
president of the witness of fact
a couple of days after that the national
security adviser and her deputy looked
through their files and they found these
two faxes
and this record of the telephone call
the deputy national security adviser
offered his resignation
and the national security adviser said
we forgot
and yet when the senate select committee
report comes up with this conclusion and
it's interpreted by
people it's it's interpreted as well
bush was okay it was right for him to
say that
which basically what they're saying to
you is it's okay to outsource
american intelligence and analysis to
the british even though the british only
spend five percent of what we spend on
intelligence even though the british
have very limited assets in africa and i
served in africa for 23 years the first
thing a british diplomat does when they
circuit ride to embassy countries like
niger where they have no presence is
drop in to see their american
counterpart to find out what the hell is
going on
the second assertion of course in this
in this uh in this report is that
somehow my wife had some role to play in
my being sent out to niger
and yet the body of the report
establishes my bona fides
in addition to 23 years doing africa
including at the white house where i
worked intimately with a succession of
niger governments as they worked through
two military coups and the assassination
of a president in order to help them get
back to a democratic system of
governance
in addition to that the report says
wilson went out on behalf of the cia to
ask other uranium related questions in
1999.
those are my bonafides now i would never
have told you that and i'm sorry the
senate select committee on intelligence
decided to do so because in so doing
they burned and compromised a number of
my business
contacts
and if they could do it to me they could
do it to other americans who at the
request of their government go out and
try and ferret out information that's
important to our understanding of what
potential enemies may have in mind for
us
and remember when i took this trip it
was several months when i took the trip
in 2002 it was months before i had ever
formulated a position on the war and
indeed when i did formulate a position
on the war it was based upon a
legitimate concern about the threat to
our national security posed by weapons
of mass destruction
i was asked because i knew something
about niger
a lot about niger
i was asked because i had undertaken a
mission before
and i undertook that mission because
nuclear weapons kill americans they
don't kill just democrats or republicans
they would kill americans if they went
off national security doesn't mean
republican or democratic security means
american security
so for these guys to try and paint me as
a partisan in this is unfair for them to
on the one hand
on july 14th
of 2003
betray the national security and betray
my wife's identity
and a year later try and smear her by
suggesting that somehow she was
responsible for something that she was
not responsible for
is really piling on and a disgrace and
they should be ashamed of
[Applause]
themselves now again
a docile press
that was an article in the washington
post that said the quoted a phrase from
my book where i said she had nothing to
do with my trip
left out of that quote was the beginning
of the sentence which said other than
serve as a conduit
doesn't that change the meeting meaning
isn't that a professional faux pas
as they say in french
yes indeed it is but that has become
the primary source material for
everybody else nobody's bothered to go
back and look at the book just as
nobody's bothered to go and read the
text
of the senate
report and as a consequence
my wife's name which never should
have been known to anybody
has been dragged through the mud
her identity has been betrayed
her reputation's been besmirched by this
while the person who put the 16 words in
the president's state of the union
address remains unknown to anybody
now why did they do this why did they do
this smear campaign well there's a
number of reasons one i suspect the
neoconservatives were not very happy
when i wrote about them that they are
parasite loyal only under themselves who
found the republican party willing host
[Applause]
i think mr gillespie was probably
unhappy when i suggested and provided
the transcripts in my book that
suggested he had misrepresented the
nature of my contributions to political
campaigns
i went back and looked at that and
there's direct quotes
the wall street journal i'm told was mad
because i was effective in fact somebody
told me that the real reason they're
after you so hard is because you've been
effective which got me thinking that
perhaps after this is all done and i
have to go out and look for another job
maybe i'll write fox news maybe i'll
write the wall street journal and ask
them for a letter of recommendation
on my effectiveness and then i thought
actually i've been reading a couple of
biographies of churchill home one of the
things that comes out in each one is the
wall street journal opinion page was
wrong on world war ii the wall street
journal opinion page was wrong on
churchill's speech
in missouri about the cold war and the
iron curtain it's very clear that the
wall street journal was wrong about iraq
they're wrong on wilson and his wife so
i'm not sure that they would be very
good as a reference
but the reason this smear
campaign has been run by the republican
national committee
they have directed this
they have sent during the height of it
three blast faxes out a day i actually
got a couple
the three days this is going to go on
another minute or two the three days
that we were in boston they opened up
their press conference by saying well
we've discredited and trashed wilson and
his wife why is anybody listening to him
now the head of the republican party is
the president united states ably
assisted by his vice president by his
political adviser
there is a criminal investigation
going on
involving the white house
in the betrayal of the national security
of this country the president i say
criminal defense counsel the vice
president has counsel mr rove has
counsel they have either appeared before
the special counsel or they have
appeared before the grand jury
i am not a lawyer
but my understanding is that there are
ethical considerations surrounding
whether or not you are actively engaged
in tampering with an ongoing criminal
investigation if you might be
party to that criminal investigation
and yet they're directing this campaign
and the reason was clear in the wall
street journal opinion piece they want
mr fitzgerald to quote fold up his tent
now there's a second reason for the
timing of this i'm absolutely convinced
is it was a dress rehearsal for the
swift boat veterans cam
slam
they were able to tweak it they were
able to see how they could manipulate
the press get the facts out and do this
before they came on with the onslaught
on john kerry but there is a third
reason which is perhaps more ominous
and that reason
is to send a signal to the american
people the signal is as follows
should a citizen
exercise his civic duty
to call his government to account
for what his government
says and does in the name of the
american people as i did
then this administration's response
will be to use every political weapon in
its arsenal
to destroy that citizen
and his family be afraid be very very
afraid
now that is un-american
it is undemocratic
it is inconsistent with the social
contract bequeathed to us by our
founding fathers
who said at the very beginning we must
have a healthy suspicion of the power of
the executive branch
hence we will create co-equal branches
of government and we will endow the
press
and we will endow the citizenry with
absolute freedoms and responsibilities
essentially to hold the government to
account and that's what we must do
as i've been traveling around the
country over the past several months
a couple of terms keep coming up
one is the whiff of fascism generally
from people who grew up in central
europe in the thirties who tell me
beware you will not know it has happened
until it is too late
[Applause]
and secondly
secondly is a reference to the mccarthy
era
from people who grew up a little bit
later now the good news about america
is that we have a long history of
resisting this type the pendulum
swinging this far in one direction
we have resisted before and we must
continue to resist it is in the nature
of our social contract to do so it is
time for somebody to stand up
and say have you no shame
thank you very much
[Music]
[Applause]
um i thank you panelists all for your
great talks and thank you audience for
your great questions about 50 came
forward let me say uh just statistically
six of the 50 were about florida and
vote count
betraying in a understandable anxiety
but and i ignore though all the
questions
about why isn't john kerry doing a b and
c because this actually is about the
bush
record
not the politics of 04 although
apparently not a lot of republican
delegates have come downtown and are in
this audience based on the questions and
your applause um
uh let me uh just uh ask questions as a
as i determined they were useful of the
panelists that they were directed to
first a policy question for paul
um
so what are the democrats plan to do on
the economy that would actually be
different and better
okay
um
in 700 words
i
that that that's the discipline i think
i've learned um
yeah the i mean the core just let's talk
first about what's actually in the carry
proposals uh the core of it there the
the central proposal is to roll back the
up the the champagne portion of the bush
tax cuts uh and use the money for health
care and a little bit for education uh
and it's
you know that's big stuff actually in a
way if again if we ever come out the
other end uh bush may have done us uh in
a peculiar way a favor by by throwing
all these vast sums at unjustified tax
cuts for people who don't need them he's
made
made it clear how relatively cheap
really big things that will do a lot of
social good are
the carry plans about 60 billion a year
which which really takes care of close
to two-thirds of the people who now
don't have health insurance uh i'd go
for the full 100 billion a year that
covers everybody but it's it compared
with the 270 billion dollars in lost
revenue this year from the bush tax cuts
you suddenly realize that hey getting
everybody health insurance is not so
hard to do that's the that's the biggest
thing the other thing in the carry plan
which is is rationalization and
enforcement of corporate taxation uh
which would do some good things for jobs
and it's just you know as again the
actually
taking money that that we need for
programs we need from from from the
right people
um the bigger thing and i think this is
you can't point to the specifics but you
know we're talking about
um actual responsible people making
economic policy
i mean what can i say
robert rubin jon snow what more do you
have to say about the whole thing
[Applause]
thank you
um
a question from a matt harwood the
washington monthly
uh addressed to joe wilson
how can u.s foreign policy effectively
fight islamic fundamentalism and promote
democratization
without resorting to military
intervention and occupation
well i i you know i try and put out in
my in in the book i try and compare and
contrast the way that we the way that we
did um uh
the end of the cold war the end game of
the cold war
um and the argument that i uh made in
the book and the argument that i would
make here is that if you um
if you understand the traditional use of
the military which is to defend the
united states against imminent threats
to us
not to go adventuring and if you
understand also that we historically
have had a fairly sophisticated
toolbox of other foreign policy tools at
our disposal a lot of which we use in
the latter stages of the cold war but
which would include everything from
incentives
such as the opening of
american markets to foreign exports to
to
deterrence
such as robust diplomacy such as
economic sanctions such as international
sanctions
um
uh such as
in fact going as far as subversion and
other tools if you really felt that you
had to do so because your concern was so
great about the nature of the direction
things that we've done in the past
things that american governments have
been
have been um have been castigated for
having done in the past
my point in all of this is that
the use of the military
uh in an aggressive way has unintended
consequences that we're now beginning to
really begin to see
uh in the case of iraq for example we're
close to a thousand americans dead were
up to 150 billion dollars spent and our
international reputation is in tatters
uh
dick cheney said that um 20 000
terrorists have been trained in al qaeda
camps
if you assume a ratio would say 101 or
even a thousand one of sympathizers and
supporters to actual terrorists who
would kill you
that gives you an overall population who
before 9 11 hated us enough to either
sympathize support or try and kill
americans of the order of 2 million or
maybe 20 million
and now with u.s
the the respect for the united states
below the statistical margin of error in
a number of arab countries which pop
which which number uh in the islamic
world a billion people in the arab world
well over 400 million people
many of whom are underemployed 19 year
old arab males uh you can see the extent
to which this potential population that
poses a threat to our national security
has
grown exponentially or will grow
exponentially and so you have to ask
yourself the question whether or not use
of military in this action when there
was not an imminent threat where there
was not a grave and gathering danger has
not had the ultimate unintended
consequences that you wanted to avoid
which is greater threat to american
citizens which we constitute our
military to defend us against
so my argument really is and always has
been that there is a whole vast array of
tools
at our disposal many of them have been
weakened over the years as american
diplomacy has has been under attack from
from a number of different quarters in
the american political process
but i certainly don't think that
that resorting to military action and
wars of choice is either going to yield
the desired result and we've seen the
limits of our ability in this in this
regard and imposing democracy in in iraq
thank you
[Music]
uh
both questions were substantive about
better economic policy uh a better uh
use of what harvest joseph and i call
soft power around the world let me say
in the book that's out there what we
stand for
a program for progressive patriotism 17
authors
discuss issues just like this sandy
berger president clinton's national
security adviser
has an essay on in a sense answering
this question joe where he uses the
phrase that america is strongest not
simply when we focus on the
example of our force
but the force of our example
and we can persuade people it's not just
by invading them
um but the values that so many americans
uh so many people around the world love
um
there's a question here for um
uh sydney blumenthal
it's long and very interesting um it's
the morning of november 3rd
whether because of brother jebs valiant
efforts in florida or because of this is
not sign by the way
or because of those clever new
electronic voting machines with no paper
ballots george w bush has successfully
stolen his second consecutive
presidential election what does each of
what do you say i don't want to ask this
of everyone
uh think
would be an appropriate response by
citizens to this scenario
[Applause]
it's good not to get a loaded
hypothetical
this question uh
is formulated on the fact that
florida was decided in 2000
by an unprecedented intervention of the
supreme court
five to four
in which it decided that the votes would
not be counted in florida
that's
and they were not counted
and
uh
so the question is
um there'll be many scenarios if
something strange like that happens
uh the the scenarios
should involve legal
and the question is what happens as a
result of the legal action and does the
supreme court act again
but these are all very very
hypothetical what's real is
that the republican party conducts
campaigns of voter suppression
we conduct go tv get out the vote they
try and get out their base and they try
and suppress our voters
they try and in particular intimidate
minorities
the chief justice of the supreme court
began his political career
on the
streets of arizona
trying to prevent and intimidate
minority voters from voting
william rehnquist
um we will see those campaigns again
we need a lot of people out there
monitoring these campaigns and we need
to get out every single voter we can and
get everybody to the polls
so that this scenario
never happens
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
for craig unger why do commentators and
reporters insist on representing the
saudi bush critique in your book
and that in fahrenheit 9 11 as quote
conspiracy theory close quote
well
conspiratorialist or
has really replaced uh red baiting and
and that that is the
uh line of attack i've been getting for
over 10 years there i mean there really
is no conspiracy if you read my book
uh
they have had this long relationship the
bush and the saudis no one really
disputes that
uh no one disputes the amount of money
that has changed hands uh no one
disputes now that the planes
actually left uh it was quite
interesting actually the
white house denied that the these
evacuation plans with the saudi
on them left uh for two full years the
fbi denied it for two full years
uh the faa denied it for two full years
and what was extraordinary true now
they'd say they all left but they've
changed the story and said well it's
okay uh commercial restrictions had been
lifted
what they omit again and again is that
restrictions were in place for private
planes and you see this kind of attack
from the riot again and again that uh
people like me are called conspiracy
nuts and and there there seems to be a
zone of comfort
uh about what's acceptable to write
about in the mainstream press
when i decided to go ahead with this
book i i i was looking for material that
i knew would be
acceptable to mainstream journalists and
i found one kernel of it in a piece that
had been published in the wall street
journal in 1991 and it showed how the
saudis had uh bailed out george w bush
when he was at harkin energy in
the back in 1991 when his father was
president
and it was a terrific piece of
journalism
uh it was done by three reporters for
the wall street journal one of them uh
was jill abramson who's now managing out
of the new york times and as i started
the whole project i said well if
she knows about this the times knows
about it
uh and yet i knew in the end the times
would not touch the story and they
didn't
and the only thing that's changed is
george w bush is no longer the
president's son he's the president and
the saudis who bailed him out have been
tied uh there have been allegations that
they uh were behind islamist charities
that funded terrorism yet no one in the
american press would touch it
and and you've seen that again and again
and i think uh one reason reporters shy
away from it and there are many reasons
i think reporters are are
addicted to access they will be denied
access if they ask the tough questions
it's about careerism opportunism and so
on uh and they don't wanna and if
they're called a conspiracy nut it hurts
their careers
[Applause]
[Music]
um yeah there's a question of me quote
if a majority of americans agree with
progressives on issues
why do they lose national elections
close quote i guess i could add or
mayoral elections
um
uh at first um at the risk of being
self-critical self-analytic
uh robert forrest is reported to have
once said that a liberal is someone who
won't take his own side in a debate
um and
which which is a perverse
which is a perversion of a definition of
a liberal which is someone who's
tolerant
but in the era of
limbaugh and hannity and uh and
fox they're out foxed uh i i see
progressives now as pushing back real
hard hence air america hence pagala and
carville on crossfire
[Music]
and the era of on this end on the other
hand and you have a very fine point
there mr limbaugh is over
um
second
republicans for generations
to be blunt have often run
occasionally successfully for president
against the reds and the blacks
uh willie horton
uh the implication that democrats are
soft on defense after having
successfully prosecuted world war one
world war ii
um and and
the suppression of african-american
voters in florida not hispanic voters
because they are split
politically but the uh
uh two large felony lists
uh disqualifying you from voting in
florida are disproportionately
overrepresented by african-american uh
people uh rather than hispanics in
florida for political uh reasons
and so that is not pretty but it has
occasionally worked as the answer to one
of the prior questions indicates
a third
sydney spoke very well to this and joe
has lived it
it was once said by mark twain that a
lie gets halfway around the world before
truth puts on her boots
and i gotta tell you haven't been in a
campaign sometimes when someone says
something about you that is the opposite
of the truth
i won't give current examples in the
presidential race but they come to mind
it is very difficult to figure out
whether to respond
elevate
and publicize the slander
or whether you just try to have
surrogates do it or ignore it it is just
not easy machiavelli once wrote that the
greatest tactic is to go after not an
opponent's weakness but his strength
to undermine what people otherwise think
about him and so um
the slanders too often work finally and
the real answer to this is
uh all data show
that on issue after issue the public is
in favor of stronger environmental law
enforcement
even if it leads to increased costs of
products in favor of teachers getting
more and they're being smaller
class sizes in favor of a more universal
health care plan whether it's based on
israel's or canada's
um and so the challenge to progressive
candidates
whether for president or anything
is to be able to
cogently
and persuasively argue
why
covering your child's health care
shrinking his or her class size cleaning
uh the air and working with allies is
more in your interest than two lesbians
marrying in vermont
and um
and uh
uh i am midway through a book
that's on the times bestseller list
though what's the matter with kansas
where the author explains how kansas is
so
economically impoverished in a century
ago
it would have led to a
populist revolt it did lead to a
populist revolt but now they are being
said the author
uh successfully misled into thinking
that
certain wedge cultural issues are more
important than their pocketbook issues
and it's up to uh progressives
to win the public argument despite the
slanders and despite
um
the misleading comments on why economic
pocketbook issues mean that one party is
factually superior to the other let me
just say that i looked at
a growth the new democracy project
looked at gross domestic product
and real growth rates in gdp
uh each year since roosevelt was first
elected before then the data was wild
because of the depression
and if you add up all the
growth rates under democratic presidents
and republican presidents which is a
fact
growth rates under democratic
progressive presidents is two to three
times i don't mean two percent more 20
more but 200 to 300 percent
more
uh than under republican presidents
um the next question um back to uh paul
krugman
uh mr krugman obviously they're not a
student of yours at princeton but um
i
professor krugman you've intimated that
if bush loses in november a lot of quote
dirty laundry unquote may get out and
bring legal problems from members of the
administration
well can you elaborate now
okay
[Music]
let me say it legal i'm not sure uh
but i think there's the the revelations
look um what are the things that we know
are
much worse than has has uh made it out
um
the wilson plane affair surely uh
the
the the cooking of intelligence do you
we know we know with with fair certainty
that there was intense pressure put on
analysts to uh to to cook the case for
war
um contracting in iraq uh we we there
are billions and billions of unaccounted
for dollars uh
um it's it's a
with with the stonewalling you know
there are there are internal audits that
that the uh the defense department and
the coalition provisional authority have
refused to release uh we can we can
guess why um the um
uh the cheney energy task force there
has to be some reason why they're
blocking it you know let's let's think
think about the fact that that it took
uh a couple of years of lawsuits and and
one very enterprising tiny utility in
the northwest to to get the tapes the
control room tapes that revealed enron
traders uh telling telling power plants
to shut down to drive up the price when
the federal energy regulatory commission
was was in possession of those tapes all
that time that they were just sitting on
it so how many more things are there
like that um i'm i'm sure i'm i'm
missing a bunch but there's no question
in my mind that that well i would grape
sorry again all we what everything we
know is that not only that there are
pictures in fact of things much worse
than anything that you've seen
um legal action i'm not sure i think
that the point is getting the stuff out
into the light of day uh that the the
psychological impact i hope of of the
revelation of what has been done in our
name uh would be enormous
um and let me say actually um if if
among the i i think that that fear of
this is one of the reasons probably they
probably didn't need extra incentive to
wage a particularly dirty campaign but
this is one of the reasons um and uh if
someone asks you what did
john kerry do in the senate
uh he more or less single-handedly
brought down bcci uh and don't don't
forget that story and he must be it must
be a real nightmare to think of him in
this position of being of being able to
to uh to re remove the shroud of secrecy
so that's the story
thank you let me ask a question
generally
any panelist can feel free to answer
what do you think is the biggest
hypocrisy in george bush
juniors
george w bush's tenure as president in
his 2000 campaign and or in the present
campaign
oh boy by oh
i didn't write this to prove it david
calaman airy of hoboken new jersey david
well let me let me it's a tough it's a
tough question
is
starving between two carrots as as a
as a candidate for president in the year
2000 president bush gave his foreign
policy speech
at the reagan library in simi valley
and that speech was characterized by a
commitment to humility
a commitment to moderate
policy objectives within the context of
alliances with friends
a commitment to internationalism
and a commitment to proposing rather
than imposing
um and i think of course the the record
has been has been sharply different um
and it is now clear
of it was clear to some of us then by
just the people that were advising him
that the operating
blueprint for the policy was not going
to be the
uh bush speech but it was going to be
the project for the new american century
which was sold to the administration as
a reasoned policy document
uh which was
which would guarantee our own national
security for the next 75 years as well
as the national security of our close
friends and allies
through the uh
aggressive use of military force to
defeat and deter
real and imagined enemies of course the
reality when this thesis met the harsh
reality of the road of iraq it exposed
first of all our the weakness
uh in our ability to manage things like
occupations militarily
and secondly i think it exposed the
whole under outline premise behind the
project of the new american century
as
a series
of ideological assertions
with nothing no grounding in history
geography
understanding of international relations
or understanding of that most basic
churchillian principle
that in addition to being strong
if you hope to succeed in your foreign
policy objectives you needed to
understand and address
the legitimate grievances of your
enemies and your potential enemies
[Applause]
similarly
on the uh
on the domestic front in 2000 bush
campaigned famously as a compassionate
conservative
and the last convention we saw just as
this one will depict him as such
and yet this time he has a record that
belies
that slogan
his education program leave no child
behind is crushing public education
today the new york times had a story
about how
children with disabilities have been
left behind systematically
his
medicare
reform
is intended to
begin the privatization of the medicare
system and throw seniors who can't
afford it out
it was achieved uh in
the dark of night in the floor of the
house of representatives by tom delay
the majority leader
uh holding open the rule for hours in
order to coerce moderate republicans who
knew better
the actuary
who
had the figure
which showed that it would cost much
more than uh the bush administration had
said
was told that
he would be
fired
his career ended if he told the truth
we have also learned that the result of
compassionate conservatism has been an
increase of 1.3 million people in
poverty
much of this was supposed to be
resolved through faith-based programs
the first person who was head of the
faith-based office in the bush white
house was a
an earnest and honest
academic
uh named john diuglia
who
was the first
to leave in disillusionment and said
that there was no serious discussion of
social or domestic policy going on in
the white house and that the entire
operation was run by what he called the
mayberry machiavellis
[Laughter]
he meant karl rove
and now we see what the faith-based
program is really about
with the reports that what bush
is doing through the bush cheney
campaign is setting up political
coordinators in every church that they
can
using the churches as though they were
little tammany halls
so that is the result of compassionate
conservatism and this something to keep
in mind as we watch
the show on tv this week
um
[Applause]
this uh paul
[Music]
um just
just an observation and i think part of
the deep mystery something i don't fully
understand but i think what's what's
really striking
uh beyond the hypocrisy and the policies
is the the pervasive personal hypocrisy
that is is just
here's the way i think about if if i
were writing a really bad political
novel a real pot boiler um i would
may i you'd have the villains of it be
you know not just wrong but but you know
grossly transparently hypocritical so
you'd have
all of the people who pretended to be
big patriots would be people who had
abduct service men who would who had
never who had never never taken a risk
or made a sacrifice for their country
um that uh all of the people who talked
about free markets and private
initiative would be people who grew
wealthy through crony capitalism and
deals and political influence
uh and then just to cap it off you
insert some comical figures like someone
who preached morality and wrote books
like the book of virtues who turned out
to have a gambling habit and lie about
it
um
and it is there's something deeply
amazing about it and that look and this
is a mystery actually it's something
that we do have to figure out why why it
doesn't these things don't have more
traction uh
uh you know when people say
when people say uh getting back to you
know uh john kerry uh brought the swift
boat thing on by himself uh on himself
by by talking about his genuine heroism
and in the war um you know i thought
that operation flight suit made the
texas air national guard
a
fair game but but all everyone treated
as if it was not and i don't quite
understand but this is it's certainly
the hypocrisy is
aside from the policy just the sheer
hypocrisy is astonishing
[Applause]
with that i want to
conclude in the interest of time and
getting you all to get home tonight to
watch the convention on television um
what we uh actually what happened
tonight was were people who are
opinionated but factual
[Applause]
and
[Applause]
having come
personally through a
exciting crossfire experience last week
on cnn
uh so often when you have a couple of
seconds to out shout someone based on a
selective fact
it doesn't yield a kind of policy
exchanges that
we did here tonight and i'd love to do
with the other side
anybody here who would like to find out
more about any of our books or the books
of our colleagues and panelists here you
can go to www.newdemocracyproject.org
which organize this with the people for
the american way and true majority in
the nation magazine
and the progressive book club i'm really
honored that you all came out tonight
and especially honored that a panel of
this quality has joined us and shared
with us please thank them
[Applause]
this event was hosted by the new
democracy project for more information
visit newdemocracyproject.org
thomas frank on cultural conservatism
tied jones on a century of radicalism
john judas on president bush and craig
unger on the saudi u.s relationship this
lasts about an hour
good afternoon i'd like to welcome you
to this afternoon session a look at
politics a chance to hear from uh four
authors of on their books on american
politics past and present today's
authors john judas thomas frank craig
unger and ty jones are all distinguished
journalists and i think that with these
four books they join a tradition of
american journalism that has been in
effect for the entire century but
particularly since the vietnam war which
are journalists who become the
forerunners of the scholars the people
who do the research
rapidly and with much depth so that we
can read about events in the world and
begin to internalize what's happening to
the world we are in before the scholars
think about it theorize about it and
actually for those of us like myself who
are american historians they have become
models for how we are transforming the
way we do scholarship and i think we
have four examples of that today
i want to say a few things about these
books before we start all four of these
books begin with the premise that we are
a nation in trouble
and although they differ in their
explanations for why we're in trouble
and for how we might get out of that
trouble they do share some uh
assumptions
and one of them is that the past and not
knowing the past harms us and that if we
did understand our past better as a
nation and if our politicians understood
it better and if as educated voters we
understood it better we would be able to
improve our conditions in the present in
the future they also share a question
and that question is where does the
domestic situation end and the
international situation begin they all
have an idea though very different from
one another that there is some border
between the domestic and international
and that understanding it is vital to
coming to terms with the american
position at home as well as in the world
i'm going to briefly say a few words
about our panelists and then each one of
them will talk to you about their books
john judas on my right is a journalist
and a scholar he's a senior editor for
the new republic was a founding editor
of socialist review
sure and of east bay voice is that
better
as well as foreign editor of in these
times he's currently a visiting scholar
at the carnegie endowment for
international peace and a frequent
contributor to the american prospect
foreign affairs gentleman's quarterly
and the new york times magazine he's
written several books including the
paradox of american democracy elite
special interest and the betrayal of the
public trust ty jones is the newest face
in the group he's a recent graduate of
columbia university's school of
journalism he has worked as a reporter
for newsday and his book a radical line
is a combination of history and memoir
and is his first book
thomas frank is founding editor of the
baffler and the author of two previous
books including one market under god
he is a historian as well as a
journalist craig unger is a frequent
face on cnn as an analyst on terrorism
and saudi u.s relations he was once
deputy editor of the new york observer
and editor-in-chief of boston magazine
he has written frequently about george
bush for the new yorker esquire and
vanity fair the format for today's
discussion will be as follows each one
of the authors will speak for seven to
ten minutes about their books i will ask
them questions either after they talk or
after all of them talk depending on what
they say and then we will have a few
moments for discussion from the floor
so without further ado john we're going
to start with you
thanks can you hear me all right
now this is the book
folly of empire that
i'm here to explain plug however you
want to put it
um
i started the book in about
june
of last year
and
in october
an event occurred that uh crystallized
for me uh what the book was about
uh george bush decided to uh visit uh
manila he went there uh accompanied by a
flotilla of f-16s because uh uh he was
worried about a
terrorist attack he didn't stay
overnight there were demonstrators on
the ground when he got there
and he spoke to the philippine assembly
and what he said among other things was
that the united states was proud because
together our soldiers liberated the
philippines from colonial rule
now uh that statement uh prompted a lot
of geforce in the philippines and uh it
is so it should have
uh in fact what happened was that um
our our effort to annex the philippines
after the spanish-american war in 1898
uh led to a bitter and protracted
conflict the height of it was for three
years
dragged on for another 10 and in some
ways it continues today in those islands
in the south uh where the where al qaeda
is based
we lost over 4 000 men in the course of
it we killed over 200 000 filipinos uh
there was widespread incidences of
torture uh and it jeopardized our
foreign relations in the pacific for the
next
50 years
so there you go now what what happened
there
again what i think what i think we had
there was a case of historical amnesia
and it was a case of this current
administration not understanding the
lessons of the past and particularly the
lessons that americans learned from 1898
to 1914
about the effort to build an empire and
what would happen when the united states
set about trying to colonize other
nations and in so doing to create them
in our own image
and what i tried to do in the book is to
explain the relevance of this period of
history and of theodore roosevelt and
woodrow wilson the two key figures
to our present history and why if our
current administration had understood
what happened there they might have
acted differently
there was a second incident besides the
philippines that was important
in 1914 19 widow wilson takes power in
1913. uh
he like theodore roosevelt and like
george bush and like all our presidents
uh is dedicated to trying to create a a
world that in some sense is in our image
freedom
liberty democracy and he promises to
teach the latin american republics to
elect good men
and it's a good he gets his first
opportunity in mexico because a guy
named huerta who is a kind of saddam
hussein figure
takes power there by assassinating the
democratically elected and the first
democratically lead
elected leader of mexico madaro
so wilson sends in the troops
and like mckinley and theodore roosevelt
in 1898 he expects to find no resistance
well he might find resistance from
huerta but where it was in the middle of
a civil war and he expected the people
who were fighting huerta carranza and a
guy named pancho villa who is now
familiar to all of us to unite with the
americans and get rid of huerta but lo
and behold the same thing happens in
mexico that happens in the philippines
and later happens in iraq which is to
say our intervention our attempt to
impose our ways upon this country
provokes a nationalist rebellion you
have little kids are shouting death to
the gringos in mexico city our troops
get bogged down in the coastal regions
there and we finally have to get bailed
out by argentina brazil and chile who
arrange a kind of peace treaty uh and
our our relations with uh with mexico
were fraught with peril for the next
decades
now what lessons did theodore roosevelt
and wilson draw from that theodore
roosevelt drew
less of a of a grand conclusion his
conclusion in 1907 was that the
philippines had been a mistake that had
turned into what he called our heel of
achilles
but he still saw the mission itself as
something that was possible wilson
repudiated the entire mission as he
understood it
what he concluded was two things
the first was
that democracy
making a country another country
democratic was not like changing its
currency
it was something that had to grow out of
the country itself organically he was a
follower of the
english philosopher edmund burke
you in other words you couldn't go in
and simply create an american system in
another country what would happen
especially if it was done in the context
of dominator and dominated was that you
would provoke a nationalist rebellion
which would trump and obscure all your
efforts to do otherwise
lesson that's important for iraq the
second thing that he concluded was that
in so far as america is dedicated to
creating the world recreating the world
in our image to creating a democratic
world the only way to do that was
outside the relations of dominator and
dominated to somehow escape from that
and the way to do that
wilson thought was through international
organizations and through working
through those international
organizations to help other countries
rise up to the level of the united
states and the west in terms of
democracy and advanced industrial
development so those were the two
lessons that he drew
flash forward to to uh 2001
uh 2002
iraq
is in the center of what used to be
the the age of empire it's a it's a part
it's part of a region that still suffers
from the scars of this great imperialist
project that begins in the 1870s iraq
itself is created out of
these by the french and the british
after world war one
i thought that it would take maybe 10 20
years for the backlash to come uh from
our invasion as it did eventually in
iran it took from 1953 to 1978 for the
big backlash to come
in iraq it took about 10 or 20 minutes
or 10 or 20 days for it to occur and
we're still in the middle of it finally
let me just say in conclusion that
if you compare these two events the
philippines 1898 and iraq in 19 in 2003
they're similar in many respects but
there's some important differences
when we invaded iraq we were still when
we invaded the philippines
and annexed it we were still a
second-class power and that act was
itself a kind of sideshow in the world
stage it was like the battle between
argentina and and great britain over the
falklands it was a minor event
not so our invasion and occupation of
iraq
iraq is at the center of the world
economy as we're
about to learn i suspect
um
and it's also at the center of uh the
the continuing struggle between west and
east uh between uh
nationalism uh and uh american and
european
it's uh so to do that
we'll have repercussions that won't just
last for 10 years 15 years but perhaps
for most of this century
so in my sense if so what my book
concludes i think is
that this case of amnesia led to a very
grave error and one that will imperil us
in the future
i have one question for you
and then we'll move on and that is uh
fear you begin by talking about fear
and what i want to know is or what i'd
like to hear your thoughts on
uh is how does the factor of fear figure
into your explanation or not for a
collective amnesia as you refer to it
and b
our attempt to deal with the question of
imperialism in the middle east
well you mean fear is a motivating
factor in our case i i don't think that
that was the that was the central reason
i think fear was the central reason why
we went into afghanistan and went after
the taliban
but what happened in the case of iraq is
similar to what happened in the
philippines in the philippines uh it
come comes on in the wake of a first of
all traumatic incident blowing up of the
main in cuba the battleship made 200
killed
right then we go to war
it's our first overseas war and we
succeed miraculously i mean at this
point it was still that still the civil
war was still overshadowing american
sense of themselves and it gave it
created this incredible buoyancy uh this
feeling of what a british journalist
called an illusion of omnipotence that
we could do anything and that was
central to the idea that we could go in
and we could take countries like the
philippines and in mckinley's word
civilized and christianize them the same
thing happens after uh september 11th we
go into afghanistan it looks like it's
going to be a long protracted struggle
rumsfeld in october and early november
is still warning that it's going to go
through this bitter winter into the
summer who knows what's going to happen
the taliban fold up in two months by
december they're out of there we've had
virtually no casualties and you have
george bush talking about oh people
thought we were a paper tiger but now we
know differently there was at that point
a kind of illusion of omnipotence that
swept washington there was the idea that
we couldn't we that we would be able not
simply to remove what i what we still
saw then as a threat of weapons of mass
destruct particularly nuclear though
again this gets foggier as we go on
uh but that we could also transform this
country and in so doing transformed the
mideast so it was a kind of elaborate
pipe dream based on this illusion that
we could do everything and that's the
that so it wasn't fear it was it was
more fantasy
thanks i think that that's going to be a
theme we're going to hear about all
afternoon which is illusion so i'm going
to move now from illusions of
omnipotence to illusions of
outsider power maybe and turn to ty
jones who wrote a radical line from the
labor movement to the weather
underground one family century of
conscience
first of all i'd like to thank this um
the festival and the organizers for
putting me on this very distinguished
panel
during this week's debate i heard terry
accuse the president of wasting the
military resources in iraq instead of
using them to hunt al qaeda in
afghanistan
and only a few days earlier there were
reports in the papers that the fbi was
thousands of hours behind in translating
the conversations and documents that
could possibly contain clues to another
terrorist attack
yet from all accounts the bureau is
right on schedule when it comes to
pressuring peace groups here in the
united states
and to me that seems like like the taste
of iraq in afghanistan a case of a
misdirected energy
it reminded me of an evening about a
year ago i was sitting around at my
parents house in upstate new york they
were out to dinner and i was watching a
basketball game when the doorbell rang
there were two men on the front porch
one was a short guy with red hair and he
had sort of a nice expression on his
face
the other guy was a tall guy with dark
hair and he had a real mean expression
uh there were these black jc penny off
the rack suits and their shoes were very
shiny i noticed down on the street there
was a car and it was obviously a rental
car
now i knew who they were the moment i
opened the door
i was about two-thirds of the way
through reporting this book radical line
which is a multi-generational history of
people in my family's decades of protest
[Music]
my father jeff jones was a leader of the
weather underground and my grandparents
were
communists from brooklyn
so i knew from my research that the
federal bureau of investigation had
always taken a pretty keen interest in
the activities of my family
they had followed my grandmother annie
stein since the days of the great
depression she had made a speech as a
college senior back in 1933
saying let's not spend our energies
proving that we are not reds if fighting
for lower tuition fees for the rights of
the negro if that be red then let's be
reds
well somewhere in that audience there
was an undercover agent and it's pretty
easy to picture his pencil flying across
his notepad at the line if that be red
then let's be reds
she was 20 years old when she made that
speech and that forms the first page of
what became a very long fbi file
you know the admission of being a
communist even seemed
bold today
and it never could have happened in the
1950s
but in the 1930s when she made that
speech
my grandmother could look around at the
student protests and she could see the
labor strikes and she really believed
that a working man's revolution was
about to take place
she had no way to know then that by
choosing communism she had chosen not
the yankees but the mets and that the
whole rest of her life would basically
consist of one political defeat after
another
she married and moved to washington d.c
to be part of the new deal
and her files from the 1940s show her
neighbors just knew that there was
something fishy about her and her
husband uh they were suspicious of the
magazines that they subscribed to and
they really hated the fact that they
often had black friends over for dinner
um one night when my grandparents were
hosting the housewife next door this is
a quote attempted to overhear the text
of the conversation by listening at the
air shaft of the bathroom of her
apartment however she stated to the
agents she was unable to overhear
anything with any degree of satisfaction
and they would you know the neighbors
would let agents sit in their house and
stare through the blinds at the the
stein household
uh you know for someone writing a family
history
having the fbi chronicling your
relatives every move is actually very
helpful
they have things like the immigration
records from my great grandparents uh
they they have like iq test scores from
high school and they interviewed all
their old college professors
but unfortunately the files are also
filled with lots of helpful pages that
look a lot like this
and this could be very frustrating
all right that's my prop
my father and the other members of the
weather on the ground disappeared in the
winter of 1970 they changed their names
and they started traveling the country
their plan was to lead this guerrilla
movement in protest of the vietnam war
there were about maybe between 50 and
100 or 200 of them and j edgar hoover
had about 9 000 men
his men were trained and equipped with
all sorts of high-tech sixties sleuthing
uh breakthroughs the fbi laboratory
which was world famous had a serology
lab to study blood samples it had
something called a petrography room to
match shoe patterns and a whole team
devoted to hair and fibers that was
second to none
hoover called weatherman the most
violent persistent and pernicious of
revolutionary groups and he said the top
priority for his men was to bring the
well-known new leftists mark rudd bill
ayers jeff jones and bernadine doran to
justice and he was sure that he would be
able to do that in a few weeks
yeah with all these resources
this band of hippies managed to make a
mockery of his bureau
and i've seen the memos memo after memo
they have to ink up their hand stamps
and they write negative results negative
results and they have an unknown stamp
that they put next to addresses and
whereabouts just unknown unknown
now the weather underground is not
really remembered for its many successes
30 years later
but it definitely is undeniable that
their main victory was an eluding
capture by the fbi
and during the time that they were
underground the bureau itself really was
humbled by a series of
reports of illegal procedure and ileal
wiretapping and in fact all of the
federal charges against the weathermen
were had to be dropped because of bureau
of malfeasance
my parents were finally caught in
october 1981. i was four years old at
the time and my name was timmy maynard
we were living in the bronx it was on
october night we were eating spaghetti
and watching uh the world series
when you know to a four-year-old let's
say i knew there's about 20 fbi and nypd
agents dressed up in full
riot year with m16s and shotguns and
they uh stormed in you know searched the
place and took my parents off to jail
they had been underground for 11 years
so they had escaped capture for that
long
so anyway last year i opened the door
and i saw these two guys there was one
tall mean guy and one short friendly guy
and i knew instantly who they were
this had been 70 years now that people
in my family had been getting visits
so the friendly guy flipped his badge at
me and asked to talk to my father and i
must have looked totally freaked out
because he was like don't worry he's not
in any trouble
and i thought all right well i guess
this is just a social visit and maybe
they're here to sort of reminisce about
the good old days
uh
so i said well he's not here but maybe
he'll be back in an hour and then i
thought oh no i said i said too much i
totally you know let down the family
side
so then as soon as they were gone i
called my dad's cell phone number and in
the old days he was famous for his sort
of clandestine instincts but now the
phone started ringing right next to me
on the table so he left his phone at
home
anyway they got back the agent sort of
asked him some questions about an old
case and my dad told him to call his
lawyer and cut the conversation short
but i was inside and i was still
unsettled just by that one brief
encounter
and i just you know for me and probably
for most of us just going through our
daily
tasks to stress enough and i realized
just how difficult it is and how
important it is that there always are
some americans who are willing to live
this life of opposition and also a
protest
thanks tai
this is my question for you this is um
an emotionally very powerful
book
and it ha it's why why is this camera on
the audience all the time
i i have no idea is there a reason he's
been filming the whole time thai was
waiting we would prefer you didn't uh
film the audience would that be okay
okay
thank you
okay or you don't have to film at all
that's the fbi's camera
[Laughter]
i was about to say you're safe at nyu
but whatever
um
um but when you're reading the book
particularly in the company of these
other books that are um more distant and
not personal stories my question was how
did you intend this book what is was it
a memoir from which people would draw
their own conclusions about how the
united states treats its dissidents
or was it it was it more of a call for
people to understand their obligation as
citizens what how did you intend it and
what genre and what were you
hoping that readers would get out of it
well i i never wanted it to be a
straight a memoir i mean first of all
it's not about me so that's what you
think of about a memoir i mean i the
last chapter begins for the sentence i
was born
on april 30th 1977 so i i do sort of
show up at the very end but i'm really
just a child you know coming from
journalism school i always wanted it to
be reported history and there's a lot of
history in there mixed in with the
family story i mean i think that the
more family you get the better the book
is
that stuff is more dripping at least in
my experience
okay tom what's the matter with kansas
how conservative has won the heart of
america all right thank you very much
yeah so that's the title of my book uh
and uh what's what's the matter with
kansas i'm from kansas
um
and
in a lot of ways it's about the other
side of this question that we've been
talking about that tai was describing
here it's about the people on the uh on
the other side of the equation uh oh
[Laughter]
and uh
it's about the people who were duly
outraged in the 1960s and who uh have
remained outrage ever since
sorry
hang on hang on
can you hear me
can you hear me
we don't want you to film the audience
there's something for you to take
we really we don't
is that
well the audience doesn't want to be
seen that's what they've said
so that's the name of the book is coming
out early next year
that's a classic okay
all right put me on the list man i want
that book
so okay so what i've written about is
the people on the other side the people
who don't mind being filmed actually no
they do they they they would have a
problem with that as well uh it's a book
about about uh uh populist conservatism
the kind of angry snarling um right-wing
culture that you see every time you turn
on fox news or
turn on your am radio or something like
that in a lot of ways oddly enough
mirrors the culture of the left but we
aren't going to talk about that right
now
and there's also a personal element to
it because this has been going on all my
life you know i was sort of brought up
in the world of the backlash as they
used to call it in the late 60s and as i
as i continue to call it and there's a
sort of continuity from those remember
the angry hard hats down in lower
manhattan beating up the anti-war
protesters there's a continuity from
that to you know the snarling bill
o'reilly
today or to the you know the the
thinking of ann coulter or something
like that it's all part of the same
culture
and so my idea was to study that culture
and as i said i was i was sort of
brought up into it brought up in it
since i came from what is i guess the
reddest
of red states uh that would be kansas
where every county except for two went
for uh george bush
and um
so
uh you know i thought i would write this
book about the about the red states
about pop conservatism and the kind of
people that
are voting for george bush and the first
thing that that you notice about all
this is that it's a kind of inverted
form of class
revolt
and the conservatives talk about this
all the time the the various
working-class supporters that they have
or you just you know turn on the tv and
watch what's going on in the campaign
bush is out there touring towns in west
virginia you know dying steel towns in
ohio and he's meeting with these uh
these fantastic receptions these
enthusiastic crowds and it's you know
it's conservatism that has that has put
these people in the in the in the
terrible
position that they're in so my book is
also it's an investigation of this
particular historical irony that we're
living with that conservatism you know
which has been off and on in power ever
since the early 1980s or the late 60s or
you know depending on how you want to
look at it
has done terrific harm
to the working class way of life and yet
there are still great numbers of working
class people that are willing to uh vote
for someone like george w bush despite
it all that's that interests me and i
think if you're going to study american
cultural history that has to interest
you because that's very very
peculiar right so the idea of the book
is to come up with an explanation for
that and
what so i did it in a number of
different ways obviously i interviewed a
lot of people in kansas uh and uh
described the political situation there
but i also sort of immersed myself in
conservative movement culture and i
watched fox news all the time and i read
all these conservative bestsellers
uh you know and i got them all at the
thrift store so don't worry
and uh
and the first thing that you notice in
this conservative literature is that the
way that they have a different way of
talking about social class than you and
i do
when they talk about uh social class
they're you know it's not necessarily
about money
it's always about authenticity
it's always about what kind of person
you are what kind of car you drive uh
how down to earth you are what kind of
church you go to or if you go to church
at all the kind of products that you
consume and you saw this especially in
the sort of red state blue state
literature of the last couple of years
where they were forever you know the
sort of
the pundits were forever going down the
list and saying well people in red
states drive chevys whereas people in
blue states drive volvos right or uh
conservatives that vote for george w
bush you know they go to uh
uh burger king or whatever whereas
people who live in the in the blue
states like to go to their snob boutique
restaurants where they eat brie and
drink you know chardonnay and you can
fill in the stereotype it fills itself
in you know the stereotype already and
uh and this campaign this election of
course has has proven to be
uh you know an exercise in this sort of
stereotyping with the you know george
bush and you know against uh well bush
and kerry who are basically from almost
exactly the same
social background where even members of
the same secret fraternity at yale right
and yet one of them always comes across
as a man of the people
uh he's one of us as they always say and
the other guy is always supposed to be
this snob elitist that's the word they
always use for him uh you know because
he
he knows how to speak french you know he
goes windsurfing uh and you can go down
the list of characteristics the things
that that they're trying to that they
try to pin on on john kerry
um
so class is about uh authenticity
and the way these these these
conservatives look at the world
uh the ruling class isn't say the
fortune 500
or you know the people who own america
uh the the the the
uh the lords of the press you know you
think of all the the the uh
uh all the terms that they used to use a
hundred years ago the the robber barons
all this sort of language that doesn't
mean anything to them when they're
talking about the ruling class they mean
what they call the liberal elite you've
heard this term before because they mean
us we are the rulers of america by this
logic and it doesn't matter to these to
the conservatives that liberals have
been out of power effectively for you
know 30 years
and that you know conservatives in fact
control all three branches of government
that doesn't matter liberals are always
the ruling class they're in power all
the time
uh and they stay in power through a form
of uh of uh i guess you would say
conspiracy on my way up here on the
train i was reading a new book that was
just published the other day uh making
this argument again i mean the
conservatives never tire of hearing this
you know repeated and repeated and
repeated that liberals
are a kind of intellectual ruling class
all to themselves you know they got
their high sat scores and they just want
to see the world dominated by other
people with high sat scores and that's
why
that's right and uh strangely though not
me i always get left out of this and i
want you know i had high s.a.t scores
damn it anyhow
but like you know they want they want
they always want judges making the laws
rather than state legislatures and and
they want regulators controlling
everything rather than we the people and
this sort of thing and so the old
industrial questions of
of of the of you know of the 1930s about
who owns who has power those are always
brushed aside it's always about liberals
with their you know their effete
ways as spiro agnew used to put it
they're deracinated
cosmopolitan tastes you know they're uh
it's we're dominated by intellectuals so
conservatives believe
that they are the victims
uh in in society and this is another
point that they just hammer home
endlessly there's even a book out there
that you know how they love these books
with the one word titles like bias
arrogance
treason
slander one of them is called
persecution okay this is by rush
limbaugh's brother and the uh the idea
and it was a bestseller i mean and the
idea of the book is that you know the
the real people of america the the good
god-fearing church-going people of
america are persecuted right christians
are persecuted right here in the us of a
by uh by the liberal the dominant
liberal elite class by this this this
class unto itself that you know doesn't
ever get elected but still manages to
dominate us and so they understand
conservative politics in the republican
party as a form of revolt this is the
real way of talking back to the to
society's masters is by being a
conservative they really honestly think
this that their movement is a rebellion
against uh you know a form of
intellectual tyranny
uh and this is i i think what gives
their movement its incredible power i
went to both uh parties conventions
and you know watched all the speeches
and did all the things that you do and
the democrats although they're out of
power in all three branches of
government the democrats came across as
though they were still they're very
complacent they were the party of power
they were speaking for the consensus of
of of of right-thinking people the
republicans were in revolt these this is
the party with their fist in the air
right this is the people who are mad as
hell and aren't going to take it anymore
conservatives have really captured that
language that social terrain that used
to belong to my team that used to belong
to the left
and that's i think one of the things
that gives them uh that gives them the
real power that they speak this language
of social class
and they speak it very effectively and
that they understand themselves in in in
a class revolt
another important factor
about concert pop this pop conservative
culture and that's the what i call the
denial of the economic
you know if you read someone like ann
coulter she'll tell you that it's uh
it's it's fruitless and and uh and and
you know a waste of time even to talk
about something like enron everybody
knows that you know business
is natural
the free market system is the state of
nature this is even you know possibly
god ordained and it's an expression it's
automatically an expression of of the
common people it's a democratic
expression to be against it or to
question it is you know so deluded it's
not even worth considering business
issues are off the table for these
people for the for the sort of
conservative movement culture everything
is about uh the culture wars
all the fights are over the culture wars
over the ten commandments over gay
marriage all over this kind of thing and
so the the economic questions are
completely off the table and this is
also a great historical irony because as
these questions have been sort of
removed from our politics um they have
sort of reasserted themselves in
everybody's life i mean class is back in
america you know just look around you
where they you know
you know we were just earlier in a
building named for king juan carlos of
spain you know here at nyu this is i
mean this is a society organized for oh
well okay i'm going i'm going a little
too far there but
um
um what was i going to say now i've
forgotten
but this is something that i trace
especially in my home state of kansas
where the the affluent suburbs of kansas
city where i grew up are today so much
more affluent than they were uh you know
25 years ago when i was a kid they are
off the scale they're it's a heaven on
earth it's you know it's fantastic it's
beautiful the private police forces the
armies of gardeners the gigantic homes
from the 1920s the houses on my street
that you know they're they're when i
grew up there are still a number of
modest homes in this part of kansas city
but they've all been torn down and
replaced by these you know gargantuan
hulking chateaus you know uh just when i
was there i was there a few days ago and
they had wrecked down another one one
that had been very large before and
replaced it with something that was even
bigger you know with several two-car
garages and this kind of thing and
that's happening all over the country
and then at the other end of the state
you have of course your low-wage
slaughterhouse workers who get paid
almost nothing you know and toil in the
really degraded conditions
you have your aerospace workers in in
wichita you know unionized people that
are constantly
fighting with management and constantly
losing and it's a terrible battle for
them
and uh and your farmers and i mean
family farmers nobody has uh you know
these people are just in in a terrible
terrible position and have been for
quite a while all of these groups are
essentially republican in kansas today
for different reasons of course you know
for some of them it's just it's your
classic republican contentment i am rich
i want to keep it that way for others
though it's the culture wars it's this
angry uh sense of this is a way to rebel
against
the powerful people in society the way
to get back at the liberals is to go out
there and cut the rich people's taxes
you know that'll do it
so
i wanted to say one other thing can i do
that
uh and this is the uh
the one of the central themes of all the
stuff that i'm talking about is
anti-intellectualism
uh people on the left and we when we
talk about the right we always assume
that it's that it's all about racism and
i found very little traces of that uh in
the the conservatives that i studied
almost none what you do find over and
over and over again is this deep
mistrust of intellectuals
they talk about well
don't take my word for it read the book
what's the matter with kansas it's
called
i just want to point out two things
about that book and one of them i want
to ask you for a very brief
sort of elaboration on the first is
something you skipped over at the
beginning and i i don't think we need an
elaboration but i just want to you make
a wonderful connection between the
proletariat literature of the 1930s the
leftist literature of the 1930s and the
conservative literature of today yeah
and it's sort of an amazing connection
that you draw and something worth
reading about and i have one more thing
i want you to make sure that they know
about this book which is that
um you talk about television and the
impact of television not just ann
coulter and news shows
and spin shows but actual
you know sitcoms and reality tv and the
idea that a sort of amoral world from
the conservative point of view is going
on on television yeah and you you you
make an argument or at least to me you
made an argument that there is a
some kind of political disconnect that
the political debate is between
conservative politicians in washington
and liberal hollywood people and somehow
the democrats aren't even part of the
debate that's a yeah very good very good
observation uh let me th those are those
are two of my favorite things to talk
about and since i'm i'm in new york this
is like one of the only cities in
america where people know about
proletarian literature of the 1930s
i i know because i bought a lot of it
you know at the second hand bookstores
and and junk stores here in new york but
it's i collect this this is this genre
of literature from the 1930s it's kind
of a hobby it's not a particularly good
literature you know there's a lot of
these novels about you know
guys riding the rails and and you know
uh migrant workers and this kind of
thing and the i guess the best known
example would be dos pasos or steinbeck
or something like that but uh
um
and the reason i got interested in it by
the way just an aside is that the sort
of the first novel in the field was set
in kansas city it was called bottom dogs
and it was about uh orphaned kids in
kansas city in the 1920s written by a
guy called edward dahlberg who
ironically later became this very high
brow sort of a very different sort of
literary figure in the 1950s but anyhow
so i'm reading this literature and uh
and reading you know ann coulter uh
david brooks and the all of the you know
the various right-wing books uh all the
stuff about the red state blue state
literature all at the same time and it
strikes me how incredibly similar they
are there's this essay by a guy called
mike gold mike gold was the literary
editor of the daily worker here in new
york
not a he wrote one really good novel but
we're not going to go into that now but
i was he had a famous uh argument with
um
with a thornton wilder a totally
forgotten no thornton wilder's not
forgotten right he's the playwright that
wrote well i don't remember what he
wrote but anyhow sorry our town right uh
mike gold was was you know lambasting
thornton wilder and he was doing it for
all the same reasons that today's angry
conservatives lamb based the blue state
people he was a feat he was devitalized
he spoke french you know he was he was
he was you know not manly you know all
these say the same reasons and he was
doing this very effective manner it's
the same stuff the red state blue state
literature is the same stuff it's all
this old literature from the 1930s and
these old stereotypes that the you know
the the the leftists used to apply to
the you know the uh to to to the rich
people at the time with their top hats
and their you know their uh a feet
devitalized air right but now they apply
it to liberals so they've totally like
stolen this class literature in this
class and maybe hey they're you know
they can they can have it for all i you
know for all i care but uh but they've
taken this class stereotype and applied
it to liberals and your other question
was about the uh the culture industry
and i i'm glad you brought that up
because
one of the quotes that i always like to
read at these events is from gary bauer
remember this guy
ran for president in 2000 uh very
conservative used to be the head of
something called the um family research
council but check this out today he's
the head of something that he calls the
campaign for working families okay so
he's already you know he uses the class
language all the time
and here's what he said about uh uh
there's this article in the new york
times just a little while ago where they
were talking about the culture wars and
they asked gary bauer to explain you
know how
why the culture wars are so resonant for
people and why they still get people so
angry and he said this
joe six-pack doesn't understand why the
world and his culture are changing and
why he doesn't have a say in it
now listen that's really powerful that's
what i say that's what people on the
left used to say that's alienation we
don't have a say over the conditions of
the world and that's true he's right
about that the weird thing then is and
they make this this
conservatives always make this very
strange turn okay they get very angry at
the culture and in my opinion
justifiably so i mean who likes to turn
on the tv i mean you turn it on you get
angry immediately so do they so do we so
does everybody but then they say
it's like that because of liberals
tv is the way it is movies are the way
they are our newspapers are the way they
are because of liberals okay
so and i and this particularly annoys me
because i spent all these years doing
research on the way that
the cultural products are actually
produced right why does madison avenue
do the things they do does madison
avenue you know make those those
insulting ads because they're liberals
is that why they do it i mean some of
them are liberals but it isn't why and
that's not why they make the tv shows
the way they do and it's not why they
make the movies the way they do
but right and wrap it up frank so the
thing is though to really to understand
why they do those things you would have
to you would have to take economics into
account you'd have to examine the
conditions of production and they won't
do it it's easier to just brush it all
off and blame liberals for it perfect
um
we're going to go a few minutes over
because we started a few minutes late
because it took time to set up so don't
worry um
when you were talking about titles you
know i have to say these are the longest
titles in the history of books so maybe
you could air a little towards it could
the one word title would be better i
think so i'm going to turn to craig
unger he wrote the house of bush house
of saud the secret relationship between
the world's two most powerful dynasties
thank you can you hear me now
uh i came to 9 11 a little differently
from a lot of people for a couple of
reasons one is the bush family and my
own family have an odd relationship we
didn't actually know each other but my
father and uncle had gone to yale and
andover with bush seniors so we actually
had photos of george h.w bush in our
family
albums
in
about 50 years ago both the bushes and
the youngers moved from the new york
area to texas
in 1959
i attended camp longhorn with george w
bush
and in june of that year came the
election he still doesn't talk about in
which we were both voted campfire
lighter of the week
and finally long after i thought i was
done with him i i just graduated college
in the 70s and i was getting my one of
my first apartments off campus
in cambridge massachusetts and there as
i came into this apartment i was about
to rent was a floor-to-ceiling poster of
george bush senior uh running for
congress and i i was getting the
apartment of his son our current
president and and this was a time to try
to tie things together a bit when uh
you saw the bushes over the in
generational terms uh moving much more
to the kind of values uh you're talking
about in kansas uh from this old eastern
establishment family
and this was also a time where the when
the weather underground was going around
but bush was at harvard business school
then and he was the the only
reminiscence of him from that period was
he was chewing tobacco which was a quite
a cultural statement in cambridge
massachusetts in 1972.
the other way i i came to it was that as
a reporter i started covering bush
senior during iran contra and iraq gate
and i became very interested in the
relationship between the bushes and the
saudis
so when 9 11 happened uh i i was
horrifying as it was in the weeks and
months that followed i was stunned by
the way it was covered or rather the way
it was not covered
by the press
and the even the new york times put out
a book on the subject on 9 11
called out of the blue
and to me it did not come out of the
blue there were events and relationships
that led up to it
and i was struck obviously by the
relationship between the bushes and the
saudis this to me was absolutely
extraordinary that when you look at 911
if you take out saudi arabia
you have to ask would 9 11 have happened
it's not just the 15 out of 19 hijackers
were saudis or that osama bin laden was
saudi
al-qaeda was created and funded by
saudis
and here you had a close close
relationship that was completely
unprecedented in the history of the
white house
never before
has a president of the united states
much less two from the same family
been so close to another foreign power
and yet no one was looking at this i i
people thought i was nuts back then
calling attention to this um and i
started googling like mad at my computer
late at night and i remember i
immediately got to the carlyle group the
the giant private equity firm
in washington dc
and uh some of the people in the
carlisle group some of the partners and
advisors included
george bush senior at one time george w
bush was part of it james baker
frank carlucci
richard darman former prime minister
john majors and so on
and there were a lot of saudis and what
was striking as i googled around was i
saw also on the carlyle group
uh saudi names
who were accused of funding terrorism
and i remember i started saving this
stuff to my hard disk and then i saved
it on september 23rd 2001
and then a few days later the carlisle
group website
was dismantled and when it went back up
uh there were no saudi names on it
so i said maybe i should start to look
into this and that's how i i got into
the book
um
i began to trace the relationship
between the two families i mean it was
also
uh and and i trace it back to 1974
when a young saudi named solemn bin
laden he was exactly my age he was 25
years old at the time
and he came to houston texas a
multi-billionaire
he was head of the saudi bin laden group
which is
roughly uh an american saudi equivalent
of bechtel a mammoth construction
company multi-billion dollars uh they
they're
actually a conglomerate that does
business with disney uh with goldman
sachs with snapple hard rock cafe i mean
couldn't be more westernized
in many ways uh and but back then they
were looking for friends
uh among american politicians and i flew
down to texas and i spent a couple of
days with a guy named james r bath
who allegedly had links to the cia he
was in the had been in the texas air
national guard
and become close friends with george w
bush
with bush's father this is back in the
70s with james baker with lloyd benson
and with john connelly
but he also started representing solemn
bin laden
and in his investments in the united
states and this was the beginning of uh
uh the bush saudi connection
uh and i over the next 25 years
i traced a total of more than 1.4
billion dollars
in investments and contracts going from
the saudis from the royal house of saud
uh
to companies in which the bushes and
their allies had had very prominent
positions i'm talking about companies
like harkin energy the carlyle group
and haliburton
harkin energy was it was a fascinating
case in point to me
here you had a tiny struggling oil
company in texas
it was drilling one dry well after
another
according to internal documents it was
three days away from uh from bankruptcy
this is in the late 80s and early 90s
and suddenly from out of the blue
uh the saudis put in about 25 million
dollars and these are some of the same
saudis uh that have since been accused
linked to these uh islamist groups that
are funding
uh
funding al-qaeda
and
what struck me in all this too is not
just that here you have an unprecedented
relationship i i think the media
coverage of this has just been abysmal
this has become something that is taboo
in american uh mainstream media uh there
was a
one of the the articles that convinced
me that i could go ahead with this one
it was sort of one of those kernels uh
that make up the book that i knew i had
to be able to prove there was a story in
the wall street journal in 1991
and it showed uh how the saudis came to
bail out hearken energy uh and it was
through multiple front groups there was
one front within another
um
and the wall street journal did a
terrific piece on it it linked it to the
corrupt uh bank bcci which was sort of
the template for our current uh
terrorist financing this was a
saudi-dominated bank that helped fund
osama bin laden
uh
back in the 80s
the owner of it was a man the chief
owner back then was a man named khalid
bin mahfuz who had come down with salim
bin laden to texas
and he helped bail out uh he was his
family invested in the carlyle group and
all his uh subsidiaries bailed out
harkin energy now in 1991 the wall
street journal thought this was a
terrific story and they did a fabulous
piece of journalism on it what what's
interesting about it today
is that it's far more relevant today
than it was back in 1991 back then yes
the
george busceny or was running for
re-election
but now george w bush is not just the
son of the president he's the president
and the saudis are not just affiliated
with a a now defunct
bank that was corrupt they've been
accused of funding terrorism and and so
the question that was staring me in the
face right after 9 11 is
how can you possibly fight a war on
terror
if the president's family is doing
business who is so close with some of
the people who may be financing it
and and i i went to to answer that
question i went to september 13th just
two days after 9 11 i began to look at
that day in some detail and on that day
prince bandar the saudi ambassador of
the united states visited the white
house
it it's impossible to overstate how
close he is to uh
the bush family that is uh he goes on
hunting trips with bush senior he drops
by kennebunkport maine crawford texas he
comes to the white house
with no invitation and just runs
upstairs for dinner
uh he uh
so he was there in the white house that
day
and this is where the war on terrorism
should have begun
this is where bush should have said
listen 15 out of 19 hijackers were
saudis
uh saudis funded al-qaeda we need
transparency into the islamist charities
that have been funding it
we need your help
instead
i traced eight planes that started
leaving on that day
people were not interrogated many of you
may have seen this in in fahrenheit 9 11
but i go into in great detail in my book
uh people were not
in even the most ordinary criminal
investigation you would uh interview uh
innocent people you would take do it in
a formal way
this was the worst crime in america in
history
but uh
there was basically no formal
investigation going on then
and uh
as we know now
even before then just five hours after
the attacks the administration started
thinking about how can we go into iraq
which of course had nothing to do with 9
11.
um so thank you
can we take a few questions
okay so here's what we'll do you these
you're signing books right
they're signing books so you can ask
them their questions then i just want to
say a few things um to
close up
first i want to read to you just two
sentences from my favorite journalist
who's walter littman who in 1914 wrote
about the american american nation we
are unsettled to the very roots of our
being there isn't a human relation
whether a parent and child husband and
wife worker and employer that doesn't
move in a strange situation we are not
used to a complicated civilization there
are no precedents to guide us no wisdom
that wasn't made for a simpler age we
have changed our environment more
quickly than we know how to change
ourselves i think because of books like
this and authors like this that continue
to ask questions and bring these books
to you we're going to get a better
mastery of our environment and a better
understanding of the world to come so
join me in thanking these authors
[Applause]
for more information on new yorkers book
country visit their website at ny
isbookcountry.com
[Music]
in 2002 italian journalist carlo benini
broke the story that forged documents
were used by the bush administration to
show that iraq was trying to obtain
yellow cake uranium from niger he
chronicles his investigation and other
stories in his new book collusion
he spoke about it recently with
journalist craig under
thank you very much we're uh
we're very happy to be back at the press
club to do this event
tonight um
i i am from melville house publishing we
published
this book
collusion
international espionage and the war on
terror
written by carlo benini and giuseppe de
vanzo
two reporters who
michael isikoff of newsweek magazine
called the woodward and bernstein
of european reporting
he called them that because they broke
what may be the story of
this young century which is the story
that
uh president bush's reasons for going to
war in iraq as stated in his infamous
16 words of his state of the union
address
his reasons were based
on documents that had been faked
and planted
by the italian secret intelligence
agencies and it was bernini and devonzo
that broke that story
as collusion points out uh it's a
collusion is about more than that it's
also about the abduction
by the cia of a of an innocent muslim
cleric from the streets of
of milan
taking him to
egypt to be tortured
it's about
secret meetings in iran i'm sorry in
rome
between
officials from the pentagon and
officials from the iranian intelligence
agencies
and in short it's about
something called competitive
intelligence
which is the creation
by international espionage agencies
of fact
from fiction in order to support
baseless policy
giuseppe
devonso and carlo benini
report
for la repubblica magazine and
carlo benini has also
written for newsweek magazine in the bbc
he will be speaking tonight with one of
america's great investigative reporters
craig unger
who is a contributing editor at vanity
fair magazine and the author himself of
the book
house of bush
house of assad about the connections
between the bush family and
middle eastern oil money
tonight's discussion will go on for
about 45 minutes to an hour
and we are being filmed by c-span for
later broadcast
so we will also be doing a q a
after the discussion ends
and all we ask is that you wait if you
are called upon
to voice your question that you wait
until a microphone
is right in front of your lips
so that the viewers at home can hear you
as well
um so without further ado would you
please
welcome craig younger and carlo benin
[Applause]
uh carla would you like to thank
yeah well first of all thank you um i'm
obviously happy
very happy to be here tonight and proud
um you know
it's quite a
it's quite emotional for me
i would never say
when this story began
almost
four years ago in the summer to 2003
when
when we got these uh
this fake document
on
an alleged deal between niger and iraq
for 500 tons of
yellow cake or
uranium ore
and
it was
i mean
this story took
uh almost uh
three three years and a half of uh
painful work um
i must say that um there were
more than a deadlock during
this reporting job because
um
i don't know if some of you knows
uh italy and how uh
how difficult it is to uh to report that
this kind of this kind of issues
and it was difficult also because of for
for a long time this story could
couldn't make its way
in washington and in the
in the press corp american press corps
then
something happened
and
let's say that between rome and
washington on the two sides of the ocean
uh this story blossomed
and uh
and i and i think that um
what what still strucks me
is that it's it sounds
a complicated story but it is not
uh the story is is an easy story is a
simple story once you get to the bottom
of it
uh as dennis was saying before
the niger story
as well as other story you will you will
find in the book
is is a story of deception it's a story
of manipulation
that as all the
all these kind of stories um
you
since you have something false at the
origin
of turning into
something
truly false
at the end
you never know
when you have to deal with this kind of
story you have also a negative evidence
you can report that something didn't
happen but it's very difficult to say
and to assess what really happened
it's this sort of a shadowy world i mean
the intelligence world is a shadow world
and i mean sources are always and seldom
not reliable
sources try to to play with your
reporting
trying to use you
so it's a it's a very slippery ground
now what we can definitely say after
four years
and that's why i'm so happy to be here
discussing with you about this
is that facts circumstances
are quite solid
and i think i'm disputable
uh the
the intelligence
on on which the u.s administration
built
uh the case for war
was a bunch of fake documents badly
forged documents
uh set up by
a few
italian characters
who who could remind you
of a yellow cake follies more than a
yellow cake
major niger gate or
uh spying game
uh at the bottom of it there is this
uh former police officer rocco martino
uh had the chance to to talk to him and
he he is simply i mean
in a word it is a windler yeah he had
been
he had been begging
uh for for the last 10 years
knocking at the door
of different intelligence agencies
exchanging
row intelligence
no no no matter if there was good
intelligence or bad intelligence for for
pocket money sometimes
and this guy was the perfect guy to be
used
in in a disinformation manipulation
campaign
that probably started in
as an italian job
you know you
you put together something that you know
could please the big brother in
washington
and you think that
that will be
you sell something the americans will
realize that is
nothing
so exciting
but in the meantime you you will have
uh your credit
unfortunately
uh the story took took another the
direction
of the americans i mean the u.s
administration
took this faked intelligence seriously
dramatically seriously
but not because there were any
um you know there were
the possibility that this this junk
material could be taken seriously
because the u.s administration
found in those documents exactly what
it was desperately looking for
the smoking gun the mushroom club
and uh
and so i think that
at that point also the italian
intelligence
uh was taken aback was uh was probably
surprised and was frightened
promise i i do think that from a certain
point on
at least from fall 2002
no one of the key characters of this
story could
control
the story as a whole i mean
the story had taken off
and turned into something absolutely
without any control
and between washington rome and london
uh there was the between this perfect
triangle uh
a really perfect storm
set up
and
and so at the end rocco martino the
swindler made his way to the state of
the union address
and i
i know that that night
january 2003 in rome somebody was really
terrified
because they suddenly realized
that the story
had gone too far
and the story had gone too far i mean
iraq was invaded
and then what happened afterwards was a
desperate
desperate
cover-up
not to
you know disclose what had happened
between rome london and washington
uh
from this point of view
uh italy was a wonderful
uh let's say
fishing pot because
everybody started to panic so
sources started to talk
rocco was uh abruptly
discharged from from the from sismi the
the italian cia he started to talk as
well
and
as soon as uh
people sources within sismi started to
talk it was also difficult for the u.s
administration
to uh to stick on the original
assessment of this story
uh dick cheney vice president of us in
september 2003
was still saying that the niger gate was
a matter of opinions
and um
and i think that at that point it was no
no way that it was no matter of opinions
was a matter of facts
uh
the the italian the italian job was
the uh the fake documents but italians i
mean the sesame intelligence the italian
intelligence played also a key role
in the second leg
of this
of this let's say
manipulation uh manipulated operation
and it was the
so-called
aluminum tubes
you probably remember i mean if you have
uranium pure uranium
uh you i mean it's useless unless you
are able to enrich the uranium
and so
when the second lag of the story was
that there must be a credible evidence
that not only
saddam
had acquired
enough uranium from niger
but he was also trying to acquire
the basic tools to enrich uranium so the
so-called aluminum tubes
to for the centrifuge
uh necessary for the enrichment
now
again the italians
because it was true that saddam had
acquired
thousands and thousands of
aluminum tubes that that was
to replace
a missile system
that was sold by the italians to the
iraqi back in the beginning of the 80s
uh the italian intelligence had this
information since the beginning and they
didn't disclose it
they let the americans and the u.s
administration making the case that the
aluminum tubes were for the centrifuge
was for the enrichment
so again you have the
the sismi and the italian intelligence
playing
this kind of of job
uh
at the end as you as you see
you have as i was saying before
you have uh something
false
turning into something
truly false so at the end at the end of
the day
you probably reading the book you will
probably laugh of rock martino and you
will probably cry because
i mean
no one can buy it that rocco martino and
that that actually was the
uh conclusion of the an official fbi
investigation on on the matter
that rocco martino
made it by his own
uh unless you you believe that again
an italian swindler
uh can you know can
put in a cage the two
most important intelligence agencies in
the world the mi6
and the cia
that was not the case um in the cia lots
of people
made since the beginning
and rang the bell since since the
beginning that
that stuff was some had to be discarded
the administration went in another
direction
and i think that the recent libya trial
in washington was
i mean perfect
uh i mean
disclosed
clearly
how the niger story
obsessed the you the white house
in the summer 2003.
so uh that's about niger
again you will as dennis was saying you
will find other things in the book
uh the um i i said to dennis that
my book is probably sort of case study
um
because you have different stories but
at the end you will see the same the
same footprint in each story different
stories different settings
you will find some stories
that have been within italy
the so-called intelligence operation in
the war on terror you will find the
story of the three egyptian fishermen
uh
you know just thrown in a jail because
they were accused of being suicide
bombers they were supposed to
uh to uh to bomb the u.s cemetery in
italy
uh
in ancient
and the it was a mocked operation
you will find the story of more than a
dozen moroccans
thrown in a jail because they were
supposed to poison the water the water
pipes of the u.s embassy in rome it was
completely fate
so you i mean and you will probably you
know reading these stories you will
probably go back
to uh to to the headlines
in the u.s press uh
you know advising about another big
success in the war on terror
and and you will find and then and then
i'll
i'll stop it
and you will find also the in the last
chapter what dennis was
was mentioning before
uh the rome meetings
at the end of 2001 in december 2001
rome was the set of an important meeting
between
members of the office of a special plan
from the pentagon
and uh sesame agents iranian agents and
and members of the sheri the supreme
council iranian council
uh
at the time they were sheets
expert rates in iran
these those meetings were overviewed by
michael ladine
at the meetings there where there was a
manuka
urbani
a well-known fabricator
in the u.s intelligence community
and during during these meetings uh the
what i mean the issue
was the
future of iraq and invasion of iraq
and
during these meetings
the uh it was clear that
washington had opened
a shadow diplomacy channel with tehran
um
you will see in this chapter also uh
i had a chance to talk for a long time
with francis brooke who was
the right hand of hakne chalabi
iraqi national congress
you will read what he what what he
what he says about
the the weeks before the invasion
when uh
chalabi and and and uh
is uh
enters iran
uh thanks to the uh the iranian
iranian secret service
and thanks to the uh us troops on the
border of turkey
to meet the iranian intelligence in
tehran to share intelligence regarding
iraqi troops on the ground
so
there is enough i think there is enough
enough stuff to reflect about uh what
happened in the last five years
and i think that there is enough enough
stuff to to say that we are still i mean
we as as reporters as public opinion we
are still waiting for a single answer
i mean the the
the more
uh was discovered the less we knew from
from the from the u.s administration as
well as from the italian government
um
we i have to say that
if the white house didn't say much about
the niger story as well as the other
stories man i mentioned before
uh italy said less than less
and so
we're still waiting for an answer i hope
that
that's why i'm so happy that um melville
decided to publish this book
i hope that maybe the i mean the new
congress the new political frame here in
the united states will help to uh to to
go to the bottom of it i hope
and uh it will be i think it will be uh
i mean i think that
the u.s
uh public opinion i mean the u.s
citizens deserve it i mean the uh when
when when uh when i was reporting this
what i thought that you know
lots of the us soldiers has uh have lost
their lives
and uh and and you know i don't know if
rocco martino realized or was thinking
about it or if pollery
had the former head of sismi
is thinking about it but
but i think that at least we all deserve
some answers at this point
thank you
[Applause]
i'd like to ask just a few questions and
i i i guess what was striking to me when
it became apparent that there were no
weapons of mass destruction in iraq
there were a lot of investigations in
congress uh that into
what were american intelligence failures
but i want to wonder is this not maybe
uh instead of an intelligence failure an
intelligent success a successful black
propaganda operation and and i wonder in
that regard if you can sort of take us
through the break-in actually took place
before bush came to took office it was
uh new year's eve or new year's day in
2001 the change of the year
um
did the break-in was it just because uh
rocco martino was a swindler trying to
sell some documents or was there a real
uh operation going on at that time and
can you sort of take us through that and
see how the documents uh came out of
that that is uh to many americans
especially when the uh uh when bush gave
his state of the union address in uh
2003 he referred to british intelligence
so it appeared the intelligence appeared
to be coming from many sources how did
all that happen
well the uh
the uh the break-in i mean the the niger
ambassador is a tiny apartment flat
in the center of the city or you will
never know that he's an embassy
beside the a small flag
uh sometimes you find it sometimes you
don't find it
i've mean the first time i i went there
i mean the flag was not on so i had to
ask to to the doorman
where is the embassy they said i will
try to the third floor okay
and so it's a tiny apartment
few people i mean basically just one
lady taking care of the
whole all of almost everything going on
in the embassy
the lady the name of the lady is uh
laura muntini
is the lady laura we we we refer to her
in the book as lady laura la signora
as they call her at the embassy
la signora was a
was a sesame mall
and had been a sesame mall in the
embassy back
at the end of the 90s
and
she
she played a key role i mean she her i
mean
as a mall her role was to
uh
put all the conditions to
get as much informations and as much
material she can
in the embassy so the break-in
uh
was was simply
a way to cover
what
on routinely la signora who did okay on
behalf of sismi now at this point we
bush had not taken office but we knew he
was coming into power yeah and
especially there is an interesting point
here
uh italy
was well known in the intelligence
community for having
good intelligence on african countries
uh on african countries the intelligence
community usually
rely on two intelligences
the french intelligence and the italian
intelligence
so um
basically
the sismi had been monitoring
the niger embassy
uh
for a long time back in the 90s and back
in the 80s
i mean the they watched closely to that
embassy also during the first gulf war
in 1991
and in fact
some of the documents some of the fake
documents
the set of in the set of documents
you'll find
lots of documents
back to the end of the 90s
and so what happened i mean
the break-in was was a way to cover a
routine or routinely work by la signora
in collecting informations collecting
materials
uh
in the fall two times i mean probably
probably as far as as i understood we
understood
uh the original idea was to use this
kind of informations and materials for
the usual trade-off
between
intelligence agencies
then in the summer 2001
and
obviously after september 11 2001
the uh the situation changed
dramatically
so what was thought
in the summer 2001 was arthur and hotter
in october 2001
can you can you explain a little about
the relationship between the berlusconi
government and the neocons why
would the italians have wanted to do
favors
curry favor with the neocons and the
bush administration well
the
the the former italian government
central right government has a strong
link to the new economy they had a there
was a key figure the ministry of defense
antonio martino
at personal also personal uh links with
the neocon
uh
circle
but basically berlusconi made no secret
uh once he uh he he took the uh the post
that he wanted to establish
a privileged relationship with bush
and
as you probably remember after september
11 there was a rush
of
european prime ministers to be in
washington
to talk to the white house and at the
very beginning berlusconi had some
problems he could make the white house
only
around mid-october 2001
and mid-october isn't is a key is a key
date here because mid-october 2001 is
exactly
when the first
uh intelligence from sees me arrived to
the cia
and the first entire piece of
intelligence is about is a large uranium
deal i mean
i don't know if it's just a coincidence
but it's quite it's quite interesting
that in the same day that sesame
transmitted
the informations regarding the
elect this alleged deal between
niger
and and saddam
berlusconi was here
and
knowing
berlusconi
um he i mean there is no there is no
doubt
that the italian administration was
eager was eager to
contribute in some way to the war on
terror
and from this point of view
uh the niger documents were perfect
because
the italians could take the glory
and eventually not taking the blame
because you know in the intelligence
world you can say okay i told you what i
knew
i don't know if it was true or not but i
told you you know
so
and it's it's perfect you know
and it fits uh it fits perfectly
with the kind of approach berlusconi had
to the war on terror
and it fits perfectly with the approach
that paulie nicola pollard former
chief of the italian intelligence had to
the war on terror
i had the chance for the book to
uh interview pollery
three times researching for the book
and especially at the beginning
the man made no secret that you know the
some way the the the niger documents was
wasn't up was an opportunity
in terms of the intelligence exchange
um
and he tried to say that and it's quite
true that i mean when he took the post
and again
remember the day nicola pollari took the
post as chief of the italian
intelligence in mid-october so
mid-october 2001 is a blossoming season
for you know in the war on terror and in
exchange for
for for for this kind of information
and again
uh what is interesting here is that
probably the italians at the very
beginning thought that the american
could
could could realize easily
and in a short time that the information
was groundless
but since it didn't happen they decided
to bet
on it
and in fact
on february 2002 there is a second piece
of intelligence from the italians
and this time the second piece of
intelligence is more so
i mean it's more more precise more
credible
because what happens is that the
italians
transmit the
verbatim text of this
alleged deal between the
niger government
and the iraqi
now now the information was these
documents were leaked uh to uh panorama
magazine and to the british can you tell
us a little about that
yeah the documents uh i mean again in
february 2002
or when the the documents based the
documents but the content of the
documents the verbatim text the
substance of the documents
arrived on the desk of the cheney
in the meantime the italians
started to exchange the same content
with the british
and there is a rule in the intelligence
community that
you don't have to share with other
intelligence agencies your sources so
the italians went to the americans
saying we have this piece of
intelligence
the americans are not allowed to ask
about the source the only question they
can make is is it a reliable source
and italians in february 2000 2002
told the americans it is it is relevant
a reliable source
same same stuff with the british
february 2002 they
they exchanged with the british and they
have the you know there is a reasonable
uh i mean there is a reason in doing
that because
you exchange informations with the
intelligence agencies that are
uh
you know more
um
that have more expertise on the field
and he and the british intelligence have
def has definitely an expertise on this
kind of field
but again at the british you don't have
to say
your source you don't have to say that
you have already exchanged this kind of
intelligence with the americans
the first check the americans duh do
is with the
british they go to london saying hey we
have this piece of intelligence we have
the same informations
wow
so it's the first it's the first i mean
it's the first
important check for the us
administration
in the meantime
today it's february 2002
they moved the french
i mean there's there's always been a
sort of skeptical attitude in washington
and the cia towards sismi
so they move the french and it's
reasonable to move the french because if
we are talking about niger i mean the
french intelligence is probably the best
the best you can you know
the best intelligence on the ground
uh
niger is a former french colony so the
french displayed and dispatched
a team
to double check the informations they
already had because the french had this
kind of junk
since summer 2001 and they have already
discarded it
but the french decided that since there
is a war on terror
it's it's okay it's important to double
check
and as you will read in the book
alain shui former number two of the
french intelligence i had the chance to
to talk to
uh reminds that they picked up the best
man they had
almost you know the best squad of french
intelligence was dispatched to niger
they came back and they say hey
nothing it's groundless this story has
no legs
i i actually tried to count i reported
on this for vanity fair and i actually
counted the number of times they were
discovered to be fraudulent and i count
uh 14 separate occasions the cia french
intelligence state department
intelligence
the national security council or
whomever found them to but they still
managed to get into president bush's
state of the union address yeah and and
you see that the the the uh
the decision to
uh to you know to make some sort i mean
to say that the british
had it
was from from you from the point of view
of the u.s administration was a smart
move
because they thought okay
if we say that we have it then we have
we have to be ready to
to justify it
but if we say that the british have it
we have it as well
we know that so we have two
two two different sources
the problem is that they probably didn't
know that the british have the same the
same junk and it's all rocco martino and
it's all rock martino actually you know
and the french too
and it's quite interesting that says me
in fact assists me in the same way i
mean when sees me realize this this
circular game
sesame started saying
well we didn't exchange the documents we
didn't give the documents to anybody
and it was true
they they gave the content of the
documents
so
uh it was another you know it was
another very subtle move italian move
just to try to stay a step a step behind
the you know the stage
and it's typical again of the of the way
that the italian intelligence
uh
played uh the big game of the war on
terror always
one feet and
and one foot out you know just to be
balanced and
and
yeah i mean it's it's incredible but
it's uh you know it's uh it's what
happened
and uh
and february 2002
then joseph wilson
right joseph wilson is dispatched to
niger
this is still i mean at that time
i think joseph wilson has been betrayed
what i mean for the first time because
when when when he laughed for niger
he is briefed on the content of the
documents because when he's briefed that
the cia
the cia informed wilson
what they have what they have is the
verbatim text of the so-called accord
deal between iraq and niger
nobody nobody tells him that
mr patrick u.s ambassador nature
had done a re is her personal
checkings and the informations are
groundless yeah i mean joseph wilson
will discover it once there
nobody tells him
that the french has already discarded
once the informations and are bound to
double check again what they discarded
at the first glance
so
i mean basically wilson is
i mean i'm still wondering why wilson
was dispatched there now the documents
themselves had a report
that a man named
zahawi
uh had who was an iraqi in charge of the
of their nuclear program uh had made
trips to the republic of niger uh and
that was seen as evidence can can you
explain that to us that that's that's
quite interesting
because
well
this is a circumstance where you can
easily see how it works um
in the set of documents
there was something true
it was uh a cablogram
from from the uh iraqi uh from sorry
from the
uh
niger embassy in rome to
may
saying that back at the end of the 90s
the the the at the time iraqi ambassador
to the vatican was flying
to niger
i mean the information is the
information this kind of information is
i mean doesn't mean anything
but if you
take this capitol
and you put this capital gram together
with the with the fake documents with a
deal 500 tons of uranium that trip
you know turns into something very
different
the problem is
that the poor
alzheimer
in 2002 and 2003
was back in baghdad
and
i mean the uh the uan inspector summoned
him
asking for this trip because when the
finally the
u.n inspectors as well as the
uh
international atomic um agency
uh
got the first informations from
from from from the us administration
that it was this problem with the major
niger and and and uranium
and got this name i mean alzheimer i
interviewed him was immediately summoned
in batted
he was interviewed for a long time
and he said what what are you talking
about and he gave plain explanation of
his trip
he gave evidence
and what was he doing there
well he was uh was i mean the the reason
of the trip was that he had basically
another i mean the goal of the trip
according also to shui
french intelligence officer
was that the real aim of the trip was
that iraq
back at the end of the 90s had a problem
of
waste waste um an exhausted
material from chemical and biological
waste i mean they had to find a place
where
you know uh
put this this this uh toxic waste we
have that problem here yeah and in the
african countries
our from this point of view was a good
market i mean so basically uh it was a
trip to find a place
where
it was possible to set a deal like that
and it the trip was unsuccessful
uh but again this trip became another
thing now you you also interviewed ahmed
chalibe and and the niger documents were
not the only fabricated intelligence i
wonder if you can tell us a little about
your meetings with shalaby and what he
was doing
at that time
okay everybody i think knows who ahmed
chalabi is
i had the chance to uh as a this is a
personal account i mean you will find in
the book as well but i had a chance to
to talk to him the first time in the
fall 2001.
um i remember that i was flying back
from from from washington i mean i was
here after september the 11th and four
days after september 11 i was in
washington interviewing james woolsey
and james woolsey
uh
told me in a plain words that the
problem was the swamp
named iraq
so four days after
the september 11 and he gave me a hint
he told me well if i can suggest you uh
something you should go to london you
should try to talk to me chalabi
he has his headquarters in london i will
fly to london in the upcoming weeks
uh i mean he will be the new man he will
be an important man he
he has he's plenty of informations
so i i went to london i knocked the door
of this
knight bridge uh
elegant apartment
and
i remember that the first thing
chalabi told me before the interview
began was
it's a pleasure meeting you
here ham what do you need and i was
quite impressed instead of what i need i
mean what do you mean he said what kind
of information you need we have
everything here
and what is
exactly what he told me
uh he said that i could talk with his
intelligence officers
there were
different different guys working at the
headquarters of inc
it was true i mean you can ask and they
could tell you
you probably remember the salman pak
story
the story of the uh training ground near
baghdad where mohamed hatta allegedly
trained himself
with uh with with the a bunch of other
uh suicide
uh
uh
and and
so they were fabricating uh intelligence
yeah yeah london was a wonderful place
to wear fabric and because you know you
you didn't have the chance to double
check because the problem was there
he
it was simple you know just imagine a
reporter i mean it was not just my
experience was the experience that uh
hundreds and hundreds of reporters from
all over the world went through
you were looking for stories
you were driven by a former cia director
to another guy
well known in the
intelligence community
he uh he showed you the place he told
you that
they were waiting for new defectors
coming in
that if you uh
that if you want you can have
what the defector
were saying obviously you couldn't talk
to the defectors
you couldn't double check anything you
just have to rely on how much
obviously this resulted in stories in
the front page of the new york times
yeah how what happened with your meeting
with uh taliban well he uh i think he
got a little bit suspicious of after a
while because uh i i kept going and
i didn't write a single a single line
so um
now i mean
one one of this man i mean he wasn't
actually was a funny guy he uh at the
second third time i went there in london
and said oh well
you know why why your paper doesn't run
a single story on on on
on child you see the new york times you
see the washington post do you see the
uh
and i said yeah okay you know we needed
we need
more confirmations i mean
and i i remember for example
that um
at a certain point it was 2002 a few
months before the invasion
he told me that uh if if i agree i could
be brought to a training a secret
training camp
in the eastern europe where
iraqi defectors
were training uh under cover from the
cia
and i said well where is this plow you
have to trust us just to you know be
ready to go
and i remember that i mean i didn't go
and i remember that
couple of weeks afterwards i don't
remember the
the the paper if it was the new york
times of washington post or or an
english paper i don't remember but it
was this wonderful story it was a a
picture of a snowy ground
it was a story saying that the baha'i
somewhere
somewhere under the snow
there was people iraqi defectors
stranding themselves and the people who
was talking i mean the source
was the guy in london i've been meeting
for what i've been dating for for for
months so
that how it worked i mean mohammad
chalabi was this
uh and the iraqi national congress
headquarters was was was basically this
uh this work for the press but the same
kind of relationship they had with with
the u.s administration
so they simply feed the administration
with what the administration wanted to
hear let me ask you this uh in in
retrospect it seems if there's a big
winner to the iraq war
uh it's iran and shallaby and a lot of
the other people have had close ties
with iran i wonder if you can tell me to
what extent has this disinformation this
flood of disinformation has it been a
trojan horse coming from iran
well you know what craig i think i mean
i was not so surprised that the
investigation launched on chaliby
on
on the ground of the alleged suspicious
uh link with tehran
just went
nowhere because i think that
this this is really a sensible sensible
issue
for for this administration
i tried to explain myself i mean chalabi
had real ties with iran
the inc
was more than welcome
in tehran at least till
beginning of march 2003
because
you have to you have to understand that
chalabi
could sell himself
to washington
but in the meantime could sell himself
to terran as well
i mean if tehran wanted to know
something about what was going on in
washington charlotte was the perfect man
we will never know exactly what chaliby
had been telling the iranians
that it's sure that chalabi was a more
than welcome host enteran
and again here is a personal
recollection
a few days before the invasion started i
was in tehran
for my paper
uh i mean i was dispatched there
on the uh eastern border
and
two days before the invasion
i had a long interview with
the ayatollah kimi was the at the time
the head of shirin the
council of supreme revolution
and
and was eventually i mean he he died one
year later in in the bombing of the
najaf mosque
at that during that interview he told me
that
he uh the americans were making a big
mistakes because just the week before
the invasion started
they had decided not to rely
on uh
iranian intelligence anymore that means
that till
end of february
negotiations between
us
and and iranians have been going on
we have those meetings back in rome end
of 2001. so it's i think that it's uh
quite it's quite clear that uh and it's
quite reasonable that the americans
besides what i mean the official
statements
we're trying to ensure
the
uh the eastern border of iraq and trying
to reassure
the iranians
that
uh a second invasion could not be
possible till uh till uh till the
complete assessment of iraq
the problem was probably that i think it
was that was a really mistake i think
that the alahimi was was sincere in
saying that
that at a certain point they the
americans thought that they could
uh do
by themselves and that was something
that they paid
uh was a terrible mistake they paid
because
uh the iranians uh started to to play a
role in iraq
uh in in 2003 and then the the role
increased dramatically in it afterwards
so i think that uh
so
to go back i was not surprised that the
investigation on the
chalabi and the iranian links didn't go
farther because i think that if
chalabi
decides to
to talk about it
i think it would be a problem so a lot
of people
could have problems because this is a
very sensible point
i remember i i remember i mean i
remember seeing him last time i saw him
was at the american enterprise institute
uh in november
i guess it was november 2005.
october november 2005 he had a sort of
road show
in washington
and it was at the american enterprise
institute
and uh
and when when when the discussion went
to iran he is you know he was really he
was really tough
saying i mean i don't remember the exact
quote but the i mean basically he was
saying
i i i don't have anything to
hide or to say i can say whatever
americans want to hear
if they want to hear
something like that
and
so i think that iran is still a sort of
insurance the iran issue is an insurance
virtuality
and i don't think that
you know
okay i think maybe now is a good time to
open up questions to the floor
yes i think you'd wait till the
microphone
gets there
uh gerald runner formerly the hartford
current
the uh documents that uh this character
rocco produced
were they in arabic
how detailed were they
where'd they come from
the documents were in french
documents were in french and french
language
and uh where
i mean if you look i mean if
in five minutes you could find out that
the word
bad forgeries uh they they were
you know
basic
you know very evident mistakes in the
stamps in the names of the ministers
and then in in the dates
i mean nothing matched
and what is interesting here is that if
you if you read
the um
uh oversee
overseeing a committee um
the
commission
of the congress the over overseeing
committee on on on intelligence report
it's quite interesting because they say
that when when they reviewed i mean when
they interviewed intel us intelligence
officers about those documents
apparently the intelligence officers
interviewed said that there were no uh
there were no
no
mistakes in the documents there were no
uh you know no clear
um
no clear hints that could lead to the
conclusion that they were forgeries
now to now at this point i have to there
are two possible thing answers the first
one is that maybe and very highly it's
highly probable that when the italians
sold
the uh sold the informations to to to
the americans uh tried to
clean
you know the the whole stuff so that it
couldn't smell too bad
uh
the other the other possibility was that
the u.s intelligence officers who
received the documents
you know intentionally didn't
didn't pay any attention to
the to the mistakes that the documents
carried
yes
i'm sorry if you can wait till the
microphone gets there
i remember reading many um
well not so much not many but i do
remember reading quite a few accounts
skeptical accounts about various stories
leading to the war and i always wondered
why there wasn't more coverage and here
you seem to have been so judicious i was
just wondering whether many of the
italian papers
were equally as
careful
and
what do you
what is expected in in terms of your
deciding that a story
is based in fact
um what does your paper use or do you
use that so many other reporters did not
use
well
um
i think you know you have to be lucky
also sometimes uh i mean i always
thought well what could would have
happened if the first my first meeting
with chalabi would be you know
if i felt in love with shallaby stories
uh i'm kidding obviously i mean the i
think that
uh you know
the
i think that we
as an italian reporter
i was lucky because
uh no one no one speaks or read italian
so we are a small country in a small
country
the press has a small circulation
uh you probably feel a different
pressure
especially in this kind of of stories
um
it doesn't mean that you don't have
pressure i mean
we have pressure and only as reporters
as in the rest of the world
but
you have probably not to forget that
after september the 11th i mean this
country was a country at war
i remember that one of the first stories
i filed from here was
was about the press
i had lots of friends in the u.s press
um
i think they're they're wonderful
reporters
and i was struck
at the time that i you know discussing
with them
i i found different people just
you know
uh really you know
looking in a from a different
perspective
so reporting with a different attitude
i remember that i told to i told one of
my friend
um
you you know you're wearing a uniform
you're you're not you're you're you're
not a reporter i mean you you you're
losing your judgment
and i remember he told me we are at war
so i think that there was
a pressure was an emotional uh uh
approach to to to what was going on
um and i think that i mean fortunately i
mean
i must say that the uh u.s press
uh
excused itself for what happened by the
way i mean italy had the same problem i
mean on a different scale i mean also
the italian press published so many junk
stories
on you know regarding the war on terror
again i'm pleased that in the book there
are at least the two or three stories
about i mean the one i mentioned before
for example the three egyptians are the
alleged suicide bombers i mean that
story made headlines for months
in italy no one excused himself at the
end of the day at least here you have a
press that was capable at the end to say
okay we we made a mistake
we are sorry we should have judged in a
different in a different way
uh
again back to to the question i think it
was it was uh it was a different also a
different attitude but also because
uh
we as italians after september 11 we
didn't feel them ourselves at war
and if if you are
if you are a reporter reporting on a war
if you don't feel him yourself at war
that can help you and you know in trying
to
to put
what you are looking at in a frame in a
context in a broader context
if if i could just add uh
one other italian reporter i believe
deserves some credit as a woman named
elizabeth berba who works for panorama
magazine and she was under special
pressure since her magazine is owned by
berlusconi it's a little like working
for a publication owned by george bush
here
and
she was the one of the first reporters
to whom rocco martino leaked the
documents
and uh she went actually went to the
republic of niger to to check them out
and realize how difficult it is to
transport 500 tons of uranium secretly
across the desert that in itself should
have raised some yellow so she
uh
did not run with the story instead she
she and she wanted to write
to expose them as a fraud
uh
the owner of the paper having to be
president of the country didn't
uh want to go along with that but she
took the the documents to the american
embassy to get a second opinion
and that was another way in which the
documents ended up uh on their path
to president bush's mouth in the state
of the union address in 2003.
uh yes sir
uh what do you know about the
cooperation of the italian intelligence
agents with the cia in connection with
the
the kidnapping of the egyptian in milan
well we uh right right now
we know quite a lot um
the uh the the trial
uh
of uh more than 20 cia agents
and uh half dozen of sesame agents is
set to begin on june the 8th in milan
and the story as in as it unfolded is
now quite clear
on february 2003 i mean the on february
2003 the 17th
uh the buomer was kidnapped in milan by
a squad a mixed squad italians and
americans
and this rendition was part of a broader
program
for which the cia had
had asked the italian cooperation
back at the end of 2002
fall 2002.
and we know that at the end of 2002 and
uh and also before
uh the cia at the time cia station chief
in rome
uh
wrote um had a had a list of at least 12
names of 12 uh
12
arab clerics living
in europe italy germany
france
luxembourg and he um and the cia station
ships
in europe asked for the cooperation of
the local
uh intelligence services
and sisby decided
sismi style
to stay in the store in the same way
that was in the niger story
because what sesame did was
okay
do what you have to do
will you know we will turn our head
around
so basically
sismi was aware of what was going on
they didn't involve i mean sesame didn't
involve him
itself uh on a full scale as a cia in
the abduction
and then what what cisme did afterwards
was just saying no no nothing happened
no the cia didn't didn't kidnap anybody
and if if it kidnapped anybody we didn't
we didn't realize it
it was i mean it was a flat lie and the
lie was uncovered by a long
investigation
of the public prosecutor in
milan uh and now the you have uh you
have the trial we will have the trial
uh i mean it was not it was not an ex
exception
a walmart is one of uh dozens of uh
cases uncovered throughout europe
i think that
there is here there is really a
different perspective i mean
in europe this is a very very sensible
issue because the
abduction practice the rendition
practice
is the clear evidence of the kind of
trade-off between
human rights
and security
issues and
in and and for for europe
it's something that uh
no matter center right or center-left
government that europeans
are not bound to uh to you know to stand
for
uh you will uh you will never find a
single european country
or single european citizen ready to give
up
uh the fundamental uh civil rights
uh in exchange of uh more security
that's probably you know the most
significant different difference and the
most significant problem in the approach
to the war on terror that you have now
in europe and the
abduction issue i mean the extraordinary
rendition issue made it clear very clear
and uh i don't know uh for example the
it's two or three days ago the german
prosecutors
uh
put on
i mean
made an indictment for another case of
abduction
in germany so
as you see europe is uh
is not bound to uh you know to to turn
around
and um
i think that that will cause some
problems in in the near future because
on the other hand i i'm sure that the us
administration will stand by his agents
also because the agents uh
uh
are saying that they did what they were
requested to to do
and that they cooperated with the local
uh secret intelligence services so
i think we have time for one more
question
[Music]
um is there a microphone here
i'm sorry
uh here
uh
i uh
i just uh wonder
i was waiting quite patiently for you to
mention uh
joe wilson and of course his wife but
you didn't mention valerie playing
but uh it's quite astounding that this
mishmash of intelligence was spread out
through all the services you know the
british service the french the italian
and uh
that uh journalists are claiming that
they had no hint of this and are willing
to accept uh very
um very
not very good stories even
that the niger
um
the niger uh uranium was a non
it was a non-story really
uh and i just uh wonder why when did i
was wanted to question you as to when
you started to um
get permission to publish that's what i
wanted to know
well we uh
we ran the first story on july 2003 so
we started publishing you know breaking
the story and then we started digging
and researching and then the idea was to
do a book
uh but
i think that i mean joe wilson was brave
in what he what he did i mean
joe wilson uh did a wonderful
journalistic job journal i mean it was i
mean joseph wilson when he when he wrote
the open ad for the new york times
uh was a reporter basically because he
put a single piece of information in a
broader context
making making it understandable and
making the known story
a story
i think that joe wilson as i i mentioned
him before saying that he was betrayed
the first time when he was dispatched to
to niger
trying to
double check informations that were
known as false
was betrayed the second time that he was
betrayed was not only when
when the somebody decided that they had
to be punished
uh burning the identity of of his wife
but i think that he was betrayed because
i i think i mean i talked to
joe wilson several times in the last few
years and i think that
joe wilson
at least at the very beginning thought
that he could have more
audience
in the u.s press
i think joe wilson
not now now it's a different situation
but two or three years ago joe wilson
found himself absolutely lonely
and
abandoned in some way
um
i mean i think that i mean his his book
was marvelous was full of things
i i don't know uh i i don't i mean
i think that he probably deserved more
more attention when he came up
uh but again joseph wilson uh
from a certain point on was a reporter
was doing the the kind of job that
reporters should do
i mean as as i was saying before
joe the problem with joe wilson
and and the approach by the press would
when you
we were discussing this the the other
night
with with that
i mean the problem is that when you are
obsessed
or trying to be very balanced
regarding your source i mean you have an
official source talking to you on the
background or on the record
and any if you if you have if you don't
have a
a balanced relation with your source
then everything that could come from
other sources or that come from
observation
that doesn't match what with what your
source is telling you it's a problem for
you so again joseph wilson was was the
victim of this this kind of
uh
unbalanced approach because the problem
with wilson was not what was what wilson
was saying that was an enormous story
the problem was his wife
you know
i mean i was quite distracted it was a
typical this you know typical way to
to victimize somebody you were you are
saying something very important
and then you are you're bound
in and then you are thrown in a corner
and you have to defend yourself
by
from a gossip because the gossip was oh
okay he was dispatched to niger because
his wife was working at a cia
so
again he was
that was i think the the worst betrayal
uh for for joseph wilson nobody took
took attention to to the core of what he
was saying
that it was not his wife
but was his trip to niger
thank you first of all before we
conclude i just wanted to invite
everyone downstairs where we're going to
have a reception for the author um you
can get the book and get it signed and
if you have further questions ask them
then and have a glass of wine on
melville house
i'd like to thank both of you
carlo for your great reporting we're
honored to publish this book and and and
craig for being one of the first
americans to spell it out in american
publication
um yeah that deserves a round of
applause
[Applause]
i i want to pose the the the final
question which is carlo i know you've
been covering or we're covering the
libby trial for lab republica
and i'm wondering if you had any sense
from your time reporting
that very interesting case if you had
any sense that
maybe it was a sign of things changing
of of the tactics of of uh competitive
intelligence being revealed and perhaps
uh thwarted
does it did it leave you with any hope
yeah
i mean i
i'm uh
i i mean i'm i'm
i'm looking more confidently to to the
road ahead um
i mean i i think that
uh
i mean facing another important crisis
as the iranian one
i think that hopefully but i i'm quite
confident that
uh i mean this administration this
country but let's say the the
intelligence community
will not repeat the same mistakes
um i would be really surprised if they
if they will if i mean if they're if
they are thinking of of doing the same
kind of stuff
um i mean once they have been burned so
badly on on on on a story like this i
don't think that they're they're going
to to play the same game it doesn't
matter i mean it doesn't mean that they
are not
the the that we are safe that we are not
on a safe ground
um especially because
um
the uh informations informations are
really the uh
uh the uh vital uh blood
of uh of not only of the policy making i
think but also the
uh of every democracy you know and so
uh
playing on informations are is uh is is
is a vital is a vital issue
so i'm i'm not saying that
we are not facing in a time where
the intelligence agencies are
uh
will decide not to play with
informations but probably we are going
to play in a different manner
and uh okay we'll we'll discover and uh
we'll work on it uh i don't know if
there will be an a new ahmed chalabi
maybe
i i'm sure
by the way that uh
rome will
will will be
an interesting uh observing point
because rome has a traditional
link
with tehran
rome is a wonderful city it had always
been a wonderful city for spies for
trucks for swindlers and
and it is an interesting you know point
of observation we'll see
and we will report
carlo benini is an investigative
reporter for italy's law republica
for more information visit their website
at republica.it
distinguish all sound making objects
that you have with you
but i want to let you know a new twist
you may have seen a lot of filming going
on here on campus they're taking videos
which will be
available on
something called itunes u
so if you go to itunes and uh
go to miami-dade college you can see all
the programs that you might have had to
not get to because we have so much going
on at once
and
now
for our next guest i turn the program
over to stephen collier a staff member
here at the college and who has
volunteered tirelessly
as you've probably seen him in the
friend's tent throughout the fair
stephen call you
[Music]
it really is a pleasure to be here today
to
preface the remarks of tom hayden and
craig unger
as i thought about these two authors i
realized they serve as bookends to the
evolution of my politics
and
it became a very personal thing
1968 was a really bad year bad thing
after bad thing after bad thing happened
and finally we came to the democratic
national convention
and tom hayden
was the leader of the protest
and that earned him a seat at the
defense table of the chicago eight and
seven trial
i was a high school senior i read the
transcript of the trial and along with
graham nash i wondered
so your brother's bound and gagged
they've chained him to a chair
in a land that's known as freedom how
can such a thing be fair
tom hayden has been in the forefront of
american social political and
environmental activism for the last 40
years
and is tom lehmann the
national correspondent for the atlantic
said
tom hayden changed america
uh wager that's true but i think the
thing that that
most intrigued me was something i
learned when he finally retired from the
california legislature
they gave him a standing ovation
it was the longest loudest most effusive
standing ovation that anybody ever got
if tom hayden is the front end of my
political evolution craig unger would be
the back end he's been
deputy editor for the
new york observer and
editor-in-chief of the boston globe he
was here in 2004 to talk house of bush
house assad
you know when you get a writer who
between the plot and the prose they just
pick you up they throw you down they
won't let you go
it's a wonderful thing
and then when you find out
it's non-fiction this is for real it
becomes all together something different
and more wonderful
he did that
he's here today from new york city to
talk about the fall of the house of bush
the untold story of how a band of true
believers sees the executive branch
and it started the iraq war and still
imperils america's future
would you all please join me in
welcoming tom hayden and craig unger to
miami
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
i guess you go first
hello everybody
i'm tom hayden and i'm very glad to be
here again
thank you
[Music]
to try to keep this succinct
and allow time for questions
um we're each going to talk for about 15
minutes uh
and
i'm going to talk about my book ending
the war in iraq which i've
i've spent five years six years on not
the book but trying to end the war in
iraq
and i expect it to be a while longer but
there are several questions that you
probably have on your mind
typical of
most people in our country one is what
should the u.s policy towards iraq be
second
how might we end the war
in iraq if that's what the policy should
be and third what are the lessons
of this long nightmare that we are going
through
as to the first
question what should our policy be
in in researching this book
i was thinking of my own experience with
vietnam and how that ended in that
debacle on the rooftops with people
leaving by helicopters
and i was also researching the history
of the neoconservatives
from the 60s until now the people who
are primarily responsible for getting us
into iraq
and trying to get us into a war with
iran
and
i interviewed some government officials
including
the former head of the central
intelligence agency john deutsch
who are masters at
how to get out of wars as well as how to
start them so i thought i would go to
the
the experts but i came upon one scenario
that gave me uh the clue to what i was
trying to say
it was in the
new york times back in
january
2005. and it's uh it's an option
that has been considered in the pentagon
but has not been uh carried out but it's
an option that's there
and and it came close to being carried
out uh but
it's it's
off the table at the moment and i'm
quoting one possibility quietly
discussed inside the administration
is whether the new iraqi government
might ask the united states forces to
leave
what one senior state department
official calls the philippine option a
reference to when the philippines asked
american forces to pull out a decade ago
now what's so important about that is
that i think the most difficult thing
about
uh ending a losing war
is that the the pentagon
and the general establishment the
politicians included
think of themselves as being a part of a
superpower with superpower
responsibilities and superpowers can
never retreat
they can never appear it's a
reputational problem
women will understand it
it's a reputational problem
the strong man can't
surrender can't back down so something
has to be designed
to make it possible for them to
extricate themselves from their own
defeat
this is this the special burden of the
peace movement the opposition
and the philippine option would be one
way because you have a majority of the
members of the iraqi parliament already
signed a petition
calling for the u.s to leave within one
year
61 percent of the iraqi people defend
the right of armed resistance against
foreign occupation
the both parties on the
to the ethnic divide sunni and shia are
overwhelmingly in favor 82 percent of
iraqi public opinion is in favor of the
u.s withdrawing within a year so
the table is set for the united states
government to say we've done our job and
we've been asked to leave
and they can stage a press conference
perhaps there'll be flowers
and a red carpet and stage an orderly
withdrawal
perhaps
the second thing that
mr deutsch the head of the cia told me
was in addition to making a decision to
get out which has not happened
the united states has one
further task to make the withdrawal
possible
and that is to talk with iran
which he identified as the only country
in the region that could make
difficulties for the us in withdrawing
since the paradox is that our government
our neocons our bush white house has
delivered
iraq to a majority of iraqis who are
aligned with iran
we've delivered them to the iranian
sphere of influence anyway
what what was said by by deutsch is is
the complete opposite of the path that
this administration seems to be on
rather than talking with iran and
there's plenty of issues to negotiate
in exchange for the safe and orderly
withdrawal of our troops we're on a
course of escalation or threatened
escalation with iran in addition to the
fact that we have
so far not decided to get out anyway but
but those those are the issues uh in
simple terms until we say as part of a
diplomatic peace offensive that we're
getting out by a date certain no one in
the region will have or in the world
will have a state interest in helping us
get out
but when we say we're getting out they
all will have a state interest in
avoiding the power vacuum that will be
created and there are issues state
interest issues like refugee overflow
humanitarian crisis protection of
religious minorities reconciliation and
above all reconstruction that countries
in the region and in europe as well as
russia and china are all interested in
from the point of view of the interests
of their nation states so the world is
ready to get in but only if we say we're
getting out
so that's the policy issue we're not
there yet but it should be
uh
clear that those of us who oppose the
war have an actual policy alternative
that is not being taken
secondly how do we how do we then get
out when we have this obstacle
of a ruling establishment that doesn't
heed the will of the voters
and pays no attention to the
thoughtless loss of life on the ground
in iraq
because they're concerned about their
reputation which includes their image
geopolitical interests oil industry
interests cetera et cetera et cetera how
do we do it
i
i would not recommend
dreaming about a presidential candidate
getting us out
although we all should vote and vote
carefully and clinically but if you just
look at the three democratic front
runners
you'll find that they all propose a
withdrawal of american forces that will
take until 2012 or 2013.
if you can wait that long good for you i
can't but
there's no
immediate
solution there and if you look at the
leading candidate on the republican side
giuliani
who is chief foreign policy adviser is
the father of the neoconservatives
norman puthorats
he thinks we've already won in iraq and
he says to his christian comrades that
he's praying for us to start the war
with
uh iran a strange thing for mr podorots
but if you look at his record you'll
find
it's not so strange at all so how do we
get out
i think that there's uh an an answer
that also lies in our history
wars are intense experiences and they
can't go on forever and they're based on
what i call pillars or foundations
and the pillars uh
are what i want you to think about the
pillar of public opinion the pillar of
available troops and and uh recruits and
the pillar of budgetary resources to
name three our moral reputation is
another pillar the war will end when
there's enough of you that put your
shoulders to to these pillars of the
policy to bring them down
people pressure against the pillars of
the policy is the way the war will end
my judgment
and it's ending it's just too
excruciating for a lot of you to bear
it's hard for people who have a strong
moral fiber
and have not been put through the
political process as i have
to bear the thought that it may take
five more years or six more years
you want you think five months is too
long five minutes is too long
bear with it because
your labors will be effective if you
think of whatever you want to do
writing a letter to the editor
civil disobedience voting for candidates
anything you want to do is focused on
putting your shoulder to the pillar
until it is pushed down
you already have 55 to 65 of the
american people against the war
those of you who who
are are for an immediate withdrawal have
to deal with the fact that only about 15
or 20 percent of americans are in favor
of that concept but you also have to
deal with the fact that if you come from
a long tradition of standing for for
isolated causes and being a marginal
person
you now are in sync with the majority of
people deal with that it's an identity
crisis i know it's difficult
but you're in the majority and you've
got to push the majority in a direction
so that it becomes
unacceptable
for candidates for office
to
avoid the issue of iraq
and it becomes acceptable in terms of
their primary interest which is
reelection
to call for a speedy withdrawal
you can have an enormous
impact in close races
for the senate
for the house and it certainly looks
like the presidency this year
if the majority of people who are
against the war
were to consolidate their efforts into
a very well organized faction of people
who want to make the difference in close
elections that's what i mean by putting
your shoulder to the pillar of public
opinion secondly
for a war to go on you need the pillar
of troops
fortunately the any any polling of uh
our men and women in the combat zone
shows that they have about the same
attitude as the american people about
19 or 20 percent for immediate
withdrawal about 55 percent for
withdrawal in one year
and
their morale is down because
movements in the past have prevented the
draft they are being forced
coerced into repeat tours of duty to a
point where the
all the officials say the breaking point
for the army is next april when bush
will have to withdraw 25 000 troops and
turn it into an image that he's
beginning to be a peace candidate to be
aware of that
pitfall that's brought on by reality not
by bush's preference
but if you want to put your shoulder to
the wheel
shoulder to the pillar rather you want
to support the right of those men and
women in the field to speak up to
petition to argue against the policy to
be heard at home to be heard in the army
newspapers and you want to go out to the
front gates of dade community college
here or other institutions in miami and
argue with the parents and the students
against the military recruiters who are
trying to turn the next generation into
cannon fodder in a war for the prestige
of the uh rulers of this country nothing
more nothing less putting your pillar
to the wheel to the pillar of putting
your shoulder to the pillar of
recruitment
forgive me i'm trying to be too brief
here
being in the forefront of the counter
recruitment movement
is the way to put your shoulder and your
energy against the pillar of the
military third the money
worse costs more money the longer they
go on because everybody that's wounded
is a new
victim in a hospital somewhere even if
they're underfunded every tank that's
blown up means a new tank has to replace
it so i can't even keep up with that but
you can go to www.costofwar.com
and find out for miami or for the state
of florida exactly up to this second as
we speak
how much money has been spent in tax
dollars by your community and what that
would have bought in terms of free
four-year college scholarships
what that would have bought in terms of
free health care for all children what
that would have bought in terms of full
pay salaries for public school teachers
and what i'm telling you is this the
peace movement will have to expand
to a broader coalition and the bridge
for doing that
is by aligning the peace movement
interest with the interests of senior
citizens in in delivering on health care
at last with the interests of the inner
city in economic development and jobs
with the interests of the
environmentalists and putting money into
restoration of the everglades and so on
so
the budgetary pillar is is the key to
forming a coalition between the peace
movement and the rest of those people in
that 60 percent majority which will
make it more and more difficult for any
of the politicians to vote for the
budget and make it very very difficult
for any of the candidates to support the
budget create an opportunity for local
groups to get candidates to say they
will not support one more dime for this
war and so on you can see what i'm what
i'm saying so that's how the war will
end
uh what lesson i'm going to leave this
to mr unger because he's written a very
interesting book on
the um
neoconservatives who i traced to the
30s to the 60s
to the present time they seem to be the
immortals
to to to quote the subject of another
book that's been presented here
um
but but they're a very very small
faction and the the chief lesson that i
would try to uh get across is that
already uh those of us who oppose the
war
without having the media on our side
without ever being able to speak out in
the editorial pages of the new york
times
we already have done a considerable
amount to finally discredit the
neoconservative doctrine the
conservative doctrine the humanitarian
hawk doctrine the democratic hawk
doctrine
of military intervention
uh as we've seen in in iraq and we
should we should realize that after
vietnam there was a moment that can be
repeated after iraq it was called the
coming of the vietnam syndrome
and the vietnam syndrome was treated
like a medical scourge of some kind
right do you remember it when it was
it was time for gulf war one president
then president juan bush announced by
golly we've defeated the vietnam
syndrome what the heck did he mean i was
asking myself this is 1991.
the vietnam syndrome was this
cultural consensus and norm
that existed temporarily for about five
years after vietnam that said no more
vietnam's no more imperial presidency no
more policing the world
instead reconciliation with our men who
fled to canada bring them back amnesty
for draft resisters and normalize
relations with our enemies like vietnam
all of that was accomplished in large
part
until it was upset uh by the coming of
reagan
and then the re the restart of this uh
madness that we've been through for so
many years so i think we need an iraq
syndrome that
that
creates a cultural norm that makes it
nearly impossible for the next five
years to start another war like this one
and in that space
we have to come forward with a positive
vision about how we intend
to
put forth an alternative to military
intervention neoliberal economics
burning up the oil supplies of the earth
and imposing
bizarre
satellite dictatorships like the one
we've imposed in baghdad and the one
that wants to impose itself in the form
of the christian right wing at home
we have to those four issues are
majority issues
to end these wars to stop global warming
to stop the privatization of the economy
and to stop trying to combine preaching
and power into presidential
authority
and if we do that we will have served
uh our time well because um
there's no recovering the damage done in
iraq only the world hopes that we will
learn our lessons so that there will not
be another debacle like this one thank
you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
uh as a journalist the kinds of stories
that have always interested me have been
what i call the the elephant in the
living room and by that i mean stories
that seem so obvious that you can't
possibly ignore them
yet it seems that people always do
and one of those that got me started on
my current project was about the niger
documents these
the niger documents of course are uh
what was behind the valerie plane wilson
and joe wilson affair these were the
forged documents that said that saddam
had made an agreement to
buy 500 times of uranium from the
republic of niger
and investigating them i found there
were many many unanswered questions but
there's a few things on which everyone
can agree and that is that they were
forged
if you think about it
there's nothing more calculated than
forging a document you can't do that by
accident uh very few of us wake up early
in the morning say oh my god i
accidentally forged documents in french
on stationery from the republic of niger
saying there was this uh uranium deal
the way the the documents were spread
around was quite extraordinary they went
through uh
to many many different sources and they
became released at various times to make
it seem like there was
uh there were multiple sources when in
fact they were really one
and as the more i looked into it i began
to doubt uh we we heard again and again
that we went into iraq because of
intelligence failures that this was an
intelligence failure these were mistakes
and you i began to see that no exactly
the opposite was true
this was not intelligence failure it was
an intelligent success and by that i
mean a successful black propaganda
operation a disinformation operation
i i found
nine
military and intelligence officials from
the cia the defense intelligence agency
the pentagon and so forth on the record
who said exactly that and in the course
of circulating these documents uh i
found that exa that on at least 14
different occasions
they were discredited
by the cia by the state department by
journalists and so forth yet they still
ended up
in president uh bush's 2003 state of the
union address these were the famous 16
words that became the cause for war
as a result i started to look to
to try to find out what were the real
causes of war and i went back
and i i see it very much as a coming
together of two very powerful historic
forces
uh that unfortunately are not going to
end with the the bush administration
they will continue
thereafter and that is the
neoconservatives that tom was talking
about which is sort of an intellectual
vanguard you can trace them to the 60s
uh there are several hundred
neoconservative policy makers are
heavily funded uh with think tanks like
the american enterprise institute the
heritage foundation and so forth and
you'll see them as talking aheads again
and again again as the ex so-called
experts on iraq and iran
and of course the christian right which
is uh arguably the largest political
movement in american history as many as
80 million adult evangelicals a voting
age
000 pastors who effectively act as
precinct captains in much the same way
that organized labor once did for the
for the democrats so i went back and
started to trace their history and how
they came together and and they really
started coming together in in around
1977.
and and they share something in common
that's very profound this shared vision
of american exceptionalism to the
christian right uh we can do what we
want because we we are
our path is ordained by god this is
deeply deeply rooted in america you can
go back to john winthrop's uh famous
model of christian charity in 1630 where
he says we are a shining city on a hill
what he's saying is a shining city on
hill is jerusalem he's saying we are the
new zion america is a new promised land
what we do
is ordained by god and that has been
picked up by the christian right by
george bush and and i i found it i mean
it's an interesting sort of uh tidbit
about how bush got into power if you go
back to the 2000 uh presidential
election uh one of the great uh
followers of the christian writer was
the former secretary of state of florida
katherine harris and if i can can read
some of her views on this she said if
people are not helping or not involved
in helping godly men and getting elected
then we're going to have a nation of
secular laws that's not what our
founding fathers intended
was she when she says founding fathers
she's not talking about jefferson she's
talking about uh john winthrop cotton
mather increased mather and and really a
theocracy
uh we need to take back this country if
we don't get involved with christians
then how can we possibly take this back
if you're not electing christians tried
and true under public scrutiny and
pressure if you're not electing
christians then in essence you are going
to legislate sin
uh bush is very much
a real evangelical but even his story
about how he was converted is not true i
found he has told it again and again and
this is his tie to his base that he was
converted by billy graham uh in 1985 i
believe it was at kennebunkport and
billy graham was asked about it and said
he didn't remember it
but but that's
but that's the least of it i interviewed
uh a guy named mickey herskowitz who is
a houston sports writer and he's a close
friend of george h.w bush the elder
george bush
and he was hired to ghostwrite uh george
w bush's campaign autobiography in 2000
and he told me he was interviewing bush
about this famous so-called conversion
uh in which he was born again with billy
graham
and he he kept asking bush bush couldn't
really remember any conversation that
took place
and finally herskowitz said uh
well did did uh did billy graham say
something like are you right with jesus
and but said no i never said anything
like that
uh herskowitz then gave the tapes to
karen hughes
she put hersco with his words in billy
graham's mouth
and the whole story was was created in
fact i i did interview the man who
actually did convert bush he's a man
named arthur blessed he had a a coffee
house a jesus coffee house in in
los angeles
and uh he was famous for what was known
as the toilet baptism in which bikers
and uh hippies would come in
and they would throw their uh
their drugs in the toilet flush it down
and and and accept jesus and that's how
and he went went to midland texas and
that's how he converted bush
the these two movements started coming
together in the late 70s and in 1977
menachem began
who was the first non-labor prime
minister of israel called jerry falwell
and begin i interviewed his chief of
staff and he realized that that in terms
of wanting support in in the united
states jews were
only two and a half percent of the
american population and evangelicals
were about 30 percent he wanted a bigger
base and he called jerry falwell he gave
him a learjet uh and he started funding
regular visits from the christian right
uh as many as 3 000 members of liberty
university come to israel a year uh
thanks to that program
and you start seeing these two movements
uh with with the israeli right
uh the neocons and the christian right
come together over 30 year period i i
kind of went when i when i hear the the
neocons as describing themselves as pro
israel
in fact they're they're they're very pro
sort of a right wing like good policy
and if you look at what their policies
have done uh obviously it's been
devastating for iraq with four million
refugees hundreds of thousands of people
dead
uh it's been horrible for the united
states and and not just the four
thousand dead americans but our geo
strategic uh vision uh uh our
geostrategic position in the world is
much much weaker today um it's also been
horrible for for israel and it has the
only people who've benefited have been
the hardliners in iran like ahmadinejad
so
um so you you have these two movements
who've been growing growing growing
together and at a certain point once
bush became the the possible republican
candidate the neocons began to to uh
indoctrinate him i can't think of a
better word this happened much earlier
than people realize and it started
by
late 1998 it was reported for example
that when when paula o'neil the
secretary treasury uh in in the book
with ron suskind that that he he was
shocked that they were discussing the
iraq war by the first week of the the
administration in fact it started more
than two years earlier and uh paul
wolfowitz richard pearl uh elliott
abrams would make made semi secret trips
down to austin uh bush senior had
realized
that his son really knew nothing about
foreign policy and he started a series
of seminars
and you see a battle between the
realists of bush senior
uh
generation and the neocons who who
actually win access to bush
with the realist you had uh brent
scowcroft you had james baker you had
colin powell one by one they were sort
of edged out of the camp
condi rice was meant to hold forth on
their behalf in fact she became sort of
an enabler for the neocons and really
didn't stand up for bush seniors uh
for the for the realest vision of
american foreign policy the one man who
kept fighting for it and he's sort of a
tragic hero of my book is brent
scowcroft who as early as the fall of
2001 uh
was trying he saw the world coming he
was trying to stop him and one uh one
way in which you can see how calculated
what the neocons did was starts just
after the election was settled in 2000
and um this is what i call the case of
the neoconcubine
and
uh the neocons realized they wanted to
control intelligence as you see with the
the
uh
bits of disinformation like the niger
documents so they and what better way to
do that than by having paul wolfowitz as
head of the c.i.a
uh and this was in december of 2000 as
the first bush administration was uh was
coming in
uh there was just one problem that uh
paul wolfowitz was then dean
at johns hopkins university's school of
advanced international affairs
and uh it turns
school of advanced international studies
i misspoke because the problem was he
was
involved in an extramarital affair with
a woman uh named shaha ali reza and in
many ways it seemed to be to the neocons
the romantic embodiment of the neocon
vision of the new middle east here he
was a secular jew dating a secular
muslim this would be the vision of the
new middle east wasn't it wonderful
well it wasn't particularly wonderful to
claire wolfowitz his wife of 30 years
and my sources tell me she wrote a
letter gear george w bush you can't
possibly uh have my husband as uh head
of the c.i.a
uh he's a security risk he's not just
having an undisclosed relationship it's
with
foreign national this represents a real
security list
the letter i'm told was intercepted by a
guy named scooter libby
libby was a protege at yale of sc of uh
of paul wolfowitz and he was becoming
the head uh the chief of staff for for
vice president cheney so the neocons
realized that they didn't want to go
through a
uh a horrible um confirmation hearing in
which all this was exposed instead they
called in donald rumsfeld and decided
that that they had to make uh we'll
run intelligence out of the pentagon we
have a 40 billion dollar a year
intelligence apparatus we need a serious
intelligence apparatus but it's designed
to get the truth instead they invented
this uh
disinformation pipeline this eventually
became the office of special plans and
this created the the disinformation they
needed to get us into iraq and you see
it coming out of this uh
uh
relationship with uh
between wolfowitz and shah ali riza
uh the horrible i i don't want to go on
too much about the war in iraq i mean i
i i think um
obviously i think i think the
consequences have been devastating what
what is most frightening of all of
course is that um
that this may continue that that you see
the same thing starting to happen with
regard to iran and if that is to happen
i think the consequences can be
absolutely devastating you will see for
example
if we do bomb iran and we we have a huge
armada in the persian gulf today uh
the the iran can immediately blockade
the persian gulf forty percent of the
world's oil supply goes through the
persian gulf you'll see the price of oil
go up to a good two hundred dollars a
barrel
uh iran's uh cruise missiles can hit
saudi oil supplies the the dollar is
inversely correlated with the price of
oil so as the price of the oil goes up
the dollar goes down uh this is
essentially has the possibility of
becoming a global oil war and uh you
know i think it's it's potentially
devastating and uh
if it happens before for the it can
happen in two ways one is if it happens
before the next election
it will radically change the dynamics of
the presidential election right now the
democrats look at to be in good shape
but i i i think you'll see a big a huge
fear campaign the democratic candidate
whether it's hillary or whoever it is
will will be uh called soft on uh
soft on terror soft on iran and so on
you will see that dynamic go into
play just as we did with the start of
the iraq war and
uh if it happens afterwards
as the election approaches as tom
mentioned norman podoritz who is one of
the fathers of neoconservatism is the
chief foreign policy advisor for rudy
giuliani uh daniel pipes is an another
neocons hardline neoconservatives is one
of the policies whoever wins the
nomination i i think you're likely to
see uh uh as it is
i i not a single serious presidential
campaign who's really a
republican candidate has um
objected to to our current
administration's policies so if a
republican is elected it's likely that
will continue
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
i guess
do we we just call on you and we'll
repeat your questions is that
okay
we'll try to give short answers
if you want to sit in your seat we can
repeat it over the microphone if you
want to draw attention to yourself by
standing in a long line
victor novoski
the question was um will it be different
if a democrat is elected craig
yeah i i don't think any of the leading
democrat
candidates would bomb iran i i think if
we're to really resolve things i think
the most important thing is to bring in
iran diplomatically and i think they
would be under pressure not to but i
think uh
hillary clinton uh obama or edwards
would uh would not bomb iran and they
would they would be under pressure but
they would try to figure out some way to
bring in uh
start talking to iran
years yes sir
we have seen a pendulum swing
against the republicans towards the
democrats as a result of the war
the financial drain it's put on the
overall economy and so on do either of
you perceive this as being a
long-lasting pendulum swing or a
transient event
transient versus what
long-lasting
oh i think
trends in american politics are fairly
short you keep hearing announcements
that there's going to be a
30-year republican majority
this or that but
we're a 50-50 country it's very very
volatile
yes sir
years ago i was a
years ago i was a
special agent in the air force
this information was taught as a
technique to be used on an operations
basis
are you telling me that there's now a
multi-billion dollar agency of
government
involved solely in disinformation
no you have to repeat it yeah i'm sorry
he would
you're he was asking uh is this
information part of a multi-billion
dollar agency no it's not so much part
of a multi-billion dollar agency but i i
believe there have been uh
there was a disinformation pipeline that
grew out of
the
the pentagon the office of special plans
and i think what the neocons did is they
disabled a lot of the mechanisms that
were checks and balances it's not just a
question
of uh
having a weak congress there were there
are mechanisms like the national
intelligence estimate for example that's
meant to be the gold standard in
american intelligence it's meant to be
uh
and and for the first time you see that
you saw that the neocons could actually
cook the books in that and they got
false information into the national
intelligence estimate this is what went
to the senate before they voted on the
war powers resolution and a lot of that
information is simply not true and so
they were able to bypass all the
security
mechanism
mechanisms get it into the national
intelligence estimate and get it into
the press worldwide ninety percent of
the american people believed that saddam
was a real threat that's a spectacularly
successful disinformation operation
yes sir
tom uh
you don't have to speak so loud it's
almost
it's almost impossible to hear you sorry
about that uh okay putting pressure on
those pillars particularly
the uh
the one in regards to the war and
recruiting
um putting people into the streets
do you still advocate
the streets is a very important tool in
putting pressure
and the second question is how do we
repair the rip between the main anti-war
groups in this country right now that
seems to be on both you know like really
big split between answer and
two questions one is
do i still favor action in the streets
and second
how to repair the rift
between the two anti-war coalitions
with respect to the first
of course i favor
action in the streets
but i believe that um
a harder problem for the activists is
how to be active within the institutions
there's a kind of shirking of
responsibility
there as if we don't know how to do it
the next time that the the streets will
become important is when and if iran is
bombed
i have not met a single
activist in the country or group
who sat down and has a plan
for
what do we do
the day of the bombing and what do we do
for the months afterwards
and how do we prepare
to oppose it i thought craig's
suggestions about
focusing on the consequences were very
important
instead i hear a lot of people who
are being you know kind of mystified by
speakers because they're insecure and
they want to know the truth are we going
to bomb iran or not and once they hear
from
certain speakers that we are
it's as if they go away satisfied that
now we know it's going to happen it's
like the people who believed all
elections are stolen
last year and then all of a sudden
the democrats won the election so they
were mystified
i i think there's still i think history
is contingent and elastic and it depe
depends on
subjective factors like what you do
and so the most important thing is is to
try to figure out what are the best
arguments against escalation to iran
and the most effective way to
communicate that to nancy pelosi or
whomever
represents you if that requires a
demonstration
fine
but demonstration in itself is
demonstration of nothing it has to be
a an instrument of a message
on the other question
i don't know there's these two
coalitions i won't name them because it
only poisons the discussion further but
i i
i think because most of the
most of the national
phenomena
in this country that passes as
progressive
is dominated by somewhat sectarian
groups
that have
long-term agendas they not only want to
end the war in iraq but they want to end
everything
and they view demonstrations as a way to
hook people into larger causes
this is pathetic
um
and it's why i've withdrawn from the
concept of national organizing a long
time ago i am a rank and filer
i don't know how to i don't know how to
handle it i just think
people that organize these
demonstrations should be very aware
that they're speaking for millions of
people and what they say and how they
behave is all
a reflection on all of us
if they call a demonstration i'm going
to go
i'm definitely going to go
but they are not the peace movement as a
whole the peace movement is much much
broader
that person would like to ask you a
question please
which is a question for craig can you
get a little closer
here's a question for craig
can you hear me
go ahead quick
how has researching this book been
different researching your life
maybe somebody can repeat the question i
was researching this book different
researching your first book
craig how is researching this book
different from researching your first
book well
well the the shocking thing to me is
i've covered bush senior critically for
more than 15 years and i was very much
persona non grata in his camp for for in
fact
bud mcfarland of his administration sued
me i i was
they hated me what was shocking to me
was that for the first time they started
talking to me this summer and it it's a
measure of how much they hate their son
it really is quite extraordinary and
the first chapter in my book is called
oedipus text
and what you see is that bush
jr
put together an administration of all
his father's worst enemies
donald rumsfeld was a bitter bitter
enemy uh bush senior referred to the
christian right as the extra chromosome
crowd
and he had battled the neocons when he
was head of the c.i.a in 76 and they
went up against him because he was four
day taunt any and he they had somewhat
measured intelligence uh that this that
the soviet union wasn't quite as big a
threat and and they they set out to
subvert it and you saw
uh
very much a foreshadowing uh of what
of what happened with the iraq you had
the neocons uh
uh distorting intelligence and working
with uh two
young men in the gerald ford
administration named donald rumsfeld and
dick cheney
yes
i was just wondering uh i certainly am
in favor of our immediate withdrawal
from iraq i do sometimes read in you
know various magazines about the the
question of our responsibility in having
created this mess and the danger to the
iraqi people and i wonder whether you
think that's something that uh our
country needs to take responsibility for
in some way
and if so what you think would be the
the most effective way to do that in the
context of withdrawal
i i think that i've answered that
question let me restate it that um
there are there there are
going to be a lot of post-war problems
in iraq sectarianism violence
refugee crisis um
failed reconstruction
it's horrible
um
what we what we need to do is announce
that we're leaving as the trigger
that'll get
other parties to to pay attention and
engage
surely we can't possibly fix the
problems we caused
that's that would be like i don't know
you think of your own analogy but it
just doesn't happen that way but
for instance the saudis will want to
protect the sunnis
the iranians will want to protect the
shia majority
the jordanians will want somebody to
help them deal with the one million
iraqis who've been dumped into their
country
syria
likewise
the russians and chinese have oil
interests so do the europeans
so
there should be a
an agreement with the
iraqis to create an international task
force or consortium that deals with all
of these problems
and it can't happen until the united
states agrees to leave because why would
any country
in its mind out of its mind
be associated with a failed occupation
it just brings
problems to them so yes
yes but you can't turn our occupation
into a peace corps
it's not that that doesn't happen yes
um i'm very concerned about the
possibility of war in iran i'm also very
concerned about nuclear proliferation
and uh we are talking about possibly
starting war on the basis of flawed
intelligence like the last time and my
question is about the elephant in the
room which is uh the nuclear might that
exists in the middle east is israel and
mordecai venue and israeli citizen paid
a high price to
let the world know about that nuclear
might and i'd like you to
speak about israel as a the nuclear
might in the middle east not iran and
also about nuclear proliferation in the
middle east
right
i i those are good questions i don't
have answers to all of them except to
say that i i would say the biggest
threat right now would be pakistan which
is a nuclear power and it is teetering
and that that's a real real threat
uh when it comes to uh
uh
iran is
what is consistently disturbing is the
way that we continue to ignore the
international atomic energy agency and
in september israel bombed syria and
they claim uh it was reported in the
sunday times of london and i'm not i
think this is a very dubious report that
they did so because north korea had
given
uh nuclear material to syria and this
was meant for nuclear weapons uh whether
that's true or not i have no idea
but again it's the kind of thing that
makes you you uh
suspect there's more disinformation
going on satellite photos have since
been been uh circulated showing that we
these were from nasa that we saw had
photos of these installations in 2002 so
this doesn't appear to be a new project
and yet it was this kind of bombing run
that could easily set off a war with
iran or it was a test yes
for two days now we i'm sorry for two
days now we've been listening to all the
horrendous things that the current
administration has been doing they've
been lying to us they've been deceiving
us they've been giving us all this
flawless information yet relatively
little of this comes out in the
campaigns of the democrats why is it why
why are they
holding back and revealing all these
things which
we've been listening to for two days
why are the democrats holding back
i think there's two
two reasons and one you can do something
about the first reason is
anybody that has a serious chance of
becoming president
goes through the initiation rituals of
the machiavellian elite the superpower
elite
and they take on responsibilities that
you wouldn't believe that are so far
beyond your imagination
you know they meet with the intelligence
people and so on they've shown where the
how you start a nuclear war
things that you just can't imagine and
so
the number one principle for anybody who
would be president is to protect the
reputation of the united states as a
superpower that's number one
so
they are very hesitant to do anything
that would have them be blamed
for the debacle in
iraq
if it ends they want it to be blamed on
bush they do not want to be accused of
being weak
the second thing is that
while american opinion has turned very
much against the war in iraq it's soft
you know you're not going to the
barricades today
so
they don't feel
they don't feel decisive pressure from
the grassroots
and
excuse me code pink
simply pressuring them
in washington behind
a hearing in front of a camera will not
move them one inch
the only thing that will move a
politician is the threat of defeat in
their congressional district that is the
and i say that with 20 years of
electoral politics
everything else is secondary
to that and you have an opportunity
maybe we've gotten past the grassroots
age i don't know but there's this huge
opportunity because there's so many
close races including the presidential
race
giuliani and clinton dead heat
so you can make a difference but you
only have an effect on these democrats
if they think that you can make the
difference in their winning or losing
that's not done just by demonstrations
although demonstrations are important
it's not done just by civil disobedience
although that's important it's done by
altering the propensity and the
tendencies of voters in their districts
invaded
iraq uh well it's actually i think
fairly clear there if you go back and
read the neocon papers starting in 1992
it's it's really they had a strategy uh
to overhaul the middle east to dominate
it strategically and there they you know
it's interesting how rarely they
actually use the word oil they will say
it will help us protect strategic
resources but that's part of it and and
they saw it as a vision protect israel i
think it's had exactly the opposite
effect
but uh you you can see these in neocon
papers that were written in the pentagon
in 1992 that called the defense planning
guidance paper
in 1996 a clean break was a strategy
paper written for benjamin netanyahu uh
by richard pearl uh david wormser who
became cheney's middle east policy
advisor
and uh in the pro in 1998 and so on
and they had this vision and they're
very much uh uh an echo chamber in which
they quote each other and they
uh it's amazing how little on the ground
experience they had if you you know it's
interesting to me because it seemed to
me very obvious that iran and iraq had
been at war for 20 years gee if we take
down iraq what's it going to do with
iran it's an obvious question isn't it
won't that empower iran
and they saw oh we'll make iraq into a
strategic beachhead and we can go
forward from there and that's why i
think we're in such a threat now but
that they did what they didn't realize
is uh the shiites were part of the dawah
party that had founded hezbollah that
were tied with iran and they they seem
to have
i'm not an expert in the region but you
can find this out and they didn't seem
to know some of the most basic stuff
hello
yes mr mr unger
um
having read your three-parter in
salon.com
on the bush
uh goes into the fraught relationship
between
bush senior and his son
kind of distant non-communicative
with the fault of the house of bush as
you title the book
what of the bush family now what of jeb
he's out there and what of john ellis
working for giuliani
where do you see them going where do you
see the movement that's kind of
metastasized around w going right well
they will he i think w was sort of the
perfect vehicle for them and that he was
sort of a blank slate when it came to
foreign policy and he he was an
evangelical who who had a face that wall
street republicans and a name the wall
street republicans
could embrace so the more moderate
republicans didn't see him for what he
really was they had a phrase and wrote
karl rose camp called dog whistle
politics and which meant that they were
sp
they would say things that would mean
one thing to the base
and something else to the general public
when bush campaigned with roger staubach
for example most people thought oh he's
out with a super bowl athlete to the
faithful they said oh he he's really one
of us
so so you saw that as for what will
happen next the neocons will attach
themselves
try to attach itself with to anyone in
power they're not an elector no one's
ever voted for neocons
yeah exactly
uh so they tried to get in with the bob
dole's campaign for example they tried
with mccain's for a while uh and they
are fixated fixed with giuliani and if
another republican wins they'll move to
him and they may even try with the
democrats if possible otherwise they'll
attack
i think what we're saying here uh
if i could
sum it up is
you have a real democratic crisis here
the amer american people are ready for
the war to end they're ready to vote for
politicians who will end it
they reject politicians who want to
support it and yet
there's a an adroit
heavily financed
conspiratorial if not a conspiracy
conspiratorial elite
that believes in the manipulation of the
democratic process to get us into war
they're the neo-conservatives it's that
clear
and they have to we have to be rid of
them
in american politics
we're pretty much rid of them in
intellectual life cultural life they're
discredited they're even whining about
how everybody's blaming them
some of the neoconservatives are even
leaving like fukuyama has announced he's
no longer neoconservative
but what i've learned about people like
this
from my life on the left and in politics
is that they never give up
in fact the more precarious their
position the more extreme their response
so
don't be surprised if a crisis with iran
is manipulated into the election victory
of an unwitting politician next year and
this becomes an even greater crisis of
the democratic process
that's what they are trying to do
and democracy which they claim is their
goal in the middle east
is hardly among their values at home
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the other elephant in the room
something we haven't heard this week i
haven't much about is the impact on the
internet and the bloggers
on the political process today
okay the question was about the impact
of the internet and the bloggers and
you know frankly i i think
in addition to what tom said one of the
great
failures has been at the mainstream
media in in addressing some of these
issues and you rarely see the neocons
called out on i think most people don't
know who they are i don't think they
know what they stand for
and at least on the internet you do see
that discourse it happens on both the
left and the right but i've heard
estimates of as many as 30 million
people turning weekly to liberal blogs
and it is a place to get serious
information it's a spectacular tool
uh for research
it's sad i think that more mainstream
journalists don't seem to use it more
but uh you know you have to be careful
and double check everything but the same
can be said of the new york times
yes sir a question
for
either speaker a moderator
i'm very concerned that the american
people aren't given enough thinking
consideration to who they do elect as
the individual to be president
uh
you look at the person seven years ago
was elected
and you look at his background
this person had a c grade average in
college his father bought him three
companies large corporations each went
bankrupt one went bankrupt about six
months after he left
it's important that the american people
understand get some background really on
their candidates to know what they're
electing
because uh the price we're paying and
the price we're paying may be more than
we think it is now you know what's
happening in the middle east
is affecting our uh
a whole economy
and now national debt is almost doubled
from 4.7 trillion dollars seven years
ago it's over nine trillion now i
believe congress is trying to get the
debt limit uh raised to 9.8 trillion
this is just the national debt well
actually actually leave us into a
depression actually the
the
american people did not elect
him seven years ago
there was a um
it was a uh
it was this it was a seizure of power in
florida
and in the supreme court
and that is the legacy that we are
living with but it should make us
very very aware
about certain forces
do not settle or
they're they're not acquiescent to the
democratic outcome
they will do anything uh if necessary to
even disrupt the democratic outcome
that's the problem we have some lip
service to democracy but when it goes
doesn't go your way
these people
start attacking the
uh
registrars in florida and and going to
the supreme court to have their way yeah
i guess
treason
sounds like treason well no usually we
have this american exceptionalism that
we're the democracy model that the rest
of the world should follow but
the longer i live the more we seem
similar to other countries
i'm starting to even
it's not a good thing
i'm starting to remember
the awkward smell of tear gas in my
nostrils i was in chicago with you in 68
something was different then i think
a lot of people
a lot of people then in 1968
had
their butts on the line they were
subject to the draft
we don't have that now so i want you to
peer into your activist cookbook tom
what do we do what do we do there's no
time to fully answer that but thanks for
the question i've already said the big
difference with vietnam was there are
many more people being killed and being
drafted so i wouldn't look to that as a
complete model it just can't be
transferred but two or three years ago i
was being tear gassed and beaten up
outside this building
at the um the
the neoliberal circus the free trade
zone of the americas whatever happened
to that fine idea that miami would be
the the center of
uh
the revival of capitalism in
the americas it was defeated so there is
a movement
that is able to at least derail some of
these projects
but
it's not organized enough or popular
enough
to
to transform the country not yet
but i i think that the anti-war movement
against iraq deserves far more credit
than people observe
because
if you think in your head an anti-war
gesture must
involve tear gassing and blood coming
down your forehead
then you'll never notice the impact of
the bloggers
or the voters
but they count too
and if
if if we don't see that
we're robbed of the potential as i said
we have a majority on our side
in my day my dad wanted everybody locked
up
they wanted to send kids to vietnam so
they could become men it was wild now
there's a much more
reasoned
attitude among most americans about
don't get into every war that beckons
there are consequences
and as a result there's a majority
skepticism
how we galvanize that is your question
and
and um
i don't know the answer but we shouldn't
have to be beaten up in order to become
angry
yeah
okay he wants to go to the convention
there you go
tom i was uh wondering it uh um the
vietnam anti-war movement sort of sort
of emanated from the college campus
i don't see that uh in iraq
what are your thoughts about that right
well i teach on college campuses there's
no anti-war movement on college campuses
but they're not being drafted
you know i teach 40 kids a sociology
course on iraq and i asked why are you
here besides your parents told you to
come why are you here in class and they
generally say
i feel terrible that this war is going
on
and i'm not doing anything about it so
at least i want to be able to read 10
books inform myself and then maybe do
something
the anti-war movement according to one
study i saw interviewing people at large
demonstrations was composed of two
cohorts people my age and people their
age so
it's led by people who probably have a
60s background or 70s background
and by
people from military families
and it's followed and supported by
students who naturally
would have no reason to be in the front
line of the movement
because they're not being drafted
but they do participate i think and in
fairly large numbers if there's an
opportunity for a big event
yeah if i can just add something i i
mean i
uh grew up in the 60s as well and and
uh
back then of course if you were a fan of
bob dylan and long hair the chances were
you would never vote for nixon there is
a right wing movement today and it's a
powerful one in the christian right and
when i i traveled undercover with them
to uh with tim lahaye the author of the
left behind series to the battlefield of
armageddon and i talked to young
evangelicals and i would ask them
uh i'd say look your your father makes
forty thousand dollars for a family of
five why are you voting for tax breaks
for billionaires
and they would they would say uh
you know we're voting for our values and
that that if they talk about uh how
strong is your walk with jesus they're
going to vote republican and there is a
movement on the right
we've got time for one more question and
so it's like you've got a candidate
hey tom uh did you ever
get your file from the fbi or the cia at
all under the freedom of information act
and if so what did you learn
in 1976 you're thereabouts
a lawyer in washington was able to
obtain 22 000 pages
on me
most of which were
you know
articles copied from magazines that
craig probably wrote for there's nothing
there's nothing secret and then the
really good stuff the interesting stuff
was redacted
so
i only have a piece of it but
i was part of the group that was
targeted for the for neutralization
under the counter intelligence program
that term didn't mean assassinate it
just i don't know what it meant it was a
broad
effort to depict me as a
suspicious guy who
where did he get his money from maybe
he's a bobby kennedy agent maybe he's a
cia agent
the what i got from those memos was
besides the cats and jammer
nature of these clowns was a
feeling that their primary purpose
and strategy is to divide people from
each other
and after all that's how minorities
maintain power by divide and conquer
everything was about how to turn this
one against that one get this group to
not trust that group
and i also concluded that if i had
another life to live
i would really like to be the head of
the cia or fbi
under a non-military no covert
operations simply trying to objectively
provide decision makers with
a true account of what's happening
because i tell you this they're not
capable of knowing what's happening
because they're so hostile to social
movements and minorities and
cultural differences that they
they couldn't get iraq straight
uh because of this superiority complex
and i think we do need
kidding aside about my being the the guy
we do need intelligence
that is bias free
and that understands how social
movements arise
at the margins and
and and
and and tries to discern
where we have an interest against them
and where we don't because most of it
has all my life has been
trying to work on domestic issues like
civil rights or poverty or environment
being interrupted by wars
that turn out to be bogus or unnecessary
adventures
for all i know this war started with the
overthrow of masadeek in in 1953 by the
i a in in
in iran no
or the wars in central america with the
overthrow of our bends
in 54
guatemala
finally 50 years later they elect a
pro-peace pro-justice president in
guatemala
did you have to have 50 years of
semi-genocide against all the indigenous
people there to get back to where you
were
in 54 do we have to go through a war
with iran
to get back
to where we were in 53
this is this is so sad i just it's
unbearable to me
that
that we are so manipulated and duped and
sent
so much blood has been spilled
by people who are treacherous in the way
they fabricate this information
for power
[Applause]
[Music]
our authors will be out and to the right
to be able to sign books and they're
available for purchase out here
his involvement with the super pac
american crossroads
thank you
they're about
a little less than two months left
before the election in many ways this is
the time this book was
uh designed for because as we enter
these last few months this is when the
election really gets going
and uh to me that one of the great
untold stories is this is not just uh
obama versus romney it's obama versus
karl rove
and he's been behind the scenes the
whole time and uh he has put together
over 1 billion dollars that will be
spent in these last two months and it's
going to we in new york here you're not
going to see much of it it'll be spent
in the battleground states
and uh his super he's become king of the
super pacs
um he has
when you put together his money with the
money that romney has raised and the
republican national committee is a total
of about
1.8 billion dollars
to put that in perspective in 08 mccain
had 375 million to spend so this is a
factor of five and and you're going to
see start seeing it coming out now
and the other thing as i wanted to
discuss about him is that who is he
really what does he do he's a political
operative well how does he operate what
does he really do
uh and and i talked to a couple of
sources about that and one who was one
of his victims said you know there's a a
dark and terrible beauty about what he
does
and i i had another source who was a ci
a former cia agent named larry johnson
who told me that
you know caa could learn an awful lot
from karl rove
and and uh the way he he has deniability
and all these operations he does he's
both very very visible uh he has
something like a 70 percent name
recognition in the united states that's
up there with justin bieber
uh but uh we don't really know what he
does most people don't and and and when
you go back over his history and look at
the things that are starting to unfold
in the election uh
he has deniability
one level after another
uh
to me the story
uh became interesting in a way because i
think most people thought karl rove was
finished
in 2008 when when the bush presidency
started to come to an end
he had been forced out of the white
house in 2007
he was the prime target in the two
biggest scandals of the bush era the
valerie plaim affair
and the united states attorney scandal
bush left the white house with a 22
percent approval rating the lowest in
the history of the united states
and even uh top republican strategists
like ed rollins said that his brand was
tainted forever no one would ever want
to be a bush republican to work with
karl rove
and uh the fact of the matter is uh he
was back working again within a matter
of weeks
and
it became evident to me in 2010 early
2010 about a year after obama took
office
three things happened
the first was
from the came from the united states
supreme court and i think no
person in the united states that i can
think of
has benefited more from the supreme
court
than karl rove
two decisions one
in 2000 obviously was bush b gore which
put his candidate in the white house
and two
in 2010 the citizens united decision and
that open the the flood gates for
contribution unlimited contributions in
many cases
from secret sources with no transparency
whatsoever
that is just
unprecedented in history
um the second thing that happened was
michael steele running the republican
party and he sort of running into a
ditch and he couldn't raise a dime and
and it came to its nader early uh in
2010
uh you may recall there was a
revelation in in los angeles that uh the
republican national committee had been
entertaining its donors at a lesbian
bondage street themed strip club
uh and for the family party of family
values this did not work too well so
they could not raise a dime
and this gave rove his opening so in in
april
he had a luncheon at his house it was in
in washington dc on weaver terrace
it was co-hosted by
ed gillespie a former chair of the rnc
and they had about two dozen people over
and came away with tens and tens of
millions of dollars
and that luncheon alone gave them about
four times as much money as the entire
republican party
so rove was effectively establishing an
apparatus
that gave him an enormous amount of
power and authority with almost no
responsibility he reported to no one but
he had his hands on the purse strings
and this led
to the 2010 legislative elections they
raised a total
of 300 million dollars
and
swept congress they took 63 seats in the
house
and suddenly obama's big advantage was
gone he had no real authority
um
this
money so so the question is what did he
do with the money what is he going to do
with the money it's going to go into the
battleground states
and i i started to to look at what he's
going to do now
i decided to look what he had done in
the past and i found again and again
that a lot of it uh
really had not been reported in depth
um
we
for one one thing i found that he had
was a was a huge technology apparatus
and i went to chattanooga tennessee
and i found a company called smart tech
i i saw rove
about a year ago in ohio and i asked him
about this company he told me he'd never
heard of it well
i find that hard to believe when this is
a company that has a rather byzantine
corporate history
but if you go through all the fronts
within fronts and the corporate changes
and find out who put up the original
money
the original money came from two very uh
wealthy republican donors named mercer
reynolds
and bill dewitt
and i researched them and in the 80s
they had bailed out george w bush uh
several times he
he uh had three oil companies in the 80s
that went belly up and each time they
came to his rescue
uh they were also baseball royalty uh
bill dewitt owns uh st louis cardinals
uh and his father had owned the old st
louis browns
and um
they gave
bush entre into his ownership in the in
the texas rangers which was the one
uh
the only lucrative investment he ever
made i mean he put in six hundred
thousand dollars and came away with
about 15 million dollars and this
company
smart tech which started out as quite a
legitimate technology company soon
became a republican operation
and it's all good and well that
republicans or conservative groups
should have their their um
websites and so forth but this was very
unusual and i saw uh george w bush
43.com was there uh the republican
national committee hosted its websites
later the swift boat veterans for truth
hundreds and hundreds of conservative
groups were there again that's all all
fine and well but
it this company which is highly highly
partisan
also
over time acquired some contracts that i
i think probably not should not have
gone to to such a partisan company
and let me just say two of those
uh one was uh if you're in the white
house your emails according to the
presidential records act
are public documents
and they're supposed to be hosted
on whitehouse.gov
but rose made sure that his emails were
hosted on smart tech and that 80 of his
staffers who other people who worked
with him in the white house also had
their emails there
so
when rove was investigated for
the valerie plame affair and again in
the u s attorney scandal
suddenly 22 million emails were deleted
and these are all government documents
and and
they have never been found
so that that was one thing he seems to
have gotten away with
um
another thing was in 2004
smart tech played a central role in the
presidential election
and the secretary of state of each state
part of their job is to oversee a fair
and impartial election
and you may recall in the 2000 election
uh kathleen harris in florida was
secretary of state of florida and she
also happened to play a central role in
the bush election and
there was considerable controversy over
that
well
a very similar thing happened in ohio in
2004 when where ken blackwell was
secretary of state
and again he was supposed to oversee a
fair and impartial election but he
happened
also to be co-chair
of the bush cheney re-election committee
and he decided that uh to tabulate the
returns for the 2004 election the
secretary of state's computers weren't
enough and they needed to get another
set of consu computer servers so who did
he go to
but smart tech
and smart tech's role in this is uh
raises a lot of an enormous amount of
very very interesting questions and i i
went through the returns with people who
studied this there were civil lawsuits
uh you could see when the returns came
in that night and what happened as that
night were on on uh i believe was
november 2nd 2004
it was a very very close election
it was clear the election would come
down to who won florida who won ohio
these were the the last two key
battleground states
uh around 11 o'clock
the networks finally called it for
florida and that meant there was one
crucial state outstanding ohio
whoever won ohio would win the electoral
college
the exit polls were in and they showed
kerry winning ohio by 4.2 percent
uh suddenly millions of people started
logging on to the secretary of state's
computer
uh in ohio traffic went through the roof
it went up 700 percent that meant that
computers in chattanooga tennessee had
kicked in at 11 14 p.m
and suddenly
in county after county that reported
there were just these striking anomalies
and in the next 10 counties in a row
and this raises a lot of serious
questions about who actually won the
election
uh i i went about as far as i could in
tr tracing this down and
in terms of of pinning it down
uh
conclusively unfortunately there were
there were still some unanswered
questions and the reason for that
is that again and again
all the evidence vanished mysteriously
and there was a court order as a result
of one of the lawsuits to impound all
the ballots
but suddenly
over a million ballots
were damaged or disappeared
in 2006 a new secretary of state a
democratic secretary of state was
elected in ohio and she was about to
take office and went by uh the her new
offices just before she formally took
office and when she went in she saw
everyone there under the direction of
the old secretary of state the
republican ken blackwell was shredding
thousands and thousands of documents
and finally uh
in this civil suit a man named mike
connell was scheduled to testify he'd
done one he'd been subpoenaed once and
uh deposed once and given one deposition
he was scheduled to give another and he
was rove cyber guru he supposedly had
all the answers
and uh on december 19th
uh 2008
uh his plane crashed i know pride
so there were a lot of unanswered
questions about that
um
i i think when we get to the current uh
uh you know two other things i'd like to
talk about before we uh
uh open it up to questions um
one is
happened just two days ago a man named
don siegelman went to jail
and he was the former
governor of alabama
and the u.s attorney scandal i think is
something that was widely misunderstood
and people didn't really understand the
impact but
it's one thing that karl rove was
heavily involved in
that that has a lasting lasting impact
today
and uh the scandal was widely reported
as that eight u.s attorneys lost their
jobs because they were not towing the
party line
but in fact i think there's a much
bigger scandal that really escaped
attention
and the and the question is
what about the us attorneys who were
towing the party line what were they
doing
and the answer is they were prosecuting
democrats
and i found uh in the first term of
bush's uh bush's first term alone over
200 politicians were prosecuted
and uh 85
of them were democrats
and uh
you what what you found
don siegelman is probably the most
egregious example
he is two days ago he went to jail he's
going to serve
nearly seven years and what he did is
something that almost every politician
has done is he gave an appointment it
happened to be a non-paying appointment
to a board of education
to
a campaign contributor he receives
nothing personally
and the man in return got a
state position that he'd held before
under the republicans
but for that don
siegelman was prosecuted for bribery and
he was convicted
and he's already served seven months he
was out on appeal and now he's going
back for another uh for nearly seven
years
uh this is something george w bush did
this with more than a hundred
appointees it's sort of a commonplace
it's it's not the most
the prettiest part of our electoral
system but it's a common place for a big
campaign contributor to become an
ambassador bush did it with over a
hundred
of his appointees of course he was not
prosecuted but siegelman was manacled
was in a maximum security prison uh he
was at the democratic position uh
national convention in charlotte
uh and now uh just two days ago he's
gone off to jail
the other thing that was part of the us
attorney scandal we're seeing again in
this election and
a u.s attorney by the name of david
iglesias in new mexico who lost his job
in in 2004 he was tasked by rove
with uh prosecuting
what rove calls voter fraud
and uh to find people who are
fraudulently registered to vote
and he investigated for several months
and he said it's not happening it
doesn't exist
and as a result of that he lost his job
and the brennan center at nyu has done
very
nyu school of law has done thorough
investigation of the idea of voter fraud
and they say basically it doesn't exist
there have been
10 or 12 cases in the first 10 years
of this century
out of hundreds of millions of votes
it's someone may register as mickey
mouse but mickey mouse never shows up in
votes
so to spend but nevertheless rove has
initiated a campaign and it's it's alive
in more than 30 state legislatures
of having votes
requiring voter ids
now a lot of the democrats are saying
that this is basically a form of voter
suppression
that is it
in many cases you find the elderly who
who've given up their driver's licenses
they voted for 50 years but now they no
longer have a government-issued id so
they're not allowed to vote
you have minorities and particularly
hispanics
one of the challenges the republicans
face
is the hispanic time bomb there are 50
million hispanics to the united states
now there'll be 70 million in 2020 if
they start to vote on mass it's going to
be curtains for the republicans there
are 10 million
hispanics in texas alone
states like texas and arizona
will flip from red to blue very soon uh
once th that kicks in so this is one
thing they're trying to do and this is
uh was at rose
behest starting 10 years ago
uh to suppress the vote and uh if these
go were to go through in all the states
it would disenfranchise
21 million registered voters or eligible
voters rather
so uh
before opening this
to questions i i think uh we're now
going to see what rove will do with this
one billion dollars plus
over the next
seven or eight weeks
and uh he's a master
at creating
a narrative that doesn't always exist if
you look at the swift boat scandal again
uh this was script wrote veterans for
truth in 2004 that was his last election
it was enormously effective rose said he
had absolutely nothing to do with it but
of course when you go back and it takes
months to do this and you figure out
where the money came from it came from
the same donors he's been using for 30
years from
people like
bob perry who's a texas billionaire
harold simmons another texas billionaire
and so forth and now
he's made sort of his allegiance
with the tea party and he's got people
like the koch brothers who will put in
as much as 400 million dollars into this
election
uh
uh sheldon adelson will put in as much
as a hundred million dollars
and uh we will see him go to work over
the next two months
so
thank you and
[Applause]
i guess we can have some questions now
and i should say this is on c-span so uh
this is being televised and be careful
what you say i guess
yes
i enjoyed listening to you earlier in
the week on leonard lopate and
developed a few questions from that
microphone
so
one
do you have any idea about who pays kall
rove and how much he gets paid and two
i'm really worried about ohio are you in
terms of voter suppression ohio is
always an uh
yeah
the question was
how does he get paid and and how much
and who pays him uh and the second
question is what about ohio
uh you know
obviously he's on fox news's payroll in
the wall street journal's payroll and he
makes a a
and
peanuts for him maybe but not not for me
um but he's uh
uh you know when you raise a billion
dollars and and uh there are millions
and millions in contracts going out to
be perfectly honest it is impossible for
me to trace that money there's no
question there are people that um
uh the media buyers the ad makers the
strategists who who make a lot of money
uh he claims he does not take a piece of
that i honestly don't know the answer to
that for sure one thing i found out i
mean it's a little off point but
when i looked at who works for him how
does he operate
uh what i found is the people who are
karl rove operatives
are not on its payroll they get paid
they find a way to get paid and when
you're in the white house when george w
bush was in the white house
uh it was very easy for them to get
contracts say from fema the federal
emergency management agency
and uh those contracts are given out at
the last minute with very little
oversight they're given out obviously in
the case of an emergency
and uh in return for a lucrative
contract people will operate all year
long as operatives for rove
um yes i'm sorry
you talked about the suppression of the
vote yet you need id to go on a plane
you need an id to get into the
democratic convention so why should you
not need an id to vote well being a
consumer or being a traveler is very
different than being a citizen
and and i i've heard this i mean the the
real question is
i mean we're supposed to be a democracy
and you have universal suffrage do you
why should you need an
uh
this is a government issued id mind you
that means like a driver's license we
don't have uh formal government issued
uh ids in this country
uh except driver's license is the only
one i have um
but but the real reason is it
disenfranchises uh millions of people
that is why should an elderly person
who's given up his driver's license
therefore be disenfranchised
people have an opportunity to issue ids
by the state you can get an id if you
have to get one how do you go on a plane
you don't have no you don't the
requirement to vote isn't that you have
to travel or go on a plane the
requirement boat is merely your citizen
why add on additional strictures
the only reason it is disenfranchised
people
thought about it
right yeah i'm sorry
but you make this country sound like
russia or afghanistan
and and the corruption
and um the uh eliminating of the right
to vote i mean somebody's been voting at
the same precinct for 50 years and they
go down there and they don't have an id
they know each other intimately but the
law says they need an id it's observed i
find the fraud on
uh karl rove and his buddy's side
horrendous
and there's been so little voter fraud
reported in all the research right
well thank you
i'm not sure what to say about that but
[Laughter]
uh
yes and so
is carl rogue at the top of the pyramid
or is he just
the top lieutenant for someone else no
he he's very much a power
of his own making and what's what's
extraordinary about him is he operates
almost
he he has effectively swallowed the
republican party
he is more powerful in some ways than
the rnc now there's a schism within the
party the tea partiers and the old
establishment which is small and his
rove and ed gillespie and some uh
hangers on from the bush era
he tries to discipline people you can
see him
in the 2010 election uh christine
o'donnell was the tea party senatorial
candidate in delaware who uh talked
about dabbling in witchcraft he did not
like that and he came down on her uh
likewise with todd aiken the tea party
candidate in
in missouri who talked about legitimate
rape uh
rove didn't like that and if you look at
the finances there you can see rose
power aiken had raised 2.2 million
dollars uh rove's american crossroads
had put in 15 million dollars in that
senate race
and as soon as aiken said that the rug
came out and he pulled it out and now
he he he's trying to oust and very
strongly aikens hanging in there but uh
in return rove uh i was sort of
surprised
last week he said if aiken ends up
murdered don't come looking for me
yes
why did michael still get fired really
well well he
he was uh you know why the question is
why was michael steele pushed out of the
republican party and the answer is uh he
couldn't raise any money at all and in
terms of style he was trying to make it
sort of a hip-hop party and that didn't
quite work uh
with country club republicans or the tea
party for that matter
um
he uh
it it just yeah i mean
it was really a funny question what were
they
whether was he trying to go up
against obama he was not going to bring
african-americans into the party he was
turning off the party base and nothing
was happening he simply couldn't raise
any money
uh so
uh yes
yeah there's a woman no the
i have a two-part question one is do you
think there ever was a time in this
country when our government was more
honorable
or is it simply that we have become more
and more sophisticated so the
shenanigans are ever more elaborate and
enormous and the second part of the
question is would getting rid of the
electoral college in any way help us out
well i mean i i personally would love to
get rid of the electoral college and and
it would eliminate
uh something like ohio being so central
i mean it's it's when you're here in new
york no one cares about how new york
votes it's for democrats so you let so
they just don't care about us and our
vote doesn't mean as much as a vote in
ohio it really doesn't uh and the
attention on ohio is extraordinary when
you go there and uh as to the first
question uh you know i think what's
amazing is the amount of money and that
um when you go back
when you look at the supreme court
decision on uh citizens united it was
quite extraordinary and i think one of
the you you see the language being
butchered again and again uh in an
orwellian way because the ruling was
meant to give a voice and and now i'm
quoting to a deprived
and disadvantaged class of people
like the koch brothers
like sheldon adelson and and it's just
uh
uh
you know and i think the founders had no
idea about uh buying up
uh niche markets in the airwaves in in
ohio uh about in about
facebook and social media and the
internet and so forth so and and that
kind of money simply wasn't an issue but
going all the way back to the
beginning things printed in the
newspapers about i don't know jackson or
oh absolutely absolutely so it was
smaller because we didn't have facebook
and it seems to me that it's been
crooked almost from the beginning we're
just bigger well there were horrible
things lies about abraham lincoln and
there were and and
likewise there have been horrible lies
about um that rose opponents in one
election after another
so is it only in our imagination that we
imagine that this really is a democracy
where we wish wish to i mean is it
really is that just us uh
you know well i think there's a constant
battle and i i can't speak to all of
american history but it's just uh
you know yeah yes
i'd like to know how karl rove got
started where what
how did he get started where was he born
and how did he get into such a position
right well as a kid when when some of us
were worshiping mickey mantle or johnny
united he was studying william mckinley
and uh mckinley's operative uh mark
hannah who put mckinley in the white
house and he calls himself a classic
nerd and in college he was on the
college republicans he ran for executive
director of uh college of republicans
and his campaign manager was a legendary
lee atwater who uh was the real bad boy
of uh the republican party he did the
famous willie horton ad in the 1988
campaign uh for
the elder george bush uh and uh i when
when
uh
when atwater died of the brain tumor at
the age of 40 and that opened up a space
for karl rove and i think that's where
he really took off but but it's also
instructive that he he worked for nixon
during watergate and he was investigated
by the fbi rove was in his early 20s
during the watergate era and the fbi
kind of dropped it because they had
other fish to fry
uh but uh even back then he was doing
dirty tricks
yeah
yeah with a billion dollars in his hands
what um
shenanigans do you see him possibly
doing in the next
week
there's no question a huge amount of
money will be going into uh the airwaves
and it if romney implodes and he's had a
very bad week you can see rove shifting
all
his attention to taking over the senate
but but i also think rove has been a
great uh
ambassador at creating a narrative and
getting it out there a counter narrative
and uh i'm looking at while i was i was
in the democratic convention in
charlotte north carolina and there were
ads on tv from a group called special
operations opsec
and uh we will see if that turns into
the swift vote veterans for truth of
this uh
this campaign also with the events in
libya and the middle east unfolding uh
you know you can watch nbc and say oh
romney's completely falling apart but
let me suggest you turn the channel to
fox and you and you'll get a completely
different narrative and with a billion
dollars to fill up the airwaves that
that uh can be built into something that
has real resonance
and uh that obama's weak in the middle
east and so forth uh even
uh the the ads i saw in north carolina
where i mean rove is uh one of his his
great
uh tactics is to attack
his opponent's strength and these ads
were attacking obama
over the killing of osama bin laden
where you think he'd be in vulnerable
but they were making it into leaked
security leaks
from the obama administration were
making us vulnerable
what i find disturbing is the following
i understand that you wrote a book about
boss rove and therefore you want to
bring out information about him that you
find is unfavorable
but in this discussion at least
there was no
um
no discussion at all
that maybe the democratic party is
uh for lack of a better word just as
corrupt we all know about the corruption
of mr soros
or at least the monies that he's
spending which you don't even bother to
discuss
we also know about the corruption of
chicago politics
and we also know and i'll tell you the
truth this is a this is an incident
which disturbs me more than anything
when there were black panthers
not allowing white people to go into
vote in a certain election and i it was
recent it wasn't too long ago okay there
was real there was wait a moment there
was there was absolutely okay so my
question is all right if you want okay
okay
all right so if you want a question i
will give you a question
why are you not presenting
an unbiased view in both respects
because because
all right
well
but but you are okay you're making him
to be the worst person and he's not
because the corruption exists on the
other side as well okay i i mean
if you find any inaccuracies in my book
i'll gladly address them but i i don't
think they're
i mean i i'm not aware of any
i just suggest next book you write is
about sorrows
uh yes
do you believe that there's anything
that can be done to turn this around
or has it got gotten totally away from
us at this point uh
you know you know the question was is
there anything that can be done to turn
this around and i i do think the
citizens united decision
does open the floodgates and and
and that uh
to me it's crazy for the united states
supreme court
the if you read the decision the basis
is it's a first amendment case
uh that we're this is being done and i'm
not uh you can read read it it's written
by justice anthony kennedy to give voice
to the deprived and disadvantaged
and it seems crazy to me
that a billion dollars
doesn't amplify the voice of
billionaires so much that it drowns out
everyone else's voice
uh in terms of redressing that uh
it requires the supreme court to reverse
it or perhaps a constitutional amendment
that's very very difficult
so yeah and
do you think there's a possibility of a
backlash if he comes out with 1.8
billion dollars worth of stuff that is
rammed down our throats for the next
seven weeks
is there any hope
of a backlash
that it'll
overplay yourself you know i don't know
but the thing is it
when you travel around this country a
bit you see how uh
fragmented it is and new york is not
really part of the united states i mean
i'm on that west side i've lived here
and uh
this is when when you're in uh
the
the heartland in the battleground states
and and your only source of information
or these ads and fox news it's a very
very different world
craig perhaps you could talk a little
bit about how karl rove
managed the republican primaries and
had a kind of puppet master
touch on what was really going on with
the republican candidates right well
well it was interesting to see rove
plays two roles of course he's a talking
head on fox news and and he works for
the wall street journal uh and and i
thought oh he's playing he's uh isn't
there a conflict there well the truth is
he was really
here you saw the party boss in action
and essentially he was picking off one
candidate after another
everyone except romney and it would be
first sarah palin uh who was so stunned
she didn't even declare candidacy
uh he he took care of newt gingrich
rick santorum
rick perry
herman cain he made fun of all of them
again and again and again and when he
does that on fox news he's not just a
talking head he's the party boss saying
look i've got a billion dollars you're
not getting any of it you're not going
to run you're not going to be the
nominee and and you know romney never
took off during the primaries he never
took off during the primaries uh
he it was simply everyone else was
picked off one at a time
so yeah
anyway i arrived like that
to what extent uh
it's not just a problem with with the
republicans but what with uh
ralph nader used to call in oh all
the republicans
and maybe for every car road there is
less efficient democrat trying
efforts like al gore's america blah blah
blah
do not
do not really touch a nerve in the
american public so maybe as as carville
would say it is the public is stupid
but i'm sorry what is the question my
point is that it's not just a republican
right-wing
or ultra-right-wing problem but the
democrats also
are embedded in money and it's only that
they are like successful are uh
yeah well
well i mean i i think the question is
aren't they all the same is that really
roughly what you're getting at and and i
i do think there's there are fundamental
differences and and i would use the u.s
u.s attorney scandal is is just to give
you one example
this is a very serious issue when the
law
is used to prosecute just one group of
people when there's elective prosecution
that's very very serious and the case of
don siegelman is important not just for
his
personal pain of having to go to jail
but uh because you see
the law being used to
ruin the queers of hundreds of democrats
really
and once a law is used just for
democrats can be used just against
blacks or hispanics or or other groups
uh that that's a very serious blow to
democracy i think
[Applause]
um
yes in the in the back there i just want
to address the the lady who was talking
earlier about why you didn't uh choose
to write about george soros and why did
you just write about karl rove so it
really it's my responses to her
um
you know if you want to read about
george soros and you want a negative uh
portrayal of him you can find one uh you
can uh the david horowitz book what is
it uh shadows or something like that i
mean there are plenty of books that will
support your point of view
an author is not obliged to include
every point of view he chose to write
about karl rove maybe at the end of his
reporting it would have been a
fabulously positive portrayal it didn't
turn out that way but he's under no
obligation
to give you both sides of the story he's
only obliged to write about what his
subject is and i think that if you want
to hear
you know the story that you seem to want
to hear you should seek out those
authors i think that's a perfectly fair
thing to do
[Applause]
yeah the
man and
i can't think of his name now but the
republican power broker that got the
guys the uh
the uh congressmen and senators assigned
i will never vote for a tax increase nor
grover
what is his relationship with rove
they're friendly they're they're close
they work together
yeah
um
and
one more question uh
um yeah
are there more of these
who are other journalists who are kind
of on your side or who who are likely to
help get this story out
no well there there were actually a
couple of uh
reporters in texas wayne slater and
james board who did uh good books early
on on rove
and i mean the only thing is i thought
it was worth going back to because i
think a lot of people thought he was
finished
with the 08 election and here i saw the
deed at second life
so
thank you
[Applause]
we'd like to hear from you tweet us your
feedback twitter.com
booktv
hello everyone and welcome to the second
day of the tucson festival of books
it's uh
hello america we're on c-span so
it's uh
it's 75 degrees and sunny in tucson that
will uh complete our shout out to the
arizona department of tourism
uh
my name is jim nintzel i am the editor
of the tucson weekly and the tucson
local media family of publications and
i'm my great honor and pleasure to be
here today with a wonderful panel of
authors
we have
going down the line here david corn and
michael isakoff two of the finest
investigative reporters in america today
we're going to be talking about their
book russian roulette terrific terrific
look at the connections between the
russians and the
and the the russians efforts to disrupt
the election and possibly connections to
the trump campaign
who knows there are some there are some
i i don't i don't see any reason why it
would be russia
we have uh from
michael mcfaul he was obama's point man
on russia and the u.s
ambassador to russia
thank you
he's the author of from cold war to hot
peace
and finally last but not least craig
unger the author of house of trump house
of putin which covers a lot of the same
ground as our our
first book there
looking at the connections
between trump and russia
let's see this uh panel is called
russian impulses we'll be going for
about an hour uh save your questions for
the panelists until uh about
where we'll start taking questions about
20 minutes towards the end of the panel
uh the festival organizers would like to
thank c-span book tv for sponsoring this
location and jerry lynn greenberg the
university of arizona wildcat core and
marilyn einstein and steve sim of
terramar properties for sponsoring the
upcoming panel discussion the authors
will sign their books on the u of a
bookstore tent on the mall outside right
after this session has ended and their
books will be on sale there and you
really should pick up a copy because
these these are these are great readings
i i said to these guys yesterday it's
like reading a tom clancy novel except
it's real life which makes it a little
more terrifying
um
the
book sales at the festival do support
the
festival itself and the local literacy
programs that it funds so it's also a
good cause uh you can help keep this
event free and open to everyone by
becoming a friend of the festival or a
sponsor of the 2020 festival and you can
stop by the friends of the friends of
the festival booth or you can go online
at tucson festival of books.org to learn
more about that we do have some hearing
devices in the back if anybody has uh
any kind of trouble hearing uh check in
the back in the corner over there
and uh as i said uh we introduced our
panelists so let's uh let's start with
uh michael mcfaul uh since we did a
panel with with three of these guys with
michael's our newbie today
and uh michael i we talked a lot about
trump uh yesterday but i want to talk a
little bit more about the russian side
of things which you know a little bit
about
and uh why don't we set a little context
by just talking about the reset process
that the obama administration went into
and how that kind of fell off the rails
once uh putin came back into power or uh
maybe we should say he reassumed the
presidency since he may have never been
out of power
okay first of all thanks for having me
uh sorry i only got here this morning
i feel i'm on enemy territory here as a
stanford guy this is kind of freaking me
out seeing this u of a
glass
if i'm not mistaken your basketball team
has beaten us 20 times in a row
um but we should talk about football too
okay no anyway
so let me even broaden the aperture just
a little bit because um at the at the
end of the cold war
there was a theory
that democrats and republicans both held
so there's not a partisan thing at all
the idea was
there had been transformation within the
soviet union
you know towards democracy towards
markets towards integrating with the
west and that it was in america's
national interest to see that
integration move forward and to bring
this new russia into the western
community of states it may seem like
ancient history now but just 30 years
ago we thought that we were going to
live in this kind of world my friend and
colleague at stanford frank fukuyama
wrote this very famous essay that
nobody's read the end of the book to uh
by the way the book he always complains
about that you all know the hit the
title end of history um but but the idea
there was that there was a set of ideas
that were universal and all countries
were moving forward and moving towards
that trajectory and most certainly that
was our strategy vis-a-vis russia
um there were hiccups along the way over
that 30-year period uh things that
russia did things that we did that
created tension in the relationship and
when we arrived um
at the white house my first day working
there was january 21st 2009
right after a really great day
on the mall the day before i don't know
if you remember that i do it was a
pretty inspirational time
and we took one last run at that that
idea and and it wasn't i want to be
clear especially because when when i
watched trump and his personal diplomacy
the reset was never about being friends
with russia or having a pal in the
kremlin all that kind of happy talk it
was all about could we engage with
russia to pursue
interests that were uh were in the
american interest and we presume the
russians would only do it if it was in
their interest as well
um and for a while it worked i want to
just remind you we signed the start
treaty in 2010 reducing by 30 the number
of nuclear weapons in the world
that's what i did in 2010 what did you
do
and i say that i say that because i work
five years in the government and it's
really hard to do anything in the
government it's kind of hard to do
anything meaningful in the academia as
well by the way but um uh 2010 was a
great year we got that done we got
supply routes to afghanistan through
russia we got the most comprehensive
multilateral sanctions
on iran in the history of negotiations
with iran and that laid down the
predicate for the iran nuclear deal
which i think was a great deal
i could go on we did a lot of things uh
and there was a there was momentum
towards kind of resuscitating this
strategy that had been tried before us
uh and then two things happened that
that derailed us and i think uh that
lays down the predicate for what
happened in 2016 in our country
one was that putin came back as
president and you may think kind of as
you intimated in your question what's
the big deal he was the big dog the
decision maker anyway he was a the prime
minister at the time but it turned out
that he had pretty different
uh views about foreign policy and about
russia's national interest than medvedev
did uh medvedev thought in win-win terms
putin's a zero-sum guy
uh
number two on a good day we're a
competitor for putin but most days uh
we're the enemy
and then third and this is important to
understand about putin
he believes he has a theory about
american foreign policy he believes that
we use overt and covert force to
overthrow regimes that we don't like
and guess what there's a lot of
empirical data to support that
hypothesis
um in fact when we first sat down with
him when president obama sat down with
him for the first time as president in
july 2009 added his dacha we debated
this for about you know about an hour
and president obama said to him we're
going to be different we're not going to
invade countries we're not going to
overthrow them
like president bush and his
administration did
by the way putin never blamed president
bush
he always talked about the deep state
the administration and he still does he
never blames president trump for
anything it's foreign policy elite and
the establishment of which you all are a
member of by the way
that he blames
anyway we had that debate but 18 months
later the arab spring started and for
putin that was confirming evidence that
we're just like just like the other
folks no different and then the end of
that year 2011 massive demonstrations
happened inside russia
and that's when putin blamed america
obama and eventually me as i show up as
ambassador in january 2012 for fomenting
revolution against him so he thinks
we're out there um suppressing
sovereignty and undermining sovereignty
of states he's a populist in that sense
um and so when that happened that's when
the reset ended punctuated by then
ukraine a similar dynamic in 2013 and
that's when he decided to go into crimea
and he decided to hell with all your
multilateral institutions and joining
the west i'm going to go this different
path and then on 2000 in 2016 he stopped
playing defense and he went on offense
and that's where the books of my
colleagues come in
which is my next question uh david and
michael can you guys talk a little bit
about what was going on with these
hackers and the troll farms over in
russia yeah yeah um there was a um
a russian general who in 2013
wrote a piece for one of the russian
military journals
that i think you know
eventually u.s intelligence and the u.s
um you know experts got wind of but
didn't really pay enough attention to at
first that said
we live in the age of now of
asymmetrical warfare you know there
aren't going to be big land
uh invasions and it's not going to be
about tanks versus tanks
and airplanes versus airplanes fighter
just
versus fighter jets it's going to be a
different type of warfare and what we
can do
is
use disinformation misinformation
fake news propaganda
and this was i think the real insight
we can exploit the political divisions
within our enemies so it was okay this
is a shift here as
you know putin is pulling away from the
west their strategic view of how to
engage or combat the west is moving into
this cyber
information sphere
and they by this point something called
the internet research agency has been
set up in saint petersburg it's a troll
farm where they are putting out at that
point they're probably focusing on the
ukraine but and estonia and other
regional uh crisis points for russia but
they're really going to be quite good
at fomenting
crises you know sometimes that includes
shutting down banking systems uh as they
did in estonia in
2013 i want to say um but using it not
just for information but actually cyber
attacks
and they're developing this capability
in a way that is really unknown
to
the leaders the leadership here all the
facebook stuff that came later was
completely
unseen at the time but interestingly
enough
a party that was
onto this
was the new york times
in
2014 15 in 2015 there's a cover story in
the new york times
sunday magazine about the troll farm in
saint petersburg and how they try to set
up a crisis in the united states on one
of the anniversaries of september 11th
by
creating the fake news that a chemical
factory in louisiana had been attacked
big explosions they created fake cnn
home pages with articles on this attack
and put that out into the social media
stream
so
it didn't really cause i think a big
impact at the time
but it was certainly a warning of what
they could do
and i think in some ways we had the 911
commission
after the 9 11 attack and a good part of
it was devoted to why did we not see
this happening who dropped the ball how
can we make sure our intelligence
finds
this word or
indications of these type of attacks in
the future
and we really haven't come to terms with
that in terms of the 2016 attack it
wasn't an intervention it was an attack
on american democracy
and a lot of it was totally unseen the
stuff that didn't come out publicly the
the the dumping of emails and you know
because of partisanship in congress
there's been no real good look at that
and they also the republicans also
blocked the formation of a 911 type
commission so uh we are still i think in
a lot of ways probably behind the curve
in understanding
what happened
and what could happen and what can be
done
to prevent this um in the future and
maybe in 2020
yeah um i just want to um underscore
david's point here because uh this was a
major u.s intelligence failure um there
were
multiple warnings that the us government
had about what the internet research
agency was up to what they were doing in
ukraine spreading disinformation uh
manipulating social media um
and um
this in in many ways the events of
2014 um were sort of the testing ground
for
um for this this sort of operation uh
that the hybrid warfare uh operation
that that david was talking about and
you know you go back then to the
new york times sunday magazine story
which is so stunning to read now in
early 2015 um uh the author showed
adrian chen that
they were starting to use the same sort
of techniques in the united states in
fact it starts off with this gripping
story of um a fake cnn news page
reporting about a chemical explosion in
an obscure uh parish in louisiana that
was entirely made up it hadn't happened
but it created panic in that community
and you know the sheriff's office was
getting bombarded people were panicking
and this was all being run out of the
internet research agency in saint
petersburg so cut to the events of a
year later
um
this is the same we saw the same
techniques being used on a much broader
scale and the u.s intelligence community
the white house the state department are
oblivious in all we talk in great depth
about how the obama administration
administration
grappled and
tried to figure out how to respond to
what the russians were up to in terms of
the cyber attacks in terms of the probe
on state election systems uh in terms of
a lot else that we're doing and in all
those discussions what the social media
component which was a major part of the
russian operation in 2016 was never
discussed because the policymakers were
completely oblivious to it and i think
you know when you look back at
the events of 2016 the failure to
understand what was going on and you
know i'll extend this to the to the
social media companies as well i mean
they were oblivious to how their own
platforms were being manipulated even
though these fake facebook accounts were
being paid in rubles uh to uh which
should have been a clue that tipped them
off um so i think that's an important
part but i having a question for the
ambassador because he was talking about
the reset and um just this week um
madeleine albright former secretary of
state who was a surrogate for the um
for the obama campaign in 2012 testified
before congress and um the subject came
up about how obama ridiculed romney for
warning that russia was our major
geopolitical foe in the country and uh
obama dismissed it at the debate
surrogates like albright you know uh
ridiculed him for saying it you do you
want your
cold war um
yeah the 1980s
and what uh albright said is i
personally owe an apology to now senator
romney because i think we underestimated
what was going on in russia so
ambassador do you share uh uh with uh
albright her apology to romney and do
you believe you underestimated what was
going on in russia
yeah i think um
the question was directed to you sir
okay
i i do want to come back to 2016 because
um as somebody's looked at this closely
and we have a whole team
at stanford looking at this including
alex stamos from facebook um we got i
think we've ma if we're not going to
have a 9-1-1 commission folks like us
have to help talk about these more
things more systematically because we
have done absolutely nothing to uh make
our elections more secure in 2020
doesn't mean we'll be attacked again but
we've done almost nothing and and
there's some other thing we'll loop back
to that i'm sure but let me answer this
question now uh did did i underestimate
putin the answer to that is no uh and do
the foia requests and and get you know
get my papers and you'll see that that
it's not uh that that we had a real
debate about putin i wrote my first
piece warning about putinism and the
threat to the west in march of 2000 uh
so i've got a pretty long track record
uh by the way putin knows that that's
why he hates me that's why he wants to
arrest me that's why he won't let me
travel to russia today uh i'm on their
sanctions list but you asked a different
question i think not just about me but
about the obama administration
and in my book i i talk about this pivot
which was
after putin came back in fact it was
even before i i talked about it in the
book it's september 24th uh 2011. that
is a that's a pivotal day uh that's the
day the reset ended uh because that's
the day putin announced that he was
going to return as president
and a couple of days later i was
actually in to see the president for
some other reason and he pulled me back
in and and he said you know by the way
i'm at this time just to set the stage
for you i'm in limbo waiting to be
confirmed as the u.s ambassador right
i'm spending some quality time at the
executive stay in friendship heights
for those of you know washington i
thought it was going to be there three
weeks our family stayed there six months
uh let's come back to the
problems of democracy a little bit later
anyway uh so i'm still in my job at the
white house uh working at the national
security council
and he pulls me and he says what do you
think mike
and i initially gave him the party line
i want to be honest about this because
the party line the intelligence
community at the time i think probably
academia
we all had this assumption that putin
was a decision maker that medvedev
didn't matter and so what's the big deal
he's just going to change jobs he's just
going to go down the street he's going
to sit in the kremlin there won't be any
change and so i explained that that
that's our assessment mr president
and he looked at me and he said he likes
his phrase he said come on
man uh
you don't believe that
and i said no i don't mr president um
uh
i think we're done and and we just have
to you know we have to like deal with
them because you know he's the president
you don't get to choose who your
interlocutors are and we got to play the
long game that's a phrase that the
president likes to talk about as well
but for me that was the end and then the
demonstrations against putin and him i
want to underscore this that's when he
pivoted that's when he said we
you all and you all and me but
especially me
we are the enemy we are trying to
overthrow him and that's when they
shifted in this you know and it was very
palpable living there as the us
ambassador where this propaganda uh
about uh you know the obama
administration seeking to overthrow
putin and it got very nasty by the way
disinformation i was the target of this
information
back in 2012 2013 i still am but but it
was very intense then
uh what do you do for instance how do
you fight this when a video pops up
three weeks into your assignment that
suggests you're a pedophile
yeah that happened to me
do you get on twitter and say i'm not a
pedophile like like think about the you
know it's a kind of a difficult world to
get in and that's the world we're in now
in the government
i'm writing this from moscow saying it's
over we got to
stop we're not going to get a new start
treaty we're not going to get
cooperation on missile defense it's over
folks because of this larger strategic
thing within the administration however
and this is how bureaucracies work uh
there was a fight
uh and it was on two different
dimensions one was the analytic
dimension
where i was making and and my team had
one assessment by the way we had allies
in washington but but we were leading
that and another side that said oh
mcfaul he's overreacting
it's because he's overreacting to these
pedophile files right these these these
accusations against him uh we all just
got to settle down you know that things
are going to be fine so that was one
argument and then there's this other
bureaucratic politics thing if you're
the head of the part of the state
department that does arms control you
get up every morning wanting to do arms
control irrespective of what putin said
about this or that or the other you just
get up and you're focused on trying to
get the next treaty uh and you invoke
the prague spring that's president
obama's big speech that he gave in
prague in 2009 that i helped to write
and you just want to do that no matter
what and so i was in this ironic
paradoxical situation i'm the author of
the reset right i wrote all those memos
and now the author of the reset is the
most
uh animated person saying the reset is
over and other people are using my words
for four years earlier to say no we got
to continue it
then there's a third dimension and let's
just be honest i'm that's all about
policy what president obama was saying
during the debates was about politics uh
and and you know that they did not i'm
i'm just an observer i'm an ambassador
i'm not i worked on the campaign in 2008
i did not work on the campaign obviously
in 2012.
but watching it from afar that just
seemed like an obvious thing that you
were not mid-stream in your re-election
campaign going to just pivot to say your
policy was wrong
by the way i still think the reset was a
successful policy and if you want maybe
i won't take the time now but but i want
to get into that argument because i
think that's a big mistake when people
uh assess policies uh earlier
with updated information and then go
back and say the earlier policy was
wrong i see a lot of that with the trump
administration right now it makes me
nervous but let's come back to the reset
later we should because craig here poor
craig hasn't had a chance to say
anything yet
and
i i
i think one of the things you said
yesterday was that the russian organized
crime is very different you always all
did this already once yes so i get more
time
yeah yeah you can filibuster a little mr
ambassador
[Music]
craig uh organized crime very different
from what we know about like italian
organization talk a little bit about
that right well one important thing to
understand about the russian mafia is
that it's a state actor and i too think
this has been uh a spectacular
intelligence failure on our part and if
you want to follow the money in this
scandal this is one place to start
because uh part of the failure was that
we i guess had dreamed that russia would
become a market economy and instead it
became a real mafia state
and that is characterized by deals i'm
going to just speak of one
involving a russian mobster named simeon
mogulevich who partners with a man named
dmitry vertosh or ukrainian oligarch and
this is uh essentially the theft of
natural resources from russia so you see
uh
uh the russia the energy trade through
ukraine going through from originating
in turkmenistan and russia and going on
to ukraine and essentially the russian
mob uh through uh mogulev which was
skimming about 750 million dollars a
year
and these are the kind of sweetheart
deals uh that putin supports it's a way
he keeps his oligarchs happy and it's a
way he keeps political power but that's
an enormous amount of money this is just
one sector and since putin has been
in office i believe it's about 1.3
trillion dollars in flight capital has
left russia
so a lot of money needs to be laundered
and how you gonna launder it
one of the best ways to launder is to
find a real estate mogul who's willing
to send you condos and not ask any
questions and that began in 1984 when
donald trump met with david bogarden who
was an associate of mogul avid and uh
david bogdan had six million dollars in
cash that's the equivalent about 15
million today he said i'll take five
condos and according to the state
attorney general of new york that was
laundering money now you can say maybe
he just didn't ask questions um and
maybe it was just an accident well
there were at least 1300 con trump
branded condos that were sold under
those conditions that is uh the two
criteria being
all cash purchases anonymous shell
companies
so when the house intelligence committee
gets back uh going i think they're going
to be some very serious questions and i
i think it's really important to look at
whether the trump organization is a an
ongoing criminal enterprise
and and that this is uh something that's
gone on for very long and if you want to
i i believe this is how trump was first
compromised
uh
i want to
go back to this whole disinformation uh
campaign because obviously the the uh
russians have been doing quite a bit of
that uh it seems as though president
trump uh engages in that from time to
time uh david can you talk about the
impacts and the implications of what's
going on with all this disinformation
we're seeing out there
well i think there's some very major
trends underway that are going to pose
significant challenges to our society um
you know it used to be that you had some
basis for believing information then
that the public made decisions based on
that
but now we're at it we're in an error
where good information which is
expensive which type of stuff that
people on the panel here produce and we
need to be paid to do this competes with
bad information on social media
formats
that give
the bad actors as much access to the
public at large here in russia and every
place else
as the
you know the good actors and we need to
develop a whole new set of skills and
tools to figure out
how to sort this out
um it is i mean i do believe and i think
you know this gets lost in a lot of the
partisan shuffle that the russian attack
on the election had had an impact had a
decisive impact this election was so
close 77 000 votes
flipped over three states and and uh
we'd now be arguing about
hillary clinton's housing policies
but um you know
what they were able to do
by
hacking really just one person put aside
the the the stuff at the convention they
hacked one person john podesta who made
one single mistake when he got a a
phishing
email
and then they got access to 60 000
emails they dumped them every day over
the course of the last four weeks of the
campaign they dominated headlines they
made a lot of independent voters uh who
don't follow the news carefully think
that this was about hillary clinton's
own email controversy with the use of
her personal server and totally
made was one of you know
if there are 12 15 20 decisive factors
that turn the election then this was
certainly one of them so it showed that
you know i don't know how many people
they had in the gru hacking
division mueller indicted what about a
dozen of them so a dozen
guys
in some place in russia you know
attacking one person
putting out information
changed the course of
american and global history
and then you have you know what we know
what mike and and has talked about on
the social media platforms and i
remember we did when we were working on
our book
i said
you know you always look for characters
right you know for anecdotes and
storytelling to animate the bigger
themes and i said there must be somebody
inside the government in the
intelligence apparatus and you know and
the state department someone who was
saying look at the social media we got
to talk about this you know like there
were a few people before at 9 11 talking
about al qaeda and they weren't listened
to you know the looming tower is a great
book and is a great mini series based on
that i said we got to find that looming
tower guy
and we looked and we looked and there
was no one there there is clint watts
who you've seen on tv and has a good
book out to he was outside the bureau
the fbi at the time and he was trying to
talk to people in the bureau about this
but we could not find any indication
that anyone inside started thinking
about this so there's the particular
how does our
national security apparatus deal with
this how do how does facebook and
twitter and journalism
entities deal with this academia as well
but the larger theme is how do we as a
society
you know
teach ourselves to separate good
information from bad information and if
you don't know what deep fake videos are
yet um and you want to scare yourselves
just google that because you know there
it's a way of putting out videos that
look real that could have mike mike
mcfaul saying something incredibly
damaging to him that would look
completely authentic
the computer technology now is is really
amazing and you can think of all sorts
of very extreme
um and obscene ways that can be used as
well
and so being able to tell reality from
manufacturing is only going to get more
difficult
in the years ahead
anybody else want to address the
disinformation issue
yeah i do i don't want to keep talking
so uh
so again i teach at stanford for those
you don't know we have a we have about a
dozen people working on this topic uh we
just had a two day confirmat conference
that's why i only got here today on
disinformation just yesterday including
about deep fakes and this relationship
let me let me say three things and i'll
say more if i get another bite at the
apple uh first let's go back to 2016. uh
and we we focus rightly on the mistakes
of the intelligence uh we focus rightly
on the mistakes of the platform
companies although that story between
them is more complicated i want to add
our media uh
not present company exclusive because
they were the ones screaming the
opposite but but here's how
disinformation works and there's there's
actually lots of good social science
research now on this uh the the
wikileaks thing happens the the military
attack the gru is the military attack
they steal the data they dump it into
different places by the way the initial
dump didn't go so well it took him a
while to get it out there
and then you get you get an effect from
that initially but the much bigger
effect that the magnifying effect the
the amplifying effect is not the initial
reporting on that that that's put out by
wikileaks it's all the media attention
including from very prominent media uh
sources that then just talk about it
incessantly and you can see this trend
and you just see it as clear as day for
the folks that have done the the
research just to echo something david
said that the fusing of the idea of
clinton being about emails and not being
credible it all fuses together in the
way that people think and you you can
see in the panel data in october she
goes from 56 to 46 as a trustworthy
president during that same period trump
stays static
and so i want to challenge the media
as well because i think the media was a
huge part of this problem october 7th i
remember it vividly that day that was a
horrible day for american media friends
uh that that's when uh the obama
administration floated out in a very
namby-pamby way and i've criticized my
friends who are responsible for that
they kind of fl you know that's when
they put out their report about what the
russians were doing they could have done
it in a much more dramatic way to get
more attention that's true but then the
media that covered it could have spent a
lot more time on it as well and oh by
the way even in the mix of that the new
york times published a piece saying
there's no fbi investigation of what's
going on a friend of mine was one of
those that published that i'm sorry
that's disinformation that was not true
and that needs we need to own that as
well as a community so that we do not do
that again the next time around
the events
[Applause]
the events of october 7th are like a
whole chapter in our book because it is
one of the most extraordinary days in
in modern history of american politics
um what the ambassador didn't point out
after right after the russia statement
which
um i have to say the uh the people at
the white house and homeland security
and dni thought it was going to be the
story they were shocked that nobody they
thought in fact we we quote jay johnson
saying he was expand and jim clapper
they were expecting to be on all the
sunday talk shows that weekend they
thought it would drive the whole
conversation uh but what happened within
an hour or so of that russia statement
was the access hollywood tape came out
and that completely
dominated the cable airwaves that became
the story of the day and then what
happened within an hour of the release
of that
the podesta emails
which gave the trump folks the
opportunity to come back because
and then they were dribbled out for
effect for the rest of the campaign by
wikileaks which is a real tell you know
wikileaks always liked to present itself
as this transparency organization that
was just about the public's right to
know when it got documents it released
them
in full in its entirety that's the way
it's always it had always done that but
with the podesta emails in those closing
weeks of the campaign they used them for
strategic effect a few emails each day
to keep the story going and that as i
say is a tell about just how um
strategic this whole russian
disinformation up and uh
hack operation uh was just to underscore
it was an editorial decision by
americans not gru military intelligence
to pivot first to the the the tape and
then to the wikileaks and i and it's not
just fox news folks the data is pretty
overwhelming how everybody pivoted to
run at that story that's on us that's
not on the right well but but my last
little
people that i work for the last little
defense here is you know the podesta
emails yes they were hacked by the
russians they were dumped by wikileaks
for strategic effect but you know had it
not been for
uh the fact that it actually had
legitimately newsworthy items in it for
instance
well no not come on compared to being
attacked by the russians that's the
first time in our history
but
ambassador you all remember you all
remember the 2016 primary debate between
bernie sanders and hillary clinton in
which bernie sanders was bringing up all
of hillary clinton's wall street
speeches let's see the let's see the
transcripts what did you say to wall
street when you were speaking behind
closed doors and she refused to release
them you know you know
you're both you're right it's a dessert
topping and a floor wax but um but the
thing but the thing about the thing is
crazy journalism just take handouts of
leaked emails
excuse
there's one thing left there's one thing
left out of the equation i disagree no
disagree
wait a second the actual transcripts no
no
i think this is really important because
i think it's important for 2020. and i
already see things that make me nervous
in the in the american media about how
we're already covering the campaign
i'm not saying it's not unimportant
that's ridiculous i'm saying in the uh
the balance of coverage that we have
evidence that our enemy has attacked us
deliberately to influence the outcome of
our election that's the first time in
american history that's ever happened
next to that knowing what clinton said
to the goldman sachs that this symmetry
is just not there and our media
michael the data's overwhelming our
media covered that other story
in order to magnitude greater than they
covered the russian but i have to say
that i have to say i mean i agree
actually with both of you
uh okay you should be a diplomat
but there's a p there's a piece missing
here because we do know the way the
media works and the white house knows
the way the media works and as you said
they made a very namby-pamby statement
that they decided they were not going to
have the president talk about and they
weren't going to make a big deal out of
it they put it out on a friday afternoon
we all know what that means and they
gave you know and they and even jim
comey ran away from signing on to the
statement and then once you know the
story was overwhelmed by the access
hollywood and then the wikileaks counter
point counter punch of dumping the
podesta emails they never came back to
it and that was because they had an
internal fight about how far to go in
blaming the russians now i'm with you i
saw that statement and i kept saying why
are we not talking more about this in
addition to the goldman sachs thing
hopefully you know we can chew gum and
walk at the same time although that's
not often the case with with american
media but um nevertheless they never
came back to it and the way much of the
media works particularly you know legacy
mainstream media which i don't mean in a
pejorative way
is that they follow the official agenda
and the official agenda at that point
was really you know trump reacting
access hollywood and hillary reacting to
uh the emails
and the white house saying nothing about
what you just said and i agree the most
significant attack on american
uh since 9 11 or in disinformation in
the history of america and some of us
that's the problem with following the
record that's the problem
with following the official agenda and
not getting to the root of the problem
and you can see it starting in russia
and russia was directing a lot of this
and it was i believe it was deputy prime
minister sirkov uh
uh who was a wonderful character in a
way i mean he was from the the art scene
in moscow and and sort of uh
uh performance art and all this and then
he he orchestrated korkovsky's uh image
when he became a sort of a glamour the
first glamorous oligarch to come out of
the communist world uh and and and when
putin took him into the administration
he started a real assault on reality and
he would create uh phony uh uh
parties to attack
uh
uh putin then they that uh backfire
would explode and they would make putin
more popular and so you start to see
that kind of thing here in addition i
think you do have a very serious problem
with the american press and if you uh
you know it was only in doing the
research for my book i realized that the
financial times had done a terrific
story well before the election on money
laundering uh and in the soho trump uh
that was and it was a very very
important story but the financial times
which is a basically a terrific
publication
is behind a paywall almost no american
papers picked it up and yet when you had
this ridiculous pizzagate story on this
uh ludicrous phony sex scandal
uh going on in the basement of a pizza
parlor uh in washington d.c which didn't
even have a basement by the way
[Laughter]
uh that goes on facebook and it gets
millions and millions of views
you know uh i wish we had another hour
to talk with you guys because
i
and maybe and maybe some beer yes that
would be helpful
i uh i have at least a dozen more
questions but it's time for us to let
the audience weigh in here so folks want
to line up with those microphones uh
i'll ask one quick question uh david
where do you see the investigations of
trump going next that's a really good
question because we've been playing a
game in washington uh what's happening
with the mueller report it won't come
out will we see it but also we don't
know what's going to what it's what it's
what's going to be in it he has no
obligation to write a fulsome report
about what he's discovered under justice
department regulations he's supposed to
at the end of his investigation submit a
report to the attorney general
explaining
his prosecutorial decisions why he
prosecuted this case and not that case
you can imagine it looking like three
pages like here are the cases i
prosecuted and you know and here's why i
did it or you could see it being 3000
pages here's everything i looked at and
here's why i decided to prosecute here
and not prosecute there uh you know we
don't really know how expansive it's
going to be what it's what's going to
come out but again it's probably going
to be limited to the things that he
looked at and i go back to my earlier
point that we still don't have a 911
commission but we do now have the house
democrats in charge of the intelligence
committee and they have pledged to
basically
rerun the investigation that the house
republicans turned into a clown show and
at the same time you have at least a
dozen other investigations underway
whether it's the southern district of
new york looking at the trump
organization and the trump inauguration
new york state attorney general looking
at the trump foundation you had the
oversight committee questioning michael
cohen last week he gave them probably 10
things to investigate um
so we have maxing waters looking at
trump's curious relationship with
deutsche bank which has been involved
with some untoward loans over the years
with russian and others so i mean there
are a lot of hammers
that could conceivably drop
and we're going to see the next two
years a big fight between
the investigations
and trump and of course the new one
about jared kushner and
ivanka lying
lying about trump not getting involved
in getting him a security clearance so i
mean i think i've left out probably at
least 10 or 12 other things that may or
may not be happening so all i can say is
stay tuned
stay tuned indeed right over here let's
have a question from the audience
uh gentlemen how can we as a democracy
with obviously a free press
who
have difficulty agreeing among
themselves
get organized and fight against putin
who obviously runs a
kleptocracy
thank you
uh well michael you are oh craig can i
start i i mean
i think you i don't want to go on for
for hours i mean that requires a very
long answer but i do think a huge part
of the problem is what's legal
and if you look in various different
sectors and i'm talking about whether
it's real estate the legal sector uh the
media uh there there are some real
serious problems there in real estate
there almost no regulations that
prohibit people from uh from laundering
vast vast amounts of money congress
should change that and they should
change it right away if you look at the
legal establishment big firms like jones
day kirkland ellis represent uh
enormous numbers of russian oligarchs
and jones day happens to have had 12
partners who are in the white house
counsel's office at the same time there
are huge conflicts there uh i i think
facebook and social media is a huge huge
problem in you know i've been in print
i've been in magazines which are
basically dead and a hundred billion
dollars a year in advertising that used
to go to newspapers and magazines is now
going to google and facebook and you
know what they're not media they call
themselves tech companies so we can be
sued they can't be and that's a huge
huge problem they have no editorial
responsibility whatsoever and i could go
on and on like this but there's an awful
lot there michael you wanted to weigh on
this
michael first yeah just a couple of
quick points there there are some
positive notes that um
that have come out of the whole
controversy along these lines in which
you now see
um the u.s government as a result of
this scandal
and it's probably in spite of trump
doing things that they hadn't been doing
before
public attribution on cyber attacks
prior to all of this the government was
loath to ever publicly accuse another
government or identify the other
government that had been doing cyber
attacks you're seeing much more of it
now you're seeing indictments by the
justice department of chinese hackers of
north korean hackers a much more
aggressive stance
enforcement of the foreign agents
registration act
something that was rarely done before
but as a result of manafort and the and
the whole investigation run by mueller
you're seeing much more aggressive
enforcement of that and that's going to
be something that's going to bite a lot
of people on both sides of the political
aisle
and then
so there are and then the other thing is
you're also seeing
much more aggressive countermeasures uh
on cyber offensive cyber operations
which some people were calling for
inside the white house in 2016 they were
rejected by obama but you're seeing it
now and we just had a report the other
day that the nsa had targeted the
internet research agency on the eve of
the 2018 election disrupting its ability
to do in 2018 what it did in 2016.
that's a positive as a result of what
happened in 2016. michael and just one
more positive that came from you and not
the government uh the platform companies
also have changed youtube has changed
their algorithm for rt youtube now has a
disclo disclaimer for where it comes
from twitter has cleaned up their act
facebook is doing things that all came
from public pressure
so my my plea to you very concretely
stay engaged
pay for good journalism
that is your civic duty and the other
thing because we're at the books
festival buy books uh
i and i wanna
and i just re i really wanna underscore
this point cause i'm an academic right
i'm not a journalist
uh i i'm really worried about the the
the the trends i mean they're hor you
know them about the the media the trends
for investigative books because they
take time they take money they take
these people's times to do and if you
don't buy their books they don't get to
write more books okay and in academia we
are not doing this we're we've checked
out if that and it really worries me so
you know you don't have to read the book
but you need to buy the books
can i say so say we all can i say two
words
two words
here here
over here a question from the audience
first all of you thank you for being in
tucson and thank you for following the
money
um
to follow up on your talk about
disinformation one of the concerns that
i have and with all due respect to both
michaels who do this ably
i would like to see a few fewer talking
head panels on cable news how can we
convince cable news providers to just
attribute a few hours a day to more
in-depth front line type propublica type
reporting on all of these topics which
could start to provide more information
back to those of us who are desperately
crazy
well um i think
i have to say that i am an msnbc
contributor
and i often appear on the news to
comment on the news as does everybody
else on the panel and you know the bot
you know the cable cable business is the
is the cable business
and they you know make decisions as
publishers as do uh books and publishers
of newspapers and magazines what they
think will
create the biggest audience so it's
really you know about demand if you you
know when rachel maddow often you know
comments on the news but then she does
these very in-depth
uh takes on on the news that are
basically mini documentaries and then
since she does actually real
documentaries and you know i highly
commend her ipod uh
podcast uh bagman if you haven't
listened to it yet and so i do think you
know cnn does do great investigative
work on the russia story and others so i
think all these are hybrid organizations
that do commentary but then all you know
and
that then try to break stories it's a
highly competitive environment but there
are places like propublica mother jones
and you know yahoo news and that you
know try to do these bigger pieces more
regularly and i'll just echo what uh
what mike what what mike two doors down
said um and that is
support these i can tell you when we at
mother jones when we do a good big piece
we get calls from cnn and msnbc when
mike breaks the story he gets a call too
so they are interested in amplifying
good work so the degree to which all of
you out there
to help us do this by paying for it it
will actually get on cable tv
more so
michael just to add so a full disclosure
i also work for msnbc
and i also am a columnist for the
washington post so i'm a quasi
journalist of sorts
but uh i challenge you uh when you're
watching tv
how many times do you see
professors
i because i'm a professor that's my
that's my day job and it's strikingly
how few they are and i'm not saying
academia has all the answers but but
there's so much happening in research
that does not get into the public domain
because of this connect now i have tried
through my relationships with nbc to to
push more for this and if you think the
way i do there's a there's a theory that
academics are eggheads that can't speak
on tv and nobody wants to listen to us i
don't have that personal experience i
get i just had 20 people walking over
here say i love seeing you on nbc now
that's in my world called anecdotal data
that's not called real data but i have
360 000 twitter followers too like you
know there's there is some data out
there that that suggests that actually
americans want to hear analytic stuff
and they want to hear data they don't
just want to hear opinion
and so my check
and so my homework for you all is to
press to do that you after all our
consumers make your opinions known about
that i don't think i don't think this
has been read properly and my own
personal experience
you know it was a real kind of weird
thing that they hired me uh when they
did and they they told me that by the
way we we don't have people like you
normally on um uh it's worked out i know
of a lot of people like me on very
different issues that i think would
would help the debate if they were added
to this this discussion got time for one
more question right over here thank you
and thank you all for being here this
has been magnificent
uh
it's really not surprising or disturbing
that the russians are meddling in our uh
elections we kind of expect that what is
surprising disturbing is that so many
americans fell for it enough to
influence the election
um you've talked a lot about the present
policymakers but talk about why is it
that so many americans were able to be
fooled and sucked into this and what
does that say about us well can i go
back to what i said a few moments ago
about the russian
plan to engage in hybrid warfare looking
at ways to exploit the political
divisions that already exist
in their in the countries that they see
as adversaries
so you know a lot of this is on us
our political culture has really been
torn apart and i can talk about this for
the next three hours because it's been a
process that's taken decades
and so
the
a divided society obviously is easier to
attack
and how we get to a
political cultural reset
is the challenge here you know trump's
not a problem for for you progressives
out there the problem is that 63 million
americans voted for him
and you know some voted him for very
different reasons
and some might be persuadable in the
in the form of public discourse to maybe
reconsider what they did and others will
be part of what rick wilson called
yesterday the trump cult
and i do think that you know
talking amongst your neighbors and your
family and your own contacts we all have
to figure out ways how to
have a better conversation and we need
some leadership you know from the top
and right now that's absent on the
republican side and as the democrats
campaign for the presidency in 2020
it'll be interesting to see
if any of them
try to do what
mike mcfaul's boss did in 2008. i mean
obama was you know was an out and out
liberal there was no you know question
about where he
lived ideologically
but he did talk
you know in terms of a big message of
trying to bring
the country together and it obviously
worked he won independent voters he won
over voters who might have had you know
um issues with electing a black guy
and he found a way to do it
i think we're in a much deeper hole
right now
and if i had the answer i'd be glad to
share it with you
but i think it's going to take a lot of
good thinking and a lot of patience and
generosity
for us to figure out how to
make america a society that is less
susceptible
to attacks like those
all right we are going to have to leave
it there i'm really sorry but we have
hit
our limit
huge thanks to our authors david korn
michael issachob michael mcfaul craig
unger you can catch up with them outside
the u of a bookstore tent on the mall
and uh let's clear out so we can get our
next panel set up thank you all so much
spanshop.org
good evening everybody and welcome my
name is sabir and i run events here at
the strand
before we launch into a discussion of
craig unger's newest title american
compromise i'd like to share a little
bit of history about the strand
the train was founded in 1927 by
benjamin bass over on fourth avenue's
book row stretching from union square to
aster place book road gradually dwindle
from 48 book stores until after 94 years
the strand is a soul survivor
now run by third generation owner nancy
vass whiten
we want to thank all of you for your
support without our loyal community of
book lovers we wouldn't be here today
and we are so appreciative of it
so tonight we are thrilled to have with
us craig unger and yuri spence for the
launch of craig's newest book american
compromise
greg unger is the author of six books
including the new york times bestsellers
house of trump house of putin and house
of bush house of zod for 15 years he was
a contributing editor for vanity fair
where he covered national security the
middle east and other political issues
a frequent analyst on msnbc and other
broadcast outlets he was a longtime
staffer in new york magazine
has served as editor-in-chief of boston
magazine and has contributed to esquire
the new yorker and many other
publications
under has written about the trump-russia
scandal for the new republic vanity fair
and the washington post
he's a graduate of harvard university
and lives in brooklyn new york
yuri schwetz was a major in the edb
during the years 1980 through 1990
from april 1985 to 1987 he worked in the
dc residentiura the pgu kgb sssr
rex has long been a vocal critic of
vladimir putin with whom he was a
college mate at the academy of the kgb
foreign intelligence
since 1998 schwetz has been doing
private business security investigations
in the former soviet union for american
and british businesses
including major banks hedge funds world
top airspace and international oil
companies
in 2020 he consulted with the committee
on banking and financial services the
united states house of representatives
on russian intelligence activities and
money laundering in the u.s
in 1995 he published washington station
my life as a kgb spy in america
joining craig and urian conversation is
scott horton
scott is a human rights advocate best
known for his representation of russian
physicist and nobel laureate andrei
sakharov
as well as other figures in the russian
democracy and human rights movement
he is also a lecturer at columbia
university law school and a contributing
editor at harper's magazine where he
writes on legal and national security
affairs he has authored several books
including the lords of secrecy the
national security elite and america's
stealth warfare and private security
contractors at war
a study of the modern use of mercenaries
he is also a member of the board of the
national institute of military justice
andrei sakharov foundation and the
american branch of the international law
association
and so without further ado please join
me in welcoming craig scott and yuri to
the stage
brand has as a bookstore as a unique
position
uh in new york and in the united states
it's just uh
it's miles and miles of books
um are something that captivated me when
i first came to new york in 1980
and i can't even begin to told the
number of hours i've spent meandering
them and buying far more books than uh
than i than any um
intelligent person would ever buy
but i've benefited from it a lot over
the years and i'm
really delighted to see the strand as a
survivor and also really pleased to see
it expand into
into this area so without any more i'd
like to go straight into the book we
have um craig unger
noted uh author uh and we have um a key
uh subject of the book as well a a
person whose interviews
uh go
right to the heart of it
and i think i'd just like to to launch
right off
um
with a question that is perhaps teed up
by one of the recent uh reviews of the
book the one written by john cipher and
published in the washington post about a
week ago
in which he has i
as best i can see really nothing
critical or no questions uh to raise
about about any of the accounts that are
furnished in the book more to the
contrary he sees them all as
almost obvious things
um with it with a few uh which are very
uh
cleverly uh presented in the raid but i
think he he at the end raises this issue
of you've given us a
an excellent compilation
of what has been reported previously
on these subjects
but
what here is new what what is something
that really justifies the purchase of a
new book so craig that that one's for
you
right well uh it's interesting that john
cipher who of course was a long-time
former cia agent
ask that question because what's new is
this is the first detailed narrative of
how the kgb cultivated donald trump
and when you look over all the incidents
i report it's true many of them have
been mentioned before
but that key fact has been omitted again
and again and again
and the the narrative starts mostly in
1980 when you see trump buying hundreds
of tv sets from a
electronic store owned by soviet
immigrants that much has been reported
before what's new
is that the owner
was according to yuri uh
a so-called uh spotter agent for the kgb
and in selling those tv sets he was sort
of opening the door to potentially
recruit donald trump as an asset for the
kgb and that kind of thing goes through
the entire narrative you see again when
when trump is being invited
uh to what is then the soviet union to
moscow uh that's been reported before
what hasn't been reported is how the
people who are doing that are tied to
the kgb that one of them worked uh in
the united nations library that that was
a place uh where uh the kgb uh reserved
special spots for kgb agents
um that when they got there when when
trump finally got to the soviet union uh
he was being force-fed against through
yuri and i've been able to corroborate a
lot of this through other sources but he
was being force-fed talking points that
were published in the new york times the
washington post and the boston globe and
they sort of inflated trump's ego and
made him think he was i mean this is
kind of ridiculous if we
knowing donald trump as we know him he
was in a a playboy phase as we all all
know back then in the mid 80s it was in
87 that he finally met jeffrey epstein
they had parties with 28 girls and two
guys and suddenly during the same period
trump is presenting himself as this
expert on foreign policy that he's so
interested in arcane issues like uh
soviet relationship to japan that he
takes ads out in newspapers
uh that i think believe i believe gives
a whole new dimension to to uh
things like the ad that he took out
during that period which of course as
yuri will tell you um
was really uh yuri was back in russia in
that in september of 1987
and uh he got uh
an internal memo saying that this was
really an active measure by a new asset
and it included the ad i just mentioned
which was signed by donald trump so that
you see that throughout the entire book
well so let's go straight to yuri i mean
you know let me let me just start by
asking
um
what
uh what is it about donald trump
that would have been so interesting so
appealing uh to russian intelligence
back in the 1980s i mean after all he's
just a real estate developer in in new
york not at that point even a
particularly high profile one you know
based in queens
um the glamour days were coming a little
bit later i think so what was it about
him that really would have attracted and
then how do we make the link from the
hypothetical that he would have been
of interest to them to
the conclusion that he was and he was
recruited efforts were made to recruit
him what are the specific signs you see
that show that
well uh first i would like to add some
words to the previous question because i
believe it's very important
i'm surprised by this opinion that it's
just compilation of everything which has
been in the public domain
in fact i haven't seen
anything in public domain before this
book
which would show
exact
connection involvement of the russian
intelligence community
with trump donald trump
were opinions they were speculations but
they haven't been a single fact i
haven't seen a single name of a kgb guy
or fsb guy i haven't seen any detailed
factual account of how it happened so
this book basically
it is
a
case file professional case file on how
it actually happened how donald trump
was spotted by the russian by the kgb
intelligence how he was cultivated or
developed as they say in the kgb
and how it all
culminated in what
we had in 2016 when he was the election
elected the president so everything
which
relates to donald trump and his
relations with the russian intelligence
in this book is new at least for me uh
why he drew attention
uh we need to remember that it was
the time of the cold war
it was the last
the biggest splash of the cold war
and at that time to recruit an american
citizen as an agent it was like for a
regular pilot to fly to the moon and
return back
it was considered almost a mission
impossible
and our biggest chief at the time was
saying that recruits me any american
and we will find a way to use it
forever to use him or her for our
advantage
[Music]
on the other hand
we had
i mean the soviet union
and the kgb intelligence had had by that
time
a very good
but elderly asset his name was herman
hammer
a billionaire which had been used by the
kgb and the kremlin
and their assets since the days of the
bolshevik revolution he met wedding
merlin
he did a lot of good things
for the kremlin but
by
the 80s he was in his 90.
he was pretty old he needed the kgb
needed a replacement
so donald trump from this perspective
was a very good candidate to replace
armond hammer as powerman
in the higher level business cycles of
the united states which by itself was
viewed as important
uh segments of penetration for the kgb
intelligence
[Music]
third consideration was that
he had set a certain characteristics
which
led kgb to believe
that he has a good future
um i would remind you that uh
[Music]
in in the kgb in their history they had
a very good case
when in the 1930s they
recruited in
cambridge a group of students
which later became known as cambridge 5
who later
in the 40s and 50s became very prominent
individuals in the british intelligence
service and the british foreign office
and provided a wealth of information so
the kgb
was and is
its successors uh very patient and they
very
and they like to work on the so-called
perspective agent meaning they recruit a
developer today
and then
several years later you have a president
elect
and this is exactly what happened
um
i i i have another question that comes
from a um
a very well-known former
cia
officer
uh milt burden
with whom i chatted
briefly about your book
and
and his immediate reaction was to say
that
at some point in the near future
there'll be a walk-in
in a cia
station somewhere in the world maybe
mexico or maybe some city in europe or
africa
and a
a russian agent
seeking to defect and looking for an
american passport
maybe a condo and veil
and a lot of money
we'll say he has the file
that documents this entire relationship
and he has a list of demands for it
starting with a big cash
request
and so i'd like to ask you to think you
know
do you see that as a
as a possibility in the future and and
if something like that happens you know
how would
a uh cia station chief have to react to
something like that
is that premier or you're
i think it's for both of you but maybe
you want to go first craig so all right
well well i think there are parts of it
yuri is better equipped to answer but i
i think um
uh
you know one of the most horrifying
things about this is there's been no
counterintelligence investigation and i
think that's extraordinary so i think we
have to get to the bottom of this or it
will happen again
uh there's no question that trump's
power has plundered him and he's no
longer nearly as important uh to russia
as he was as a weapon so it's quite
possible that at some point in the
future and i don't know when that would
be
uh
that uh someone might feel free to open
it but i don't think it's in the
immediate future but again i defer to
yuri
uh
who
but what what do you think specifically
it's worth to the united states why
would the us be showing out millions of
dollars now that trump is a retiree
what's the value well i think when you
look over what happened with trump uh
again it has not been investigated and
if we don't investigate it it will
happen again and if you read my book you
can go to various points where there
all sorts of things that that uh opened
the door for what was initially a very
banal
transaction buying television sets that
sort of morphed over time over 40 years
into
the biggest most powerful uh
intelligence operation perhaps in
history
so what how and why did that happen and
you we have to examine it if we're going
to prevent it again
yuri
yes scott uh you asked a very
complicated question there are several
questions which may take hours in uh
kgb or svr
uh
we don't have an hour
all right so i'll be i'll i'll try to be
concise first
uh
yes i believe they will be
individuals
on the russian side who
i believe within the next several months
i even
said the timeline would work in
somewhere
into the u.s government institution and
offer some intelligence information
possibly related to donald trump
why sarah sayso because there is a
transition of power in moscow right now
from putin who is losing it
to
his potential successors
and unfortunately potential successors
are the fsb
led by nikolai patricia
these guys are terrorists actually this
is the same guys who blew up
buildings in moscow in 99 to bring putin
to power
uh they were the ones who poisoned
lithuania in london then skripal's
family is in
salisbury recently police navalny in
russia so these are monsters but
as the history shows us
succession of power in moscow
usually leads to leakage of sensitive
intelligence information because
different factions
they need to get in touch with
appropriate agencies of the us
government for different reasons
and for this they offer information
so i expect that within and i'm getting
actually signals which i treat as
reliable as serious that within the
uh
few months
the offer for intelligence information
will be coming
second aspect of this question is this
um
burden
suggests that
it may be a good idea just to sit tight
at the embassy and wait for what we call
walk in
or volunteer who recruited himself and
then comes as a gift to the embassy like
aldrich aims came to the soviet embassy
and says guys
i'm yours
i need money i have secrets let's let's
what you know
i call this walkings a miracle
because it's not a product of work of
this station intelligence station
miracle can happen tomorrow or it can
happen 25 years from now and if we sit
and wait for the miracle to happen we'll
definitely have another 911
and
we may have an onslaught and non-stop
penetration of hostile intelligence
services into the united states
so
i believe another strategy is much
better proactive strategy so we better
get out of the embassy go into the
street we look for information we
recruit agents we
guaranteed bit of information then
connect the dots
and this way we can in advance
understand
what the bad guys are preparing for us
uh so i would in brief i would answer
this way
so so craig and yuri have more or less
the same response here which is that we
shouldn't sit back and wait for it but
we should be going after to unravel
everything and complete a
counterintelligence
uh investigation
um
well
it seems to me that um
whenever anyone
unravels or exposes
a major
intelligence operation the pushback and
this is probably true just about
anywhere in the world and with any
intelligence operation the pushback is
pretty much always uh to point a finger
at the people who are doing the exposing
and accuse them of being tin hatted
lunatics
conspiracy theorists
so so i'll just put that on the table
for you so
you know this is um
this is conspiracy theory squared so
it's not only all of this you know
uh russian manchurian candidate
stuff
uh that attorney general barr told us
had been totally debunked and trump
himself has
thousands of times said it's debunked
it's not true it's crazy uh it's also
we've also folded in opus dei you know
another uh another
sort of conspiracy theory that um that's
propelled uh hollywood to any number of
feature motion pictures uh but you know
there's very very little about it that
can actually be documented so you know
so how do you respond to that so craig
you're up first okay well well i think
if you look at all the con i mean
there's a lot of talk of conspiracy
theorists and all that and i i think
everything is a mirror image of what
it's criticizing so in in fact you you
do have if you look at the epstein
scandal the jeffrey epstein scandal you
do have pedophiles you do have
horrifying pedophilia and sex traffic
and all that but it's reflected
uh when you see people like marjorie
[Music]
taylor green
and various other right-wing
nuts i think saying that they're satanic
pedophiles in the basement of the comet
pizza place in washington uh you you see
that kind of thing going on and on it
from the right uh the conspiracies that
really took place the corruption is
mind-boggling beyond belief uh you you
look at the leon black case uh where he
paid 158 million dollars this is
according to the new york times uh to
jeffrey epstein and for what uh for tax
advice i don't think so um
you know there had to be compromise in
that at
in one way or another and i think that's
an element you see running through all
this that you see you do see compromise
factories these are
compromided forces compromising material
and it's a bit like extortion of
blackmail it's being held over people so
there's a lot of that going on and when
you you investigate the whole
uh spectrum it is sort of remarkable i
mean when i was talking
uh to yuri he identified trump as a as a
special unofficial contact and when you
look at other people who've held that
that kind of been in that kind of
category it's not just armored hammer
it's people like robert maxwell who's
glenn maxwell's father
um and so there's an awful lot going on
in a very very dark world there are
trillions and trillions of dollars in
dark money
uh that that are being laundered and put
back in our economy much of it from
russia from uh from the middle east as
well in china
um
so it's it's a period of just
extraordinary corruption and you know
conspiracies is really i think i mean
you're the lawyer but it's more than one
person committing a crime really and
working together and that does happen
um that's exactly right and of course
you know we we some conspiracies in fact
occur
regularly they get regularly charged in
in criminal cases um the problem here is
uh is the issue of proof uh that of
course a um
a professionally managed
active measures campaign involves lots
of people who have been trained
professionally for years to avoid
leaving a trail with the sort of
evidence that can be used for legal
levels of proof yuri am i right
yeah absolutely the first requirement a
requirement of any intelligent
separation is confidentiality
or conspiracy conspiracy this is how
they call it in in russia so this is the
biggest requirement not to leave any
traces
and
until recently until putin they had been
pretty good at this
so if you sit and wait until
bullet-proof bulletproof evidence
which you can take to the court
you lose this game you need to to to
look for tick bits of information
you can get
and then you have to analyze it and it's
by the way i can tell you the analysis
analysis of case file of information
when i was trained in this uh
intelligence academy
we were trained 24
24 7 basically um there we lived
in the outskirts in the woods of moscow
and
we had most of the time
for
uh
for for training in foreign languages
uh
after the foreign language
the most time was spent on uh
analysis
we had a crowd in our group for instance
about 18 guys and most of them could
perfectly make a dead drop load the drop
unload that drop detect surveillance
uh avoid surveillance but just two guys
had excellent on analysis
so it's a hard real job but you should
know this
uh in order to do the analysis now just
a few words about uh conspiracy theories
with respect to this book
um
what i
what we did on trump kgb connection was
uh craig
it's not an article it's not a religious
text which you believe or you don't
believe
uh
i produced a professional
k analysis of a case file
craig presented this in a language which
would be interesting to read for readers
not a bureaucratic language it was
originally written by me
so
it requires to know each intelligence
agency had its own modest apparent die
and analysis this particular analysis is
based on inside knowledge of this modest
operandi because i was there at that
time
i was involved in a portable operation
of
basically identical
so
it requires a certain knowledge of
professional detail and i'm ready to sit
down with any professional
in this field intelligence county
intelligence service
officer and to go
paragraph by paragraph sentence by
sentence of the story of trump kgb
relations and try to disapprove
not just say i don't believe it tell me
where
tell me what you don't believe and i
will explain
well let's go let's just let's start by
uh assuming it's right uh that that
you've um you've exposed an operation an
active measures operation that was
maintained for a period of 40 years or a
little less than 40 years perhaps
with an individual who
becomes politically prominent
and rises ultimately to be president of
the united states
and then you continue to exercise at
least some measure of influence over him
during his presidency and thereafter
things going on afterwards
so i put it to you that this is
the most successful
russian intelligence operation of all
time is that right
i i well
i'm not an expert on russia but i think
the the flip side of it is that its most
serious national security failure uh
perhaps it's a civil war in the united
states since john will
wilkes booth
yuri you're the you're the intel the
russian intelligence professional yes
anything you can think of that's better
than this
uh it is the big biggest success in
history but there is a caveat because
it wasn't the result of a well-planned
operation they had been conducted for 40
years
they were just working the guy
working the operation and then
the stars the stars angled in a special
way and it just happened
so it happened sometimes it was a fluke
just a streak of good luck for them
i believe that they realized that this
candidate donald trump
has a reasonable chance to be to become
the next president of the united states
somewhere at the end
of march or early april
2016.
before that
no one in moscow
had any calls
in
this department
and
when they realized they threw the entire
capability everything they had
to help him
they
introduced into the operation the agents
which had been operational in the united
states in the early 70s
serious
very good uh
camouflaged people
um
and unfortunately unfortunately for them
for the russians when they
uh started working on this in full gear
this is where they expose themselves by
the way it is interesting maybe it would
be interesting to listen as to know that
the whole russian
meddling into 2016 uh presidential
campaign in the united states it was
from the kgb point of view
madness
i remember when i just joined the
department number one which was american
department
uh my first boss who had
in total about eight years
uh of posting
in the united states very experienced
gentleman
he told me that you know what we have
capability to intervene and to influence
to some extent presidential elections in
the united states but we're not going
we're not going to do that
because if you do this kind of operation
it should be absolutely confidential
which is very hard no one would wish
that it would be absolutely confidential
but if we fail
and americans will notice that
we are involved
the negative ramification of this
failure will be
just
horrendous for our country and this is
exactly what happened for kremlin
after donald trump was elected the
president but the exposure of his
connection with russia just put them in
the corner and he couldn't help russian
to the extent they they they expected
this to happen
well um so let's let's switch to uh to
uh a different subject so it seems to me
you know reading over this book as a
whole
um it's a tapestry
um and there um there are many different
um yarns that flow through it so you
know certainly the principle one is
um russian intelligence the russian
intelligence
recruitment operation and the active
measures um another is which i was
rather surprising to me is opus dei
figuring in a very very prominent way
another is bill barr and all the
kirkland and ellis
lawyers who seem to heavily populate
this um
past presidency the trump presidency and
another is jeffrey epstein and all of
his doings um in which you offer um uh
analysis that i think many many people
before have hinted that but you i think
go quite a bit further and suggesting
the linkage between these activities and
those of
um
of intelligence services but let's just
step back to you know these main two
strands of opus dei and russian
intelligence so
why would
opus dei
not expose a russian intelligence
operation
if they knew about it if they'd learned
about it why would they allow it to go
forward uh unexposed that's i think
puzzling
to most people who look at it
well i think the most obvious answer is
power
uh opus dei is an exceedingly weird
mysterious group and it goes its roots
go back to fascist spain
and it's very authoritarian in nature uh
i kept trying to find uh
you know exactly i were there links
between opus dei and russia and no i
couldn't find a single one what i could
find is that they uh attached themselves
to uh william barr
very early on he was uh
on the board of directors of the
catholic information center which is the
operational headquarters of focus day in
washington he says he's not in opus dei
they say he's not an open state but the
truth is it's a secret society and the
nature of a secret society is it's
secret so you really don't know and they
do lie at times and they have a doctrine
of um
uh forgive me the
where they can rationalize almost
anything to the point of lying
um and you see this small group of
people the even the board of the
catholic information center uh was
centered near the fbi uh robert hansen
was in
the great the the spy russian spy
uh who worked who was with the fbi was
in opus dei
his brother-in-law happened to be the
chief speechwriter for william barr
when he was attorney general the first
time around under president george h.w
bush and you see them also allied with
members of the uh federalist society
which of course is this uh large much
larger uh deeply conservative
group uh one of the key people there is
leonard leo
and uh who has uh vetted i believe the
last six republican supreme court
justices so they have enormous clout
there and they want uh
they want those judges they they want to
wipe out roe v wade uh it's an ex you
know and they've essentially taken
enormous power throughout the judiciary
it also happens to overlap oddly enough
with as you say law firms like uh
kirkland and ellis an immensely rich uh
law firm
which happens to represent a lot of
roads and oligarchs and there's big
money coming in from them uh and they
end up in a lot of those attorneys ended
up in bill barr's uh justice department
so there was this great accumulation of
power
and uh i think there is sort of a shared
ideology between
the theology of opus dei which is very
very authoritarian and the kind of
imperial presidency that uh
william barr advocated and used to
enable donald trump to become
almost dictatorial and and that's sort
of the direction i see things going in
so yuri let me flip it around a little
bit for you i mean and ask you know how
would russian intelligence view a group
like opus dei i mean russian
intelligence of course has
well-documented relations with the
russian orthodox church that's been sort
of a a key part of operations for a very
long period of time
on the other hand you know it's had
quite a bit of hostility towards many
other uh religious groups and the
catholic church in particular i think
has been suspect and the subject of
repression um and the certainly in the
communist period that was that was the
case so how do you understand this
relationship
uh between fsb the the foreign service
kgb and opus day
uh well
i don't i know
this is this is attitude rather than
relationships
which was surprising for me but i can
explain something here
it was especially evident under putin
under his administration people in
moscow and kremlin they're prone to
conspiracy series
they like everything secretly
and they
believe in theories which are close to
what q anon is distributing they believe
that there is some kind of cabal
somewhere out there
a group of powerful people which
who pull the string
and make the world work it work and
they're plotting against russia they
want to destroy mother russia
and sometimes they generate this series
and then
they start believing because this series
goes through mass media et cetera give
you an exam one example on in yeltsin's
administration in kremlin there was a
guy he was two star fsb general his name
was rogozin
he was involved in some kind of para
psychology
and he generated an idea that
america wants to take over siberia
because of envy that there are so many
natural resources there
uh he was a question how did you know
that he said that you know madeleine
albright
the secretary of state of the united
states at the time
we penetrated into her mind and what we
saw there in her mind was hatred towards
russia
and the desire to take over siberia this
is what these crazy guys really believe
and you know what right now
in you can you can very often run onto
this uh
story in the russian social media
networks there is no reference to
regarding anymore this story leads by
itself this is the fact already that
madeleine albright wanted to take over
siberia so this explains why they're
interested in different in everything
that seems or is secret
and has this cloud of you know
exclusivity
so i can explain just
by this but during the time of the kgb
this series was just of the wall we had
strict so-called objective or principle
of penetration based on
objects
object meaning uh
government institutions pentagon white
house
uh cia fba etc
these are the main objects and then
intermediary objects such as think tanks
law firms lobbying firms etc but they
were no opposed day or some biddelberg
clap which you know which which
they're very uh concerned with right now
in russia in in moscow yeah but i i
think we've got just a few minutes left
so i think though the last subject i've
got to toss out to you has got to be
jeffrey epstein right we haven't quite
gotten to any discussion of him um
although he winds up being almost in the
exact center of the book um and some of
the really most remarkable chapters so
what are the ties here between epstein
and professional intelligence services
russian intelligence
and trump uh you know
what what unites all these things how
are they tied together well to me what i
saw on that scene you know most people
write about him as running a a sex
trafficking ring which of course is true
but it was also a compromise factory and
i look for his links to various
intelligence sources and uh
uh i had one israeli uh agent tell me he
saw
uh uh
epstein with robert maxwell in london in
maxwell's office and maxwell himself is
glenn maxwell's father the uh the great
british press baron who who had enormous
intelligence ties to you very close to
general kurzkov who is head of the kgb
uh so there are certainly questions
about that and you see it throughout the
whole epstein operation
i interviewed among other people
a man named john mark dugan who is a
deputy sheriff in palm beach county
while epstein was being investigated and
i tracked him down in moscow uh
john mark dugan to me reminded me of a
guy from a refugee from an elmore
leonard
uh novel and uh he had been given he
told me 478 files
of
478 dvds
of apparent sexual activities because
epstein had cameras in all these rooms
in his various residences where he was
um
uh taping sec uh people
you know that he was collecting the
dirty little secrets of the richest and
most powerful people in the world but
what does this have to do with trump
that's that's that's the the part we
haven't yet crossed well epstein and
trump were good good friends for 15
years
um and it started around 1987 that
friendship uh it their friendship blew
up uh in the early 2000s and it was
over this famous palm beach mansion that
epstein very much wanted to buy and that
uh uh donald trump
after consulting with it scooped it out
from under his nose
and then flipped it he sold it for
double the price
to the russian oligarch rebelove
so that ended their friendship and uh
not long afterwards epstein was showing
around photos of donald trump
with a couple of uh young women or girls
i don't know their age uh but what's
your specific evidence for that
uh
yeah i talked this was a uh off the
record a background
source who said he saw it
uh is it
it's not fully conclusive but but you
could see uh trump turned on epstein
very very much after this period
so yuri um why would this be of interest
to to moscow to russian intelligence
oh
um well this story deserves a separate
book
written by mike craig
because what we have here is two
unprecedented since world war ii events
first honey trap
the kgb use honey traps but mostly
domestically they never
on very rare occasions they used it
uh
outside of the soviet union by honey
trip they they
they met
beautiful ladies which seduced
[Music]
high level officials generals
scientists etc
now uh
they
use it massively in western europe and
in the united states and they use it in
the biggest after the end of a world war
ii operation russian intelligence
operation
in the years of last years of war for
world war ii the russians were stealing
a bomb in the united states now there
after
artificial intelligence and so-called
supercomputer
uh there is obsession in the kremlin
that who is the first
to
artificial intelligence will run the
world
and this is where this operation comes
comes in
uh it is massive it involves hundreds if
not thousands of people
russian agents operating in this country
and what craig describes is just a tiny
bit tiny example of this
so so now we're going to turn the floor
back over to severe to moderate uh q a
session
i'm sorry to interrupt that a
fascinating conversation but i think we
have
a good question to pivot off of yuri's
answer to start with
which is from james who asks is the
trump case unique have there been any
similar fsu slash su
deep penetration of politics or
corporations
operations in any other key western
countries since 1980
well if this is a question for me
i've been working on the united states
and my focus was always on on the united
states uh my knowledge about perform for
russian penetration in western europe is
is professional but it's pretty much
peripheral
i've been doing business security
investigations which
brought me some information showing that
the russians
over the last about 10 years
have
unprecedented penetration into the uk
in political and business cycles of the
uk
they have business they have big success
in penetrating in germany and in france
right i would just uh like to add
something i mean i i would add the
entire republican party if you look at
it i mean it it and it happens in many
different ways
many of which happen to be legal that is
uh
you know if a new coal mine appears in
kentucky and it's tied to oleg garapaska
well
he of course is an oligarch who is very
very close to vladimir putin and that's
why uh mitch mcconnell is sometimes
called moscow mitch and if you look at
uh some of the campaign contributions uh
the republican senatorial campaign uh
committee gets lots of money from lenin
blavatnik who's a naturalized american
uh so it's perfectly illegal but he's
also a russian oligarch and uh
i've written about this in two books and
it's just incredibly widespread now uh
throughout the republican party and i
think that's why we see a lot of the
craziness uh as to what it's become it's
very much like the party of regions in
ukraine which is essentially a political
party for vladimir putin
that actually helped answer a few other
questions which revolved around the
republican party's represent
repre well excuse me the republican
party's relationship
with
the
russian compromise right i mean it's
astonishing to me i i grew up in dallas
and the republic you could not be more
right-wing and anti-communist
than uh the people i grew up with and to
see the same political party uh turning
a blind eye to all this is just
extraordinary
and our next question is someone playing
devil's advocate who asks
how has russia directly benefited
from having trump as an agent if it
didn't
if it did so
isn't it actually much worse off its
economy is stagnant tech base is
declining
capital flight has soared we are seeing
massive protests
putin is widely reviled nato is reviving
and sanctions are spreading
across the movement
right well i mean if you look do you
want to
go ahead
well i will i will
uh trump has done for the republicans
it's just enormous
and uh putin wanted to put
was constantly saying american democracy
is corrupt well now at least 70 million
trump supporters absolutely believe that
and they believe the presidential
election was stolen and i think
relatively speaking the united states is
much weaker that may not address uh all
the questions
your your uh
the uh other person raised
but uh
the damage to the west has been
absolutely enormous and it's gonna take
us quite a while to recover
um the problem with this operation is
that the russians the putin's secret
services they blew it
as i explained earlier to previous
questions when they started massively
uh helping uh trump to be to become real
elected they exposed his connections
with moscow and they basically by doing
so they put him in the corner they
everybody slightly talking that he's
connected to russia this is putin puppet
and
he could not do in this situation he
couldn't do as much as he could have
been done if it was secret you know so
russians exposed him and neutralized his
capability to help
to help them
more efficiently but he did help he
helped a lot what he did
he put on hold many of uh initiatives
uh
basically most of them were initiated by
the u.s house
the laws about different sanctions
imposed on russia on different uh
over the previous four years
most of them
were
put on hold or made less effective than
they could could have been so i mean the
putin finally
he got the result of his fail
by exposing trump
but on the other hand there was
something something which
helped russians to make these sanctions
less painful
and
less damaging to the russian economy
because you know the analysts in russia
they say that if all sanctions which are
embedded into law passed laws
passed over the last four years had all
of them been implemented russian economy
would have been dead by now
i just add a couple of things here too i
mean it seems to me that there are two
areas
where trump made a huge difference for
russia
that were advantageous to russia not at
all advantageous to the united states
the first of them is oil and gas so
trump reversed course on a series of
policies aiming at energy
diversification in order to double down
on fossil fuels
and that's not remotely beneficial to
the united states i mean maybe west
virginia a little bit but that's hugely
beneficial to russia
because the russian economy really is a
fossil fuels economy they needed those
experts that's that's the key uh to
their economic development because putin
failed to do diversification and the
second thing is nato
so trump from from the 80s doing as much
damage to nato as possible was always a
high priority for russia and russian
intelligence that's the this newspaper
ad that
that craig mentioned and yuri talked
about before that was all targeting nato
and nato operations and trump from the
instant he came in was doing everything
he could possibly do alone to undermine
the sound governance and coordination of
strategy that are the principal purposes
of nato he weakened it so those are just
two things
yeah and the russian reactions when he
was elected the president it was evident
it was decession of the russian duma
russian parliament was interrupted
when
one deputy
he was beaming with joy and pride
announced ladies and gentlemen donald
trump is elected the president of the
united states right now he's addressing
the nation and it was standing ovation
it was like they won the war
and then a couple days later one deputy
shows up it was on youtube
he is raising the toast saying that
america is ours
without a single shot this is what it
means aggressive and professional
foreign policy of president putin
and this
message was spread by the kremlin's
propaganda
over entire russian population and the
idea that our guy
recruited and
is the handler of this guy who was
who was always the big guy you know
right and now our guy is the master and
this one is center it's supported to put
his popularity you know
it was
it was a real big achievement for his
for his pride and even for his
popularity in the population
and i think all of this is a war of
sorts and it's a war
a new kind of war without bombs or
bullets or boots on the ground but it's
cyber warfare it's a war on truth it's a
war of using corruption as weapons it's
a war of looking at all the loopholes in
the american system whether it's
campaign finance corruption through
campaign financing uh through big rich
white shoe lawyers uh
and all sorts of things and no
i mean that's why i i keep saying it's
so important to have a real
counterintelligence investigation to get
to the bottom of how all this happened
so unfortunately we only have time for
one more question and to make things
easy i'm going to ask a meaty one to end
which
essentially uh reads
how do we
understand the communication between
russia the kremlin and trump
is it a matter of ideological alignment
or is there a consistent thread of
communication through secondary figures
within trump's ordinance
well i don't think we have all the
answers to this and when it gets to the
subject of compromise i think one thing
is pretty clear is if you look at all
the conversations between uh trump and
putin the russians have them and we
don't
and and we really need that and that's
one thing they can hold over him um i i
don't think there needs to be a constant
back and forth and then in a lot of ways
the way this materialized was sort of uh
you scratch my back i'll scratch yours
and creating a favorite back and forth
and and you can see what trump got out
of it uh very early on when i mean if
you go back to 1984 he had begun
effectively allowing trump real estate
to launder money millions and millions
of dollars uh for the russian mafia and
i found 13
uh russians who were either mobsters or
had uh intelligence ties
either owning or living in trump tower
and from properties that's a lot of
mobsters i think um
but if there were other secret
communications well if they're secret i
don't know all the secrets
i i agree i mean it seems it seems to me
that you know what we don't know is is
quite alarming
you know
remember the very first days of the
administration when trump came in there
was a lot of talk that we learned about
later about establishing a back channel
of communication not using
white house secure coms and things of
that sort uh to allow to facilitate this
sort of communication you know what the
hell is all that about and what
communications actually occurred you
know we still don't know many details um
and i guess i've talked to people um on
the
uh national security staff uh in the
trump administration who have told me
repeatedly that you know one thing that
really alarmed them was that they would
discover
that uh trump had communications with
putin directly and it wasn't a scheduled
call it was nothing they knew about and
people in the white house learned about
these calls when they appeared on a
readout from the kremlin
which is pretty bizarre
so this was going on all the time sort
of violation of all the protocols and
that's not even getting into you know
meetings at the g7 uh where uh where uh
uh trump walked over to putin's table uh
and sat down and had a conversation with
him without even his own translators so
putin's translator did the translation i
mean i challenge you to show me any
other case where an american president
did things like this i mean they're good
reasons why they wouldn't so there are
loads of unanswered questions on this
comms issue i think
i'll give another example that happened
just before
trump was elected in october of 2016
donald trump jr gave a speech in paris
at a french think tank uh and and uh it
happens you know he was paid fifty
thousand dollars plus all that's
perfectly legal of course what was
unusual is the french think tank is
widely said to be uh
a front for russian intelligence and he
was passed a talking point donald trump
funerals past talking points on
uh
what policy the russians wanted trump to
carry out in the middle east once he he
got
uh got into office and sure enough trump
did exactly what they wanted when he
pulled troops out of syria abandoned our
kurdish allies and left the russians in
charge of it now all of that was
perfectly legal every little step of it
was legal but it was part of a larger
intelligence operation
actually he was not donald trump was not
micromanaged he was micromanaged and he
got the assignment after
uh during his first trip to moscow 1987
and actually he published this
assignment in three major american
newspapers upon his return from moscow
he published his view on world affairs
in washington post new york times boston
globe and the idea was we need to
unravel we need to
break all our national security
agreements with our traditional allies
uh to help with nato we'll get together
with russia and we too
will run will rule the world so it's
bipolar
world this is what russia has been
looking for for decades and that's what
he's been doing
when specific questions arises obviously
he was not doing this for for for for
the idea for ideology i believe it was
forced his ego
his vanity
and
money and money
when
the necessary necessity
arise for specific
issues to solve he had a line of
communication i'll i will outline you
just one he has rudy giuliani you can
tell what he needs to know to rudy
giuliani rudy giuliani goes to him where
he communicates with two higher level
russian intelligent
intelligence agents he tells them what
is required what the boss
wants these guys they take private jets
they fly to moscow and they communicate
this to the fsb to put it and then it
goes backwards channels they have
channeled communication
and then openness openness in
intelligence sometimes is the best cover
for
uh intelligence espionage activities and
this is exactly what scott's prescribed
just now when they communicated
in unusual circumstances
breaking all
possible protocols which existed
on that note i want to thank all three
of you craig yuri and scott for a
disturbing but like interesting
conversation
uh
on that note to our audience thank you
so much for joining us this evening if
you have yet to purchase a copy of
american compromise there is a helpful
green button which says purchase in the
center of your screen you can click on
and uh to everyone thank you and good
night
thank you good night thank you thank you
and good night
you're watching book tv on cspan2
every weekend with the latest